good morning ladies and gentlemen it is
now uh 10 o'clock i'd like to
call the hearings together i'd like to
begin with the
um
pledge of allegiance please
representative gay can you start us
of the united states
i see here that i have many
pink cards already so if you do want to
speak if you do want to come up to the
table
you have to submit a pink card
and with that i will call the sponsor of
the
first bill on our agenda which is house
bill
the establishing a committee to study
the new hampshire family court system
and with that i'll call the prime
sponsor
representative betty gay
thank you very much
i have allergies and that's from eating
something with soy or milk in it
i've just passed out an amendment ols i
owe them big
um it dawned on me when i was talking
with other attorneys
who are reps and people who are affected
by family court but if we open in a
commission we already have professional
commissions
but we don't have one that's primarily
the people who are affected by
by the family court so the amendment
simply changes the members of the
commission to
form house members to senate members but
they're volunteers they're people who
are really interested they're not going
to be hand-picked according to this by
the speaker or the president because
that's really hard they've already had
to staff many commissions and they may
as well just ask for volunteers who are
really interested in the subject
we ask for two domestic violence
counselors
five new hampshire citizens who've been
involved in family court an attorney
who's part of domestic violence
emergency project the dove project
attorneys who have experience in family
court
certified mental health therapists
so that's that's the change
i don't have to tell you that we have
issues with the family court most people
have been involved or have family
so i will just uh now
yield floor to
people who would like to testify
um representative gay can you do a pink
card please i will thank you thank you
oh can i add
i've also passed out the yellow sheets
which uh is written by barry goldstein
who's very famous
attorney who process
represents victims of domestic abuse and
i thought this was the most interesting
thing
on
the website
it's 12 misconceptions about domestic
abuse that were set in the 70s and the
courts haven't changed and there's been
a lot of research since then so this
addresses
these 12 rare events that unfortunately
the courts think are standard
then the pink
the pink is a
testimony from a woman who spent
seven years in family court
and
she would you believe today
is when her parents
house
contents are being delivered to her
so she couldn't come
so she spent a lot of effort all her
testimony she she sent testimony very
short testimony on several bills so i
printed them all on pink
so you can see it she's also kind of at
risk because she's still in the court
system to say anything critical
so that's why her name's not on here
so thank you for reading it it's really
heartfelt and she's very intelligent
compassionate person
thank you
the next pink card i have is
representative sue
hanola
oh it's fine no worries
thank you for allowing me to speak uh i
just have some brief comments i don't
have written testimony i'm from hollis
i'm a state rep there in hollis and i
just wanted to say that a year ago the
family court system wasn't on my radar
but there was a couple constituents
who've actually brought some
brought some issues to my attention at
that time and it was at that time
centered around the judge intracaso
issue as you may all recall judge
intracaso was the family court judge who
was
convicted of falsifying documents
and it was it could be a felony it could
be a misdemeanor as it turned out
i was actually at that sentencing
hearing it was decided it was going to
be a
lo and behold go figure a misdemeanor
with no jail time and the precedent they
were using for that was another
court judge who was actually also
convicted of something that could have
been a felony that got a misdemeanor
that's slightly erroneous to what this
bill is but it
when i started getting involved in
looking at things i try to look at
things in a wide angle so when i was
looking at the judge intercasso case i
was actually talking to the assistant
attorney general i was talking to the
judiciary code
conduct committee and i was trying to
really understand it
and one of the things that i was
surprised to find in all of my research
was actually there was quite a few
people in my town who actually were in
the family court system and had some
very heartbreaking situations things
that they were currently happening in
their family and they were left to
languish for quite a long time
that was the reason that i decided to
to participate with representative gay
on this bill
one of the things that came
that
is pretty clear to me now is that there
are there's a need for a look
there's a need for a look there's a need
to lift up the rock a little bit and see
what exactly is going on in family court
system because since that judge in
tricasto case we've actually had other
situations where we've had a marital
master have an issue we've had issues
with the gal
there are a lot of hard-working
wonderful people working in the family
court system that do yeoman's work
having said that
there have been enough issues from
people that you'll hear today
that it just does deserves a little bit
more oversight
one of the things about that i've
learned about the judicial conduct
committee
while they are very thorough and they do
great work
they have a very narrow scope in which
they can look at things and they look at
things with only regard to does this
violate this or that there's a lot of
things that seem to be falling outside
of that area that they
they cannot look into and that's why
it's our responsibility
and that's all i have does anyone have
any questions for me
thank you
oh yes sir
would you take a question oh please
senator long thank you
are you uh thank you for taking my
question are you familiar with the
amendment
um no i'm not as familiar with the
amendment okay i should it's
representative but yeah that's fine okay
thank you thank you sir
thank you
next we have a
mr richard head
good morning mr head i see here that
you're asking for 10 minutes
i have
a huge stack of cards
do you think you could keep it to five i
will i will certainly do my best
obviously thank you kindly um and some
of what i'm going to talk about today
relates to some of the bills generally
that you'll be hearing today so
my first opportunity to talk to you
maybe a little bit longer than some of
the later ones uh because i won't repeat
myself relative to the other bills
if you if you could just keep it to this
bill we'd appreciate that sir absolutely
thank you kindly so my name is richard
head i'm the government affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch
um one of the things i just want to
clarify and it's it's a common theme i
think is
there is no family court anymore
there is now a family division in 2011
the legislature
consolidated and created the circuit
court and the circuit court has a uh has
three divisions it has the
family division has probate division and
has district division
and judges in the circuit court sit in
all three divisions so there's no
with with some exceptions so there used
to be a marital master system
and in in the same statute in 2011
the decision was made to start phasing
out marital masters so as marital
masters retired
those by statute uh could become uh
judges instead of masters we currently
with the resignation of master delphra
we have one marital master currently in
the system
and when master cooper retires uh the
met there will no longer be any marital
masters
so in the in the circuit court with with
again some limited exceptions judges sit
in all types of cases
and you have roughly in the circuit
division 125 000 cases
that are heard
that are filed each year
in the family division they're roughly
uh 19 000 new cases
in roughly 5 400 cases that are reopened
so in the family division itself we're
talking about 25 000 cases
so it just sort of put it puts into into
context
so what we're talking about when we're
talking family division because we no
longer have a family court system in a
dedicated family court
process
in in in
in sort of within that we have 47
full-time judges that manage that 125
000 caseload
so it's a significant caseload that
these judges are working under the one
marital master we have two senior judges
and nine referees i think although once
you get into the seniors those are
retired judges under 70 and the retired
referees are over 70 are no longer able
to act as judges
and and they work essentially
on a volunteer basis they're paid but
but they work at
their own schedule they're not a
full-time
they're no longer full-time
employees
the other aspect that i think is
important for the committee to know so
with regard to this bill which is to
create a commission
there is currently
a task force domestic violence task
force that began in january is expected
to issue a report probably sometime in
march or thereabouts
and many of the people that are
participating in that in that domestic
violence task force are similar to the
types of people that would be in this
commission that's being proposed and
i've not seen representative gay's
amendment so i don't know exactly what
was proposed there
but within the domestic violence task
force we have county attorneys we have
legal assistants we have victim witness
advocates
we have chiefs of police we have the
coalition we have dove casa
uh private attorneys
so it is a
a wide spectrum of people that are
currently participating in a in a task
force that ultimately is likely to lead
to legislative recommendations
so it may make sense to look at those
recommendations see what comes out of
that and really tailor what it is that
you're talking about in this bill
into into a more substantive bill that
can that can incorporate those task
force recommendations and also the
testimony that you'll hear here today
and and from other people that you may
be hearing from but it just may be
premature
given that there is this task force
given that they will be issuing a report
and given
that it is likely
to include legislative recommendations
um
and now i'll say simply that you know
there are this is a very difficult area
of the law in and in the vast majority
of cases roughly 75 of the cases that
are in the family division they are
completed within one year of filing not
all cases are there are some highly
contested cases and you're going to hear
this afternoon from judge lemire
who does who is one of the few judges
that does mostly family family division
cases
but they are they are significant and
they are
um in some instances highly contested
and and judges are simply in the context
of the cases that are being presented
trying to take the evidence and and
render decisions and what we're talking
about when we're talking about family
division
is not only divorce and parenting child
support we're talking about domestic
violence guardianship of minors
abuse and neglect cases children in need
of services juvenile delinquency
adoptions there's a wide range of cases
that are being heard in family division
at the same time those same judges are
hearing in the district division
and in the probate division relatively
few in the probate division we're
primarily talking district and family
excuse me mr head you're past the five
minutes
so if you can
what you're saying is very important to
us and and the decision-making process
so
if you could i'm happy to to wrap it up
i'll i'll i'll be talking throughout the
day on many of these bills
but i'll be happy to take any questions
thank you does anybody have questions
representative long
thank you madam chair uh thank you mr
head
so with respect to the task force um
if you look uh on page uh actually it's
the first page starting at line 28
um
i mean it looks like they're
they're looking at domestic abuse so
some of these would be picked up with
that i would suspect correct
i think that's i think that's correct
thank you for the question i think
that's right okay and with respect to
other uh
uh
educating court staff uh
trauma suffered by victims um
children permitting to speak for
themselves
do you think any of that within the task
force will be addressed
truthfully i i'm not sure some of it
certainly training uh is is on their
agenda um uh
and again i'll i'll note that it is a
domestic violence task force right so it
doesn't cover the full range of
matters that are being heard in the
family division um but i think in terms
of that type of recommendation i i do
believe that is one of the specific
items that they have on their list of
things to look at one more follow-up if
i may madam chair certainly uh
who
who picked this task force uh the chief
justice the chief of justice i think
that i think that's picked any i think
he consulted with some folks but it it
was created by the the chief justice
okay great and i should have added
there's also
the task force has a public hearing
scheduled for the 21st
where they'll be taking public input and
their meetings are
streamed and their meetings are also
recorded and available on the task force
website
which is which is accessible through the
supreme court website okay thank you
thank you any any further questions from
mr head
are you going to be able to submit your
written testimony at the end of the day
i actually don't have any written
testimony i apologize
with what's in your notebook well my
notebook is is scattered random notes i
see okay i have nothing thank you anyway
my my system is is pretty random in
terms of what i end up saying versus
what may actually be in here
like mine thank you thank you
uh next we have katrina heinrich you've
asked for three minutes
i forgot to say while she's taking her
seat um
if everybody could please be sure to
mute their phones
so that we don't interrupt whoever is
speaking whatever they have to say is
important
so thank you for that
thank you miss heinrich you've asked for
three minutes uh yes and i hope i can
keep it to that for all of you
so
my name is katrina heinrich my case has
been in the control of the family court
for over a decade
on this particular bill i'd like to
speak to some notable reasons i believe
that this needs to happen
first let me begin by saying i was
delighted that the governor signed
the family court awareness month
proclamation
which embedded in that proclamation was
governmental and academia studies that
support the reasoning behind it and the
need for it
with that said
the statistics from 2020
from the administrative office of the
court
noted that about 20 percent of the
family law cases
actually
actually are extracted from the overall
pool
of
whatever the number was at that time 20
25 000 cases
in those cases when you break it down
that's 3 000 cases and in that 3 000
cases that's actually affecting at least
a minimum of two
citizens of new hampshire because
there's two people in every case that
doesn't even include what children there
is
so a number of people are being
you know affected by this
so with that said i'm going to go on
with some of the issues that i have
found that are very transparent you can
see them you have to look at the data
and the only way to do that is to
investigate it
the lack of transparency issues at the
family court
for me one of the biggest ones is the
gals are paid private contractors
in that particular case i feel like they
should not get immunity they do not work
directly for the government they work
for themselves they have no direct boss
of responsibility they themselves are
the boss
the control of that
goes without speaking
they work directly with children and
family without obligation or
accountability this includes their
business practices actions and decisions
non-medical professionals are paid
privately also in most cases
void of accountability the court
is ordering medical and psychological
services and treatment to families and
children where it's not needed
there's been failed billing codes
there is no litmus test for them
the court is making judgments and orders
rendering opinions and decisions about
individuals who may or may not be party
to the case without service
and a very good example of that is
they're including
people that have never been served
they've never been given court decisions
but they're in the orders restricting
them
from their rights
children do not have the voice as in my
case
my daughter has already stated
in numerous letters to
numerous legislators
how her kidnapping occurred
and that had the gao actually been
working for the child it would have
never happened
the result of that is her lifelong ptsd
which is the reason she is not here
today to testify
the little girl that is missing harmony
really set uh
her off for the last week
due to the fact that
she herself was removed from the state
and the state didn't care no matter what
i tried to do
she couldn't contact me for 45 days she
found a way to get a message to me i had
no idea where my child was
none
the court fails to acknowledge the abuse
and trauma suffered by the victims
instead excuse me
your three minutes is up i'll give you a
minute to wrap it up please yup thank
you dear
instead the victims are included in
stalking harassment cyber bullying
gaslighting by the unhealthy parent
and third parties that are outsourced
requests for family court financial
information that i have tried to get
from the family court for audits
i would like to know
their money trail i'm very curious about
their money trail they cannot provide me
with any financial audits for the last
20 years
court income and billing seems to be in
some type of dispute
by way of written transcripts of family
court proceedings are frequently
incomplete and missing critical data
suggesting that the court the family
court software and technology is
incapable of accurately recording
proceedings in their entirety
such as i have one that's missing 30
minutes it's a 30 minute court case and
it's missing 20 minutes of actual
documentation
parental rights are violated when the
child is kidnapped to a southern state
that was my case
and it violates constitutional rights
and civil liberties freedom of speech
suppressed without due process using
rule 1.1 or 1.2 and 2.2
thank you
do you have written testimony to submit
please i do not these are my notes but i
absolutely can get that to you thank you
kindly
next we have the honorable dan itza he's
asked for five minutes can you
you know what it's like representative
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh there's no place like home
i spent 16 years in your seats
um i want to
tell you something about uh six years
ago there was an attempt to dissolve
this committee i'm going to tell you
what i didn't
say in defense of this committee at the
time
if you uh
understand
the that the simple summation of the
natural rights that our constitution
state constitution is designed to
recognize and protect
are that a man's home is his castle
the
subjects that this committee deals with
every one of them every single one of
them reaches inside that castle
and therefore it is incumbent upon you
to have a particular regard to those
natural rights
the
family court
this committee was formed the year after
the first family court was
created and then it was under the
auspices of this committee
that it was eventually expanded
statewide
that courts those courts deal with
the subject matter of your committee
whether it's divorce
child protection
whatever and it is therefore your duty
to make sure that the court is doing its
job in dealing justly with your
constituents
um
one thing i'd like to bring up it was
brought up that there are no longer any
marital masters as of 2012 they were
phased out that is true they were
replaced with referees
however
while the
district court probate court superior
court
all have specific recom uh requirements
of their referees
family court reference referees have no
requirements
when i tried to impose requirements it
was
pursuant to a tally of the referees and
family court at the time was
approximately 2014 2015 i can't really
give you a precise number anymore
um
a large number of them
were simply listed as former court
employees they were not attorneys they
were not former judges they were former
court employees
you can obtain this information through
legislative services and i
advise you to do so
see who is there doing making uh
recommendations to the judges
uh this is important
because
second party i or second hand
i have knowledge of
referees or marital master who's then a
referee and is now a judge who accepted
closed envelopes as
information upon which children were
removed from custody
no one ever saw what was inside of that
it was observed by then representative
paul emerson in person
ms heinrich who
you just heard observed the same
behavior
this is
not everything and there's a lot of good
that happens in family court there's a
lot that is not good that happens in
family court and it's your job
to make sure that it ceases the bad
if there is anything i find
missing now in this legislation i advise
you to adopt the proposed amendment
i think it's a very good idea to have
members of the community
what is not included is investigating
uh
what happened you know those cases in
which it goes sideways
what and find out why certain cases go
sideways when there is loss of due
process
and that's basically every time it goes
sideways it's a loss of due process
figure
court rule 1.2 says the court in the
interest of justice the judge may waive
any rule not in statute
which means simply
there are no rules
except at the discretion of the judge
so you need to define determine
which
rules or what needs to be put into
statute so that it cannot be
circumvented i'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you mister it's uh
we've
one question representative cody
bollinger
thank you madam chair and thank you the
honorable daniza for being here today uh
if anybody understands the family court
at this table probably one of the number
one people who do
one of
um
what was that uh
what was that
the court rule you just mentioned 1.2
uh it dovetails with the
authorization of the family courts i
think it's uh
473 d colon 4 which says notwithstanding
in spite of which means in spite of any
law to the contrary
the
family court has equity powers in all of
its cases which means that
any law that was passed
prior to 2012 has no particular force in
family courts
follow-up yes ma'am certainly thank you
can you do you have
can you provide that to this committee
of course thank you
for the follow-up
um
so
unfortunately i don't have the amendment
in front of me but if somehow i can get
that that would be greatly appreciated
thank you very much
thank you representative rung thank you
madam chair
and do you think this bill seeks to kind
of dissolve that court rule um
i don't know that it needs to be
particularly dissolved what what this
committee needs to to do is to determine
uh
what constitutional rights are being
circumvented by the waiving of rules and
establish them in statute
so to ensure that they are protected
any further questions
seeing none thank you representative
next i'll call on uh dana alberti
dana albright you've asked for two
minutes
good morning
good morning thank you madam chairwoman
my name is dana albrecht and uh the
committee heard me testify last tuesday
about the shared parenting bill
i'll try to make this brief
uh at this time i just like to remind
all of you that i'm one of at least nine
family law cases
in which former judge julie intercoso
appointed her very good friend kathleen
sternenberg his guardian ad litem
you'll probably be hearing from a couple
others as well
but instead of hearing me say that
i'd like you to briefly
listen to
them say it
in the on may 4 excuse me on may 1st
in the sobo case and there's a list of
online cases up there
um you've got julian tricasso and
kathleen sternenberg together in open
court
and if we can just listen to that
briefly
excuse me
and i recognize attorney sternberg's
writing i believe maybe maybe not but
her name
the council should know that attorney
sternberg and i are
very good friends
very good friends i don't know if she
shared that with you or she did not
excuse me sir excuse me sir yeah we're
very good friends can you speak to the
relevance of this
yes the need to establish a court record
thank you
so again
um
we have serious issues in just these
nine cases
alone
and i just wanted to ask uh if everyone
caught that on the audio because
kathleen sternenberg was a little harder
to hear
but they were both there and she
certainly agreed with julie intercostal
about the friendship
and the key that's back in
okay and marital master bruce staupra
also knew about the conflict
since then too and we know that because
julian tricasso said so in her sworn
deposition
anyway not everyone from all those nine
cases is here today but we have a couple
you can hear more from them directly
and so i just wanted to be crystal clear
to everyone what the issue was in those
cases it goes far beyond the alteration
of court documents and for everyone to
pretty much just hear
uh miss intercostal and sternenberg to
say it for themselves
so
that's right there is reason enough to
support the bill i'll just add i like
the amendments
and i agree there's probably
plenty of
other good reasons as well
uh that's all i have to say on this so
i'd like to save the bulk of my time to
speak to appeals later thank you does
anybody have any questions for mr
albrecht
representative long
thank you madam chair uh
sir
just a quick question
how
how do you believe this commission is
going to solve all the issues that
you're bringing forward
uh so i'm just bringing forward
respectfully nine cases in which we know
there are serious problems
and so
that really justifies the need for this
commission and i would imagine
in its existence that
more cases with serious problems other
than these nine i think you'll probably
hear from vivian later
would also be representative
of
cases that a commission like this just
might want to look into and figure out
what's going on
just a follow-up for me certainly i
don't see in the in the bill where uh
they're looking at specific cases so
that that's where i'm having a hard time
tying into how these nine
issues
are expected to be resolved within
with this study committee i'm trying to
get that tie-in can you help me with
that
uh
i would
gather if they don't look at any cases
at all
what are they doing
well they're doing what the bill says
they
should be looking at
i mean they're studying the family court
system but how do you do that without
some representative examples of what
it's doing yeah i don't know okay thank
you
thank you uh
next we have robin
oh i'm sorry i apologize madam
sir
we have one more question please
here i am i'm fumbling all around um
yes thank you very much for your time
i'm sorry to drag you back like that
um
in the bill
it says that um on line 28 part 3 the
commission shall study parenting cases
and decisions by courts
within the judicial family branch system
is the
and
as i understand you're one of these nine
correct so
is it your
hope
that um your
case will be used
as instructive
yes
all of the nine is instructive and may i
follow up please yes and so i'm
um
is it um
i guess what i'm asking is are your
your hope if i understand your hope is
that these nine will create
um a template for exploring further
cases
is that
possibly case review is that
i i think these are a great example of
things that can make a template that
doesn't mean there aren't some
other different types of cases that
can't as well
okay i i
get it yes now thank you i understand
what you're yeah oh what it was what you
were getting across thank you so much
you're welcome thank you all set
representatives thank you
thank you
anyone else
seeing no further questions now you can
go
thank you
the next person i have is robin partello
we have so many speakers on this i'm
hoping that your testimony will be
bringing us new information correct
thank you thank you
good morning panel thank you for hearing
my testimony today my name is robin
partello i'm a resident of nashua new
hampshire
in october of 2018 i went through the
family division in nashua where judge
intercasso and marital master delta
assigned kathleen sternenberg moving
forward six months later march 12 2019
judge intercostal personally signed off
on three specific orders related to the
guardian at lightham her payments and
how i have to comply with her and in one
of the cover sheets from the court it
said my failure to comply with the
guardian at lightham would potentially
result in my incarceration
two
three days later judge introcaso issued
a handwritten order in my case in which
she said
i have to disclose for the record that
gl sternberg is my best friend we travel
together we discuss finances she is the
godmother to my children and this is a
conflict of interest that in my opinion
cannot be waived at this point i looked
at the order and i said it took you six
months
to realize this and to disclose this to
me this is not fair when you're making
substantive motions
regarding my life my child and how i pay
for the guardian at lightham
so i filed a judicial conduct committee
complaint
while under investigation
julian tricasso took my file into her
office
and altered several of my documents
including whiting out the handwritten
portion
where she
said i had to pay kathleen sternenberg
she went on to blame me for this
i didn't do it i would never do anything
like that
she blamed the court staff they said we
didn't do it we have no interest in
doing something like this
so i had to be prepped by the judicial
conduct committee and in my opinion they
did the attorney waste act did a stellar
job
however moving forward
i went to
the court and i filed a motion saying
can we remove this gal there's clearly a
conflict she's an attorney she had a
duty to disclose this conflict with
former judge intercosta and it makes you
conflict or
or question
her ability to testify truthfully if
she's not even disclosing a known
conflict
despite my request to have her removed
as gal
my new judge said to me
this is um
this can be redressed with the supreme
court you can file an appeal ma'am can
can you stay with the substance of the
bill your issues are very valid and
relevant to a degree
but we really need to hear about okay
the bill i apologize so my but my i'm
just trying to tie it together and i'm
almost done so my judge said to appeal
it to the supreme court go to the
judiciary or go to the gal board i tried
all three gal boards said you cannot
file a complaint until your case is
concluded
i can't appeal to the supreme court
until it's done the judiciary said
go to your judge and ask
i have no recourse at this point so
that's why
to tie it all together i think if there
was a committee to
investigate this it would give litigants
who are in my situation an opportunity
to be hurt i feel like my hands are tied
at this point and every state agency
that could be helping is
there's a loophole and nobody can help
me at this point
at this point that's concludes my
testimony if anybody has any questions
thank you so much
any questions for this
seeing none thank you for your time
next i'll call on laura
montgomery
you've asked for three minutes can we
i will try to make it thank you kindly
thank you
my name is laura montgomery i'm the
mother of two children a daughter
currently aged 16 a son currently age
six
my daughter and son are from separate
relationships as such they have separate
court cases both of which i'm labeled
the respondent both of which were heard
through the
nashua new hampshire court system
and approximately 2019 with jl and
sternenberg initiating both of those
since then it's just gone off of that
initial um
determination by j.l sternberg and um
former george anacosta
my the exhibits that you have in front
of you are labeled chronologically um
this is especially important given the
fact that um in in particular note there
was an instance in which julian acosta
wrote an ex parte email directly to my
attorney at that point in time
uh saying she was going to appoint
kathleen sternenberg at g as a jail
in the case unless she unless my
attorney objected within the next 27
minutes
i've been going through this process
since 2005 every three years
was the initiation that
both my exes
had started and
essentially that was the point in time i
lost both my children they were taken
away from me citing the fact that i
my gps wasn't working and i couldn't
make it to the softball field my
daughter's softball game was at and they
felt that that was an extreme case of
mental disorder and that was rationale
behind taking my kids away
i haven't had normal parenting time with
my children since 2019 prior to that i
was a primary caregiver for both my
parents for both my children with
limited involvement from their
respective fathers
this is an extreme upheaval and it goes
against everything that you are required
to learn in the cip classes everything
um which is in the best interest of the
children
meaningful involvement from both parents
and i am speaking here today in support
of a committee and review process for
cases in which supporting information
is available and has been presented yet
in which the court system is either
unwilling
or um
frankly just not wanting to listen and
review thank you
thank you
any questions
seeing them thank you
and that was your
testimony that was handed out
the exhibit
do you have
written testimony that you can give us
yes
perfect
thank you kindly
the next person i have here is angela
lorenzo
sorry
lozier
angela lozier yeah
you've asked for five minutes we're
already 15 minutes past yep no worries
how many thank you
thank you chairwoman and
committee children and family in law
again my name is angela lozier and i'm a
mother and a one you have to leave it at
the end
thank you
my name is angela lozier and i'm a
mother of a wonderful 13 year old
daughter
many of you heard my testimony on
tuesday last week in support of shared
parenting
i started out as a full-time mom for
almost 12 years and i offered and
proposed a schedule close to 50 50 and
now i've become an every other weekend
mom
for the majority of the year
my entire life changed when kathleen
sternberg took my daughter away for no
good reason in a 20-minute review
hearing before marital master thomas
cooper
on november 30th 2020 it's hard to
believe a gal can make such an influence
on a marital math and a marital master
did decide without any proof of neglect
or abuse
never did i think november 30th 2021
would result in the young in the outcome
it did unfortunately it happened to be
it happened to me in a blink
i am still struggling to figure out why
and how kathleen sternberg
made her recommendation on hearsay and
false allegations before my scheduled
final hearing january 28 2021
i brought the transcript for you that
for that it's only 15 pages
that's all it took to lose the most
precious thing in my life 20 minutes
changed my entire life
excuse me
this record
this recommendation from the gal did
destroy the close and fun-loving
relationship between my daughter and me
one would think the court exercising its
equitable powers would exercise fairness
and good conscience ought to be
administered
all relief
with the nature of the case and the
facts demand
please understand what the courts did in
my case
i'm not just a case number
only having one child
in the judiciary system took that honor
away from me
well this is is extremely difficult to
comprehend
it is
inequal to change the child's residence
in a school
on a temporary basis
i feel the findings of fact and ruling
of law should avoid significance in
determining the relocation of my
daughter
and this is exactly why i support hb
1346 and i hope you will consider it too
we need to study the family court system
and figure out why this is happening to
families
thank you
any questions you have any questions
representative long
sure ma'am you can have a seat back
there
thank you man for your testimony i
this is what i need to hear
um did i hear you say that at the
beginning you had a 50 50
agreement
no
i left when she was a year old i always
tried i think both parents deserve to be
involved in the child's life
he had every thursday friday
and every other weekend
when she became five he took me to court
again for full custody
um we went to mediation that time
no gal worked out okay
you know he then became in every other
weekend father
and every other week in the summer
school vacations
anything that wouldn't disrupt
her schooling here in concord
he lives in dover
um
now it's completely flipped i offered
throughout the course
of this last previous time of november
pretty much
every weekend school vacations every
other week in the summer my daughter
wanted more time with her father
absolutely she craved it
and um
i never wanted to deprive her of that
um
but yet when you have somebody that
almost has his
and not to say but it feels like
his hatred for me for leaving him
um was almost stronger than the love of
his child
what father really wants
to do this to a mother
it's obviously to hurt her
and he manipulated the gal
and we'll hear more i have a few bills
i'm going to testify on today
but um i really felt
when a parent is
trying to do the best of their child and
the other one's just
bashing the other one
where and there's no evidence it's just
boggling to me how
i could end up like this and what scary
is i'm very well known
within the community
i'm a realtor i've owned a hair salon
business for 22 years
and everybody knows what type of mom i
am
they're scared to think
to see what i've gone through
they are scared they're like how does
this happen
we we can't even imagine
you are such a wonderful mom you and
still have always been like this but
unfortunately a child can be bride a
child can be made promises
a child wants to love both parents
period
and a gal in the middle of it no kid
deserves to be in the middle
and a gal does that in favor is it
perhaps the parent that's paying her
is it um
i had
allegations made against me when he
wasn't getting his way
and then a gal was ordered thomas
marital master thomas cooper
um
refused to give him an in-camera
interview
early into
the proceedings of him filing again for
full custody
so things were going right i can't say
thomas
cooper is to blame for everything but i
think gals hold too much power and it
needs to be overlooked more
um
because if you were to read
the temporary order and her
recommendations and the things that are
said about me
are horrifying it's embarrassing
so embarrassing
um
and i guess i i hope i answered your
question i know i probably went off a
little no you did but i i i think i was
fair i think i um
i always try and look at things from all
perspectives
um tuesday was very hard for me i i
actually
i'm very emotional about this this like
tuesday reminded me of being in court a
mic people staring at you being judged
so
i'm here today
to hopefully say
to my daughter and
future families that voices can be heard
things can be changed
but you can't stay silent and i think we
kind of stand in numbers today and i
really appreciate you guys hearing us
thank you thank you
i just want to make an announcement for
the safety of the committee
i would ask all audience members or
people who are testifying to not
approach
the committee members if you have
something you would like us to
enter into the record please do
leave it at the first
of each end of the table
especially those who are
not wearing masks
it's
safer for our committee members for you
to not approach
so i appreciate that thank you very much
and the next person i'd like to call is
vivian gerard
you've asked for three minutes thank you
very much
thank you chairwoman and members of the
children and family
committee
um i actually won't even need three
minutes but i did that just in case
my name is vivian gerard i'm the mother
of two daughters age 13 and 15.
many of you heard my testimony on
tuesday last week about my struggles
getting child support
i had 20 trial court hearings
mostly by julian dicasso and
more recently master bruce delpra
i had four appeals
to the new hampshire supreme court
the rulings came from them they were all
okay
and it's been seven
it's been a seven year sentence from
hell for me
clearly something is very very wrong
here so maybe just maybe
we should figure this out
what it really is
and that's why i support this bill
if anybody has any questions i'd be
happy to answer them thank you any
questions
thank you very much
and the final
person i i'll call is alicia broshu
thank you
you've asked for three minutes yes ma'am
okay
thank you my name is alicia brochu
i uh i'm not very good at public
speaking i apologize
i'm here today as a mother stepmother
and a formal former legal professional
and i support this bill
um our family courts do have an
unbelievable amount of discretion
the only guidance that they really have
when determining children's lives is in
their best interest that guidance is
vague our judges are only human though
they have all sworn an oath to complete
their duties in accordance with the law
and without bias because they are only
human that bias will affect their
decision they can't help it
sometimes they get it right but other
times they get it wrong
and when they get it wrong it can have a
devastating effect on the children
not just physically and mentally but
also mentally and emotionally
we need this committee to give the
legislature the information and the data
they need to determine where more
guidance to the judiciary is needed
we've all heard um the statistics
regarding the benefits of equal shared
parenting it needs to be known how often
our judiciary follows the science and
ensures that when parents are both
willing fit and able
that our children are able to maintain
an equal relationship with both
we all know the devastating effects that
domestic violence has on children as the
gentleman in the smashing thai said
there is a death task force regarding it
but what is not talked about is the
effects of false allegations of abuse
and how that has on children
i personally have been a victim of
domestic violence in my past
relationships and my family has been the
victims of false allegation and that
pain is very real that trauma is very
real for children
um
we need we also need to know um if the
guardian idol items are
performing their duties ethically
um and without the loyalty binds that
where the payment comes from can create
without all of this data every attempt
of the legislature to issue more direct
guidance to the judiciary will be like
trying to stop a flood without knowing
where the water is coming from
the only ones who will truly suffer are
not the parties listed
in the case name
but it's the children whose lives these
orders directly affect
i believe in the need for the study so
much that when my husband said to me
we need to do something
there needs to be a study into these
courts there's been too much going on
there and i said
okay
he said let's sue the state i was like
uh he couldn't find an attorney to take
it so i said you know what let's throw
the spaghetti on the wall let's try it
so we petitioned this uh superior court
in rockingham county to ish to issue a
manamis relief for
studying the family courts of course
superior court doesn't have the
authority to issue mandemous relief and
create a study so now i am here
looking at you all to do the right thing
we really need this data
the only people that are truly a hundred
percent affected by these judicial
orders are children and it's lifelong
and now we have generations of children
that are now adults being traumatized by
when judges get it wrong thank you
thank you any questions
thank you very much
we do have one more person who wishes to
testify eric braund
eric you've asked for three minutes
can we make it even more brief
i will thank you madam chair i will do
my best thank you kindly
thank you madam chair and committee
members for listening to me today there
are obviously a number of bills um
affecting family courts that are on the
docket today i only plan on speaking on
a few of them um most of my remarks and
many others here uh will probably be
very duplicate in nature
um i am
life pretty much a lifelong citizen of
nashua business owner for 30 plus years
father of three
um i do support hb 1346.
um this committee is seeing an onslaught
of bills between this week and last week
that all have to do with the family
court
this is really all coming in light of
the three court officials that were
removed from nashua
i believe and many others believe that
there are many others that have been
affected by not just these judges and
court officials but by many others
throughout the state there have
been many before myself and the group of
people behind me that have tried to make
some change within the state within the
court systems that have kind of given up
it's a very very hard uphill icy battle
in order to try to make change within
the state on a lot of these things
currently the judges and and masters if
court officials can throw out evidence
not listen to evidence
use their own opinion as fact
completely erase one parent
completely disable financially another
parent
all without any oversight
as you're listening to the testimony
over the last week and
what you're going to hear today it
should be very clear that there needs to
be a look into what's going on in these
court systems
there's more than 50 percent of the
population that is affected by divorce
and parenting plans
with so many people that have been
affected by this there's been very very
few changes over the years that have
gone to if to
help out
individuals families and parents
representative long asked how this bill
would help before
as i mentioned there are so many people
that have tried to make change before
that haven't gotten the ears of the
committees and of the rest of the
legislature in the senate
we're just the tip of the iceberg here
trying to make a change and we really
truly hope that everyone in this room is
listening and that we've gotten your
attention and we can make some change
together
it's not just the
guardian items that we hear a lot about
but it's really the whole entire process
that's erasing parents
i've had my children removed from me
from my from my life to become just in
every other parent when i was probably
one of the most involved dads that you
can imagine not just in the community
but in the upbringing of my children
from feeding and changing diapers to
teaching them things to coaching for
them and doing all of this and to
practically erase me financially and as
a parent
doesn't seem like it's the right thing
to do to help my children
i think that this review
will help find the flaws and make the
correct changes that are necessary
as you can see with a lot of the bills
that are coming out in last week and
this week
there needs to be that change our
children don't deserve just to be with
the best parent as some of the guardian
items try to choose they deserve to be
with both parents and this is just part
of
the whole
complexity to what's going on within the
family courts you also need to look at
the financial aspect of it as well so
it's a whole court system that needs to
be done i'll be happy to take any
questions
do we have any
seeing none thank you very much
thank you
and with that i'll close the hearing
on uh
hb 1346 at 1104.
representative gay i don't have a pink
card for you for this
oh
wait a minute
that one was for the other one
yeah
uh i apologize that was a clerk too
there you go
okay 1436. here you go
thank you
representative gig
um
what is the appropriate way to address
you all
i should know by now
just thank you for hearing my my
presentation for house bill 1436
to establish the right to a de novo
which means from the beginning
i don't have latin but they said that
means starting over appeal to the
superior court for family court
divisions because right now
you have to appeal to the supreme court
and some of the inconveniences of that
are number one supreme court's extremely
busy and there's only one of them and
the other is that they require they just
review what has happened so if you were
not able to present a
testimony
excuse me
i don't know what i ate
if you're able uh if you are only able
to or you were not permitted to present
evidence and
testimony it's still not going to be in
the record or reviewed
so if you start over
with a
superior court you can be have your case
reheard
and it it's true there is a risk in
there because they said over 90 of the
cases are
pro se
so i mean you're stepping into something
that
you know a good attorney could just work
right around you but hopefully the the
truth will out so that's the conclusion
of my testimony if anybody wants to ask
questions
please
any questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you
next i'll call
mr richard head
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch um just in terms of
background the superior court would be
where this these cases would be appealed
currently there are
approximately 21 superior court judges
they hear about 17 000 plus cases a year
currently
in if we were to
incorporate family division into the
superior court on de novo
trial so essentially starting over again
going to make the party start over again
the courts are going to start over again
the evidence is going to start over
again
you were talking about a significant
increase in caseload in the superior
court where they don't currently do
family
family cases so if you currently in
family division and again family court
doesn't exist anymore we're talking
family division of the circuit court
there are roughly 25 000 new or reopened
cases there that would all be eligible
for appeal on a on a
a brand new case essentially in superior
court um the
increase in load the increase in
um in in complexity of of managing the
superior court
is going to is going to increase
exponentially if these cases were all
appealed or or some significant
percentage of them are appealed on a de
novo basis to the superior court i can't
say how many are going to appeal be
appealed but there is it's an inevitable
significant increase in in case load
where they're simply not currently set
up to do that i don't know that that's
you know
the other aspect of this bill it doesn't
talk about what type of decisions can be
appealed it just says aggrieved by the
decision in the course of any particular
case that's pending there are numerous
decisions that are being made along the
way
and it's it's just unclear from the bill
as to whether or not we're talking every
decision that is being made at the
family division is appealable to the
superior court to be heard over again
you're going to you're going to
cause a significant load in the superior
court you're also going to potentially
create significant additional costs for
the parties
especially you have the non-appealing
party who is now going to have to try
that entire case over again
there are just
significant complexities that i think
are not
obvious from a fairly simple bill that
simply says
you can have de novo appeals to the
superior court
i think what what that would entail is
significant and not currently manageable
in the system we have today i'd be happy
to answer any questions with that
thank you any questions
i don't know who raised their hand first
so we'll
representative long thank you madam
chairs uh so mr head
when we set up the family division
that was to expedite out of superior
court correct that was that
expedite these cases no family division
was was established as as part of the
creation of the circuit court so there
was a consolidation of family court um
district court and probate court all of
which operated separately and brought
them under the the new circuit court a
lot of it was a
uh budgetary issue so
a significant reduction in staff flowed
from that
and just some some other uh
uh efficiencies but no it was not a
it was not a superior court operation it
was it was a family court operation
prior to that
right uh follow up by me
certainly the um so so there was no
there was no expedition with respect to
uh this family division being the
circuit court being set up
it was financial
my understanding i wasn't involved in
2011 but i think a lot of it was uh
was both efficiency and financial
okay
that's my understanding okay thank you
and
the next person
representative
belanger thank you madam chair and i'm
going to preface this because
and i will get to my question just
there is a preface to that
so
i've been to family court myself twice
now for two different cases one to adopt
my nephew and one to obtain
excuse me one to obtain custody of my
niece
the second case
we have a judge who
tends to think he has a lot of power in
that courtroom and in fact mentioned to
me directly
that it's his courtroom and his rules
so with that being said
for many families that are dealing with
the same issue in the same judicial
discretion that is slightly
more
inappropriate if you will
what is the current appeals process for
families like myself and some of the
families that are dealing with that
power hungry judge if you will
so the the
there's a couple aspects i think thank
you for the question there's a couple
aspects one is
appeals on the decisions being made to
the supreme court
there are if the if the judge is acting
in a way that is unethical there's the
judicial conduct committee which would
enforce as you heard earlier specific
rules of conduct
some of those could apply to the
circumstance that you're talking about i
don't know the specifics
um
and
uh there can also some people would
at least flag any issues for the
administrative judge of the circuit
court judge king
but
in general what you're talking about are
appeals to the supreme court on
decisions appeals to or
complaints filed with the judicial
conduct committee on ethical violations
and on the basic administration of the
courts uh judge king
follow up
yes man i'm sure thank you thank you for
answering my question so basically what
you're saying is there's already an
appeals process
if i can clarify there's already an
appeals process to the supreme court
correct absolutely yes okay so
follow
follow up
so this bill is saying that
um
you can appeal to the
supreme court
correct no this bill says this bill
would say that any party aggrieved by a
decision of the family court shall have
the right to a de novo appeal in the
superior court
and and actually one other defect in the
in the just the way that bill is phrased
it says has a de novo appeal in the
superior court in the county in which
the aggrieved party resides not all the
parties necessarily reside in new
hampshire so it would be unclear at
least as the bill was written as to
where those appeals would go i'm sorry
final follow-up yes
thank you so
for those of us who don't know what a
novo appeals is can you kind of i want
to say for a lack of better terms done
that down but uh it's a start over so um
so nothing nothing in the original
decision would apply to the spirit court
in that case you essentially start
over again so it'd be as if nothing had
happened you file a new petition in this
case it would be an appeal
in superior court
unclear sort of the way the the bill is
written as to whether or not you would
start discovery over again
but typically when you're in superior
court you have a period of discovery um
and you have motions that are filed and
you have a trial if the trial is
warranted or if it's not resolved in the
in the pleadings so you know again it's
a it's a it's a starting game start from
scratch proceeding
no further questions and things
thank you
uh representative grossman did you have
a question
thank you representative all chiller did
you have a question
yes thank you madam chair
um thank you very much for the
explanation and i'm i'm curious mr head
um what does the appeals docket look
like
right now
it seems that what we're hearing
is that the process is either
so backed up maybe or
arduous to access
that
that we have this bill sitting in front
of us so what is what does the
administrative
judge's appeals docket look like
the
uh
the the family division appeals you mean
yeah that's we're talking about yeah um
so currently in the supreme court from
the family division
um
in taking sort of 2019 through 2021
there were between 184 to 193 cases that
were appealed to the supreme court
each year so 20 1993 2020 184 and 2021
i'm 186
that's roughly 25 to 30 percent of the
supreme court's
caseload
and then within family division of
course you have
a host of types of cases that are that
are within the jurisdiction of the
family division so that includes abuse
and neglect adoption chins
divorce domestic violence
family sort of general guardianships of
minors juvenile delinquency paternity
and termination of parental rights
all of those under this bill would in
theory be appealable to the superior
court for for a start over trial i'm
sorry could i get a clarification on
what you just said follow up yeah follow
up um
did you
correct me if i'm wrong please but there
was a lot of numbers right
no worries um
did you just say that between
there are there are between
184 to 193 appeals
from the family division
pending did i catch that correctly every
year on so those are annual files so um
there are no
so taking uh 2020
uh 2020 for example there were 184
appeals filed in the supreme court from
a family division decision
of those
well
so like the determination parental
rights were 68 of those 15 of those were
abuse and neglect
31 of those involve divorce degrees
um
so on et cetera okay let me
gather a further clarification
thank you um and
of that number that you just gave us of
that that range 184. yep um
25 are you telling us that 25 to 30
percent
of the supreme court's total caseload
is reviewing
these appeals is that did i understand
that correctly
yes i think so so approximately 25 to 30
percent of the
total number of appeals filed
um
approximately 25 to 30 are appeals from
the family division from the family
division alone correct okay which which
then has within that division a wide
range of types of cases
okay thank you very much i think i get
it
any further questions
actually
may i
inquire the the numbers that you have is
that submitted to us and i just haven't
seen that um it was actually submitted
so
oh is that in the email
no so
on i think the 11th judge king judge
ashley and judge lemire all came and
presented to this to this um committee
and this was part of judge king's
testimony and he he submitted some
written documents when when he testified
i think on the 11th of january yep i
might have that wrong but um so this is
this is from judge king's testimony
um when you when the when
on the introduction session for this
committee
okay to also be applied here
thank you got it thank you
thank you very much
sure representative long thank you
um are there any cases that are denied
i'm sorry cases of the supreme court do
they deny any of them and would you know
what to do so
fair question so um appeals from uh
superior court and circuit court are
mandatory appeals in the supreme court
so they're they're not subject to
discretion as to whether they accept
them okay if you're asking so if you're
asking whether they accept them they
accept all of those
the
there's some technical variations that i
won't need to get into
talking about the decision on the merits
i don't know how many are no but as far
as the what's what's the appeals that
are being the numbers you gave us they
can't just deny
they're not they're not rejecting their
appeals they're not able to reject the
bill absolute technical defects or
you know if they're not yet a final
decision on the merits
in between stuff too thank you
thank you mr head thank you
the next person is katrina heinrich
you've asked for three minutes
thank you again miss heinrich and if you
have written testimony and can
submit that we'd appreciate it yes
absolutely
um i'm katrina heinrich i'm not going to
need the full three minutes
due to some information already come out
there's no point in
doubling down on that
for my experience and the cases that
i've observed or participated in
the access to appeals
filing fees tools resources to the
family court causing undue burden
occurs in the 20 percent of the family
cases that i'm speaking about
access to law and legal protection seems
to be
almost void
in my case in particular
like most other cases the numerous
barriers to access a fair review with a
higher court
or functional deterrence do exist one of
the biggest ones of course being
financial
all attempts at trying to
follow the processes that were in place
at the time
uh have been caught in loopholes
and they continued
to determine i mean that was effectively
what they did
so there was no
opportunity in any way to get a review
and that's all i have to say
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
the next person to testify will be
alicia
brochu
and you've asked for three minutes
that's correct thank you
my name is alicia broshu uh once again
i'm in support of this bill and once
again i'm testifying as a former legal
professional a mother and a stepmother
um as it states in the methodology of
this bill the supreme court appeals to a
matter of um
basically they're a matter of law not a
fact
so what doesn't state in the methodology
is that except for the first final order
out of a family law case
the supreme court appeals are
discretionary they're not mandatory
so what that means is that if a person
files an appeal with the supreme court
unless it is the first final order the
supreme court can use their discretion
to not hear the case
and then because of supreme court rules
discretionary appeals when they kick it
out they don't even have to give you a
reason why they're rejecting it so that
means that this leaves the majority of
the parties with a family law order with
no recourse
if the orders are in violation of the
law or if the violation
if the violation is of facts
which caused the violation of the law
family cases canyon usually do have
several final orders especially when the
parties per statute have the right to
re-evaluate child support every three
years or if there's a substantial change
in circumstances my husband has appealed
to the supreme court three times with
two cases all three times the supreme
court justices decided it was
discretionary so they were not going to
hear them two of those cases were in
front of the supreme court at the same
time
both were for child support in the first
case the issue is whether or not the
child support order was legal due to the
fact that the judiciary nine years
earlier effectively terminated his
rights and issued a lifelong no-contact
order but then nine years later same
court same judge decided to issue child
support even though there's a statute in
place that specifically states that any
order that permanently severs the
parent-child relationship also severs
the responsibilities to
financially support the child that's the
tpo
termination of parental rights statute
um
the other case is in a different court
with a different judge my husband in
that case has 80 residential
responsibility with the mother having 20
percent but yet the judge decided that
her monthly child support obligation was
zero dollars a month
the factual reason was because she
determined that the parents have
approximately equal shared parenting
not only as we know equal shared
parenting is not a reason permissible by
statute to deviate from the child
support guidelines but last i checked 80
and 20 is not even remotely equal
by allowing family court rulings to be
appealed to the superior court it will
allow parties that are aggrieved by the
family courts to have that right to
review the way the system currently
functions there is absolutely no
recourse when a case is opened again
and again
once a family law judge makes a ruling
whether it is right wrong it is done if
they made a mistake there is nowhere to
turn to fix it the family court judges
are aware of this and last i checked
that's not the definition of justice
that is actually tyranny thank you
thank you any questions
representative long thank you madam
chair so
i mean i've been here in an hour of all
the court systems are not
doing their due diligence yeah so why
would going to another
court
because um
mostly um
a little back story for the past i don't
know five years
we've been basically trying to for build
uh documentation
and
it's kind of hard because
going to another court it just gets that
eyes in place and right now for instance
the the case where my husband's rights
were terminated
um and then now he has to pay child
support 10 years later um the judicial
referee in that case actually
threatened to default him if he didn't
create a crime
um if he didn't illegally access my
personal banking information even though
we are uh married we keep everything
separate so he has no access to my bank
account information she point blank said
if you do not tell me your wife's income
and her bank account information i am
going to um i'm going to default you
we filed a complaint with the judicial
conduct committee and that went nowhere
i we filed we
went to the attorney general's office
they said they didn't have jurisdiction
i even contacted we filed a federal
lawsuit that went nowhere because of
judicial immunity um we even contacted
the fbi to say hey
you know maybe you guys can do something
about it
i i think it's the it's the desperation
that people need right now because not
only are the these judges and court
actors they're not upholding your
statutes that you guys pass they're not
upholding them they're finding ways to
go around them um
but
then you go to all these other agencies
and they're not
they don't want to do anything about it
so i think that filing the appeal to the
superior court is really it's going to
create that paper trail because that's
what you need you need to have that
paper trail in order to have
a
more effective
action
by the legislature because that's what
checks and balances is about in our
government
thank you thank you
thank you any further questions
thank you seeing none
i will move on to
dan albrecht
you've asked for five minutes and we're
35 minutes
over our time
so if we can make it
brief and not repeat information we've
already heard i'd appreciate it thank
you and i think i can do that because a
lot of people earlier covered points
that i wanted to cover so
um
again for the record my name is dana
albrecht and you heard me testify
previously
and i support this bill i've had a lot
of appeals
in my case and i'll get to that
momentarily
uh
but
uh echoing the prior testimony there's a
lot of cases where appeals simply don't
get heard at all because they're
discretionary
and so you have
fundamentally no right of appeal
to anywhere
of a family court division
and i've got uh an exhibit if that could
go around you don't need to look at it
now
you probably don't even need to read it
all it's just a good case study thank
you in how this happens
um
but first i'd like to address something
that the judicial branch said in their
analysis of this bill
they talk about a scenario where half of
family division cases
might be appealed to superior court so i
guess my question for them
is are they saying that the family
division is so messed up
that in half of all cases
there's an aggrieved party
who is sufficiently aggrieved to want an
appeal
because if that's true we've likely got
a much bigger problem
than we could solve with any of these
bills so maybe they could address that
next i'd like to point out that at the
state level
41 of the 50 states
have an intermediate appellate court
there's only nine that don't
and we're one of them
so back to my case where
i've actually filed a number
of appeals
um
and again the exhibit is simply a case
study
you can find others
um i don't expect you to read it
carefully heck the trial court sure
didn't read any of this stuff it was
their job they didn't do it
so you know
so just please remember that i had paul
moore
master diaper kathleen sternenberg
julian tracasso mark derby
all deciding my family's fate
and
i just want you to realize that if i
thought their orders were wrong in
practice i don't necessarily get to
appeal to anyone
and there's your case study
um
let me tighten this up
just pointing out we have discretionary
excuse me mandatory appeals under
supreme court rule 7a
and discretionary appeals under supreme
court rule 7b
uh which require a process called
certiorari
you
heard
more on that earlier if you need more
from me you can ask me in the questions
um this is typically because of the
caseload up at the appellate court
so for example the u.s supreme court
would only hear four to six percent of
all cases
uh they just don't have time to hear all
of them so they take the big ease of
national importance and those are the
ones you read about in the news again
that's u.s supreme court
um and again the
big problem i'm trying to bring up is
the state supreme court kind of works
the same way they don't have to hear
your case
and i think you already heard in prior
testimony
the
um situations in which they don't so i
won't repeat that
um
so
just a quick note on that case study
uh what we've got here
is a case
in which all of the judges involved
julian tricasso mark derby
claimed
not to actually know anything about the
orders they signed
and so i wanted to appeal that
and i had no right of appeal so i guess
my rhetorical question to this committee
is what's my remedy in this situation
i mean i sent it all the way up
i wasn't expecting the us supreme to
hear it i mean i'm not of national
importance but it's
really
that's why it's such a good case study
in which there is no
recourse
and this was just about a
julian tricasa order where they wouldn't
enforce
my cross-country parenting plan all i
was trying to do is get a cross-country
parenting plan enforced
and when the trial court didn't do that
you know i wanted to
send it up and i couldn't so that's the
issue there
um
and i would just point out where all the
family court judges
involved claiming to know nothing about
the orders they signed
i'm not making that up that's in the
official record it's in hearing
transcripts and it's in sworn jcc
depositions
um
so i guess
kind of i'm saying if we think we got
the wrong decision
why can't we go up to some next level
intermediate state court as an appeal by
right just like we can in 41 other
states
finally in closing i'd also say that
most of the complaints i've heard from
other people about family court
involve a claim that the judge got all
the facts
most of the complaints i've heard from
other people about family court involve
a claim that the judge got all the facts
wrong
typically because they failed to read
pleadings at all or failed to look at
evidence at all along with some kind of
documentary evidence that the aggrieved
party claims proves that again they
they're just making a claim
my question is what's the remedy
if an aggrieved party
wants to make that kind of claim and i
think it's the superior court and it's
not our supreme court and that's why i
support this bill and i'd be happy to
take questions
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
thank you
you're
welcome the next person i have is vivian
gerard
and you've asked for two minutes i might
not even need that much okay thank you
thank you madam chairwoman and members
of the committee again my name is vivian
gerard as you heard my testimony earlier
i'm just a mom
i'm not a lawyer but i had four appeals
this new hampshire supreme court
and my lawyer won all of that for me
and it's still not
fixed was extremely expensive and
probably took a toll on the court system
it definitely has taken a toll on my
family
i've heard some of these complex
case dockets were some
but where
i found them in the basement of the
courthouse
i guess
i don't count for that huh
hello
it's like
bueller euler
bueller
does anybody know that reference
or maybe not
it is
is it the supreme court the only way to
even try to get my
case fixed
anyways
a question for the committee and you
don't have to answer this right now
do you think if my case
had just gone up to the superior court
the first time around and stayed there
that i'd still be in this mess
anyways
at julian dicasso's plea hearing and
sentence hearing
my friends and i actually
even tried to intervene at the superior
court just to have the right to be heard
that's all judge temple denied that
and said that my complaint related to my
specific case
and there
are other remedies
so can anyone on this committee tell me
what those remedies are
i guess parking my truck out front of
the national court didn't work
because in the document i hand it out to
you
that's my truck
in that photo within that exhibit i hand
it out to you
so that's why i'm trying to support this
bill and i'll take any questions that
you may have
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
next person will be
angela lozier
and you've asked for two minutes yeah
maybe not even
um
i guess
this past year i've really i oops thank
you chairwoman thank you um your family
committee um this past year has really
made me learn about
the court process a lot more something i
never thought i would have to do and i'm
still learning
um
my name is angela lozier as you heard me
earlier
[Music]
in my and in my situation
where gal
took
made her
recommendation in a temporary hearing
and a judge signed off on it and i went
eight weeks
on a temporary order that then turned
into a permanent order
it's terrifying to think
what do i do i don't know what to do
i've been told you go to the supreme
court and then
then i hear stories like other people
that tell me
good luck good luck um
to me that's scary i'm already petrified
of the result i had do i want to
emotionally keep putting myself through
that and my daughter
um no it would have been nice to have a
d is it a de novo hearing
um to maybe have all the evidence to
hear both testimonies
um without anybody being
biased in my situation um we would hope
i that we wouldn't have to go there
right to the the supreme court or the
superior court we would hope that people
that are evaluating our families
would do their job so we wouldn't have
to
have more emotional stress
um
and and keep asking for for things when
they're not being looked at
so i guess i you know learning like i
said
to me this seems like um
a bill that would help a lot of families
you know um and therefore i support it
um
any questions i'm happy to answer but
again i'm just a mom i don't really i'm
not a lawyer i don't know a lot about it
but to me and what i've heard in
testimony today it would give
families a chance if they weren't hurt
and maybe hold people accountable to do
their jobs so it wouldn't be handed down
and down and then objected and then it
just seems very complicated and
i don't think the average person that's
trying to work and provide
should know these things or have to pay
the expenses
to get
justice like i just feel people should
do their jobs and we wouldn't have this
right we wouldn't be sitting here today
um
so thank you again madame chairman thank
you family law and committee thank you
any questions
seeing none thank you very much
and our final person will be the
honorable dan itza you've asked for five
minutes
i'll do my best to be less
uh thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record i'm danitz i
currently reside in manchester
the most critical aspect of this
bill is the de novo nature of the appeal
the problem arises primarily out of the
manner in which evidence is received in
the family court person and family court
can be
uh confronted with what i call ambush
evidence something that they were not
aware of
going into the hearing and therefore are
not
prepared to rebut
it can be by the opposing party it can
be by the gal but they are then stuck
unless they or their attorney if they
have one
is
well enough prepared to make an offer of
proof
then they can make no more rebuttal of
that in any future proceedings
their first recourse is what's called a
reconsideration in which you bring the
case back before the judge that just
heard the case
when in that case not being able to
enter any additional evidence the
probability of achieving a different
result is extremely low
[Music]
sometimes you can get a reconsideration
before a different judge if the if you
can make cause for the judge to be
recused from the case
or you can repeal to the supreme court
which may or may not hear your case in
any case you can't present
any additional
evidence because you're limited to what
was before the original hearing
a lot of this can be alleviated by
statutes you might
contrive to regulate or require
information evidence to be submitted the
other thing that you heard was instances
where the judge openly defies the
statutes the legislature has
instituted
there is recourse for that but that also
resides with you and it's under part 2
article 38 i would suggest you read it
it's for mal administration in office
i'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you representative any questions
seeing none thank you very much and with
that i'll close the hearing
on 14 26 thank you
i'm sorry 1436.
and um does anybody need a refresher
break
huh
soon
um okay
so with that i'll open the hearing on
and again representative gay i don't
have a pink card i'm so sorry that's
okay thank you
haste is so important right now
we're going to try to do a little bit of
catch-up here
so we'll with your permission we'll go
to about 12 30 and then break for lunch
does that sound good
is that okay okay thank you
thank you go ahead
thank you
for your caring i feel i feel that way
um okay
house bill 1265
relative to a judge's discretion to set
aside rules and family court proceedings
is totally legal right now
the judge
the magistrate marital master whoever is
in charge of the proceedings
is permitted to set aside
any of the family court rules
and so that means that when you come in
as a
i don't want to call it litigant
a participant
uh party
when you come in you don't have any
rules that you can cling to
to uh
state your case because any of the rules
can be set aside so this just very
simply says
they can't do it the rules that are
there need to be followed and somebody
said well if they're going to set aside
fees don't you want them to be able to
do that so so we added that and my my
personal feeling is it's not in the bill
because it's not
polite
it's
if it's a bad rule don't have it in the
rules so that's
that's my whole testimony
thank you any questions
representative long
uh thank you representative gay uh
i mean every every governing body has
rules
uh that they are allowed to override
those rules i mean we have it in the
house
um
we have to we have rules
and we can change those rules when we
vote on them correct so
[Music]
i
i mean i
i'm trying to grasp how
rules don't get changed once they're
established they
wouldn't get changed until
[Music]
yearly or
i mean
any
should i can answer sure i'm thinking
there must be a process where the rules
are made
and this is just one of the rules
unfortunately the very first rule
that
all the subsequent rules can be
overruled
i understand discretion sounds really
great maybe there ought to be a set of
rules that are discretionary but as it
is now we have pages and pages of rules
that nobody can count on because it's
the
option
to ignore them
and i don't think that is fair for
people
to go in on what's a very scary
situation
and not have anything to be confident
about
okay okay thank you thank you thank you
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you
oh i'm sorry please oh i'm sorry
representative belanger you have a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you representative gay for being here
and answering the questions for this
committee
and when we refer to judicial discretion
what exactly in an example can you give
me as to
what you're trying to solve what's the
problem that you're trying to solve as
far as judicial discretion
well since i'm not an attorney and have
the rottnest memory in the entire world
i could compete
i'm thinking that so many of examples
given today
of things that went wrong were against
rules
they weren't following procedure
so
i'm going to guess that among the many
some of those happen to be
a
violation of not violation but setting
aside
rules
there are many pages of rules but i just
stopped at the first two
the fact that people don't have the
you know are denied rights because there
aren't any rules they can count on
any further questions
seeing none thank you representative
the next person i have
is uh richard head
you've asked for five minutes
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
what we don't
the ability to waive rules is
one of those sort of
necessary concepts that a judge needs to
be able to have
to ensure that that what they're doing
makes sense in the context of a specific
case
there may be you can disagree with a
specific decision to waive a rule
but
if the judge is going to have an orderly
and
thorough
opportunity for the parties to be heard
there are instances in which rules need
to be waived
what is unclear from this bill is
what
is there a specific rule that we're
talking about as opposed to all rules
all context all family division cases
because again we're talking about
a wide range of cases that fall within
family division each of those types of
cases has their own sort of
body of rules
and and really what we're talking about
is a blanket
rules must be applied whether or not
it's going to be fair in a particular
circumstance or
or activity so
we're talking about the rules regarding
adoption domestic violence um uh
guardianships
invo um
marriage
termination of parental rights and a
host of others and this
statute would say under no circumstances
in all cases in the family division the
judge has zero discretion in waiving any
rule no matter how inconsequential that
waiver may be and in fact not waving may
prove to be harmful we're talking about
you know as i said before 25 000 cases
being filed every one of those has their
own nuances and change in little quirks
about them and maybe a rule needs to be
waived in order to provide fairness to
the parties what this statute says is
nope no waiver no rules can be waived
sorry
you have to follow exactly what the rule
says no matter how unfair it may be
and and and what is unclear from the
bill
is are we talking about a specific rule
and then secondarily and i think the the
question was raised is
should the rule be changed and if the
rules should be changed there is a rules
committee in the court system that rules
committee does have a member that from
the house of representatives and a
member from the from the state senate
that sits on it if there is a rule that
should be changed really the the best
vehicle and and process for that is to
go to the rules committee and say
there's a problem with this rule you
should look at it and and that can be
introduced through the representative
member through the senator member but i
think
what we're talking about is you know the
operation of the
of the courts that is that is typically
maintained through a court rule
not through a statute that says
you know we don't know what what rule
we're talking about we think you should
apply them all without regard to to any
waivers
i think it's just it's too broad and
really the proper process is other
specific rules that are at issue and if
so
those rules should be evaluated through
the the process of drafting rules
and there is a process and there is a
membership that that can allow the house
or the senate uh to bring those forward
i'd be happy to answer any questions for
that thank you thank you
representative grossman you have a
question
thank you madam chair
thank you for coming today to our
committee um
so who who sits on the rules committee
so there's a representative from
the senate the house and then
uh
i apologize i i had it last week for
another hearing and i forgot to bring
the list of of who's on it um it is on
the court's website um the if you if you
just
search for for rules committee the the
membership of the rules committee is on
that okay great thank you
uh representative belandrick
and then representative long
representative long can go first
representative long
thank you madam chair uh
is there when a judge waves the rule is
there always an explanation as to why he
waived the rules
is that required is that a rule no it's
required
no it is not the rule does not say that
uh it just says
rules can be waived except
stat except if required by statute okay
they don't need a reason
they don't have to tell the parties what
the reason
of this waiver is
my
my experiences they do but um
i can't cite you a rule that says that
they're required to put it in writing or
or tell the parties uh okay
thank you it's my general experiences i
do
thank you representative bolandja thank
you madam chair thank you mr head for
being here today
is it not an advisory committee that's
correct that's correct they don't write
the rules but they do provided they
bring input on the rules follow-up can
you give me a definition of the
difference between an advisory committee
and someone who tells somebody
can you give me the difference between
an advisory committee
thank you for the question an advisory
committee is what its title suggests it
provides
information and recommendations it does
not have the authority to implement
follow-up follow-up so with respect to
to an advisory committee only
if if someone has an issue
that representative or that senator can
maybe say
we advise that we change that but it
doesn't have to get done is that correct
that's correct um but but that is the
mechanism and that's the process by
which our rules are developed is
with input from the from the advisory
committee
so i guess may i follow up again final
follow-up i don't know about that we'll
see
um i guess i'm just kind of curious
why would the
you know
why does the judicial branch feel that
having such a high
judicial discretion
and then only having an advisory i mean
if you look at this bill it is
bipartisan support
both
both both representatives and a senator
on each side of the aisle so i'm curious
why the judicial branch doesn't feel
like this is a problem
because it is
i i think the
what we're talking about in terms of
of
of what i'm presenting is
the rules go through a a fairly
substantive process both with the with
the rules committee um
which as you said is advisory and the
court itself
to implement the rules if there is in
what a
i suspect they're going to be people who
will testify about a specific rule in a
specific instance
if there are specific rules that should
be
reevaluated or considered
i think that's a that's a
a a more structured way of approaching
it simply saying we are eliminating all
discretion in all circumstances
with regard to
all of the court rules in family
division
i think the the
the level of unintended consequences
that flow from that can be significant
and severe
um
and what i'm what i'm suggesting is that
when we're talking about court process
and procedure
the the
mechanism for doing that is through the
rules and through the rules that apply
that are that are created by the
judicial branch
so i do think it is that that process is
an important one to follow
thank you
one more
final one
okay thank you madam chair thank you
thank you for answering the question um
so
i'm a judge right
and i choose to
use my judicial discretion to
make a decision
that
i feel is the right way based on my own
personal experience of the case that's
being presented in front of me
so i make
a huge change and i'm using this as an
example
because i have that judicial discretion
but i have maybe unintended biases
towards a party
do you believe that that's not being
taken advantage of in many family case
hearings
i think there are you know as i said
before
um
roughly 25 000 cases filed every year i
think the judges
do a
do
work very hard to implement
the
the intent of the statutes that they're
following and the rules that are before
them
and they're trained and they receive
training on a whole host of of
areas of law
whether or not mistakes get made
i can't say no mistakes are ever made in
the family division but i do think that
the judges when we're talking about
cases involving children they try
very hard to apply the best interests of
the child standard i think if there are
if there are instances in which a rule
needs to be waived in order for them to
receive information about the best
interests of the child they may do that
you may get some better insight if you
ask the question from judge lemire this
afternoon she unfortunately had a trial
today and won't free up until after two
o'clock
but i i think
you have judges that are
working very hard
to do what is
described in the statute and applying
the rules
to read to to achieve
the result that the case the facts
and the evidence
present
sometimes
what is being heard in court has to be
the evidence that the judge is relying
upon and and the judge is is going to
make the best decision based upon the
evidence that is presented and based
upon this the statutory guidelines that
are provided i think in the vast vast
majority
vast majority of these cases
you have a very diligent judge doing
that i'm not going to make excuses for
judge intercoson
i'm not going to make excuses where
somebody like judge intercostal has done
something wrong what i am saying is that
this
bill
would in all cases in the family
division in all circumstances prevent
any discretion on the part of the judge
i think that is
a step further than really what it is is
what is the goal of this committee i
think what
if you if you have a specific rule that
has been waived and has been waived
unfairly
that's that's a different conversation
than what this bill is and i'm just here
to address the bill
which says all rules cannot be waived
under any circumstance under any of the
types of cases that are presented in
family division
and i think that the unintended
consequences from that are significant
thank you
representative rung
thank you and thank you mr head for
taking my question you made a couple
comments in your opening statement that
waving rules is often necessary for
orderly and thorough hearings and that
not waving could be harmful
would you provide an example or two of
that please uh when i i probably
wouldn't say often uh so i if i said
often that was that was unintended on my
part um i i
i
it's probably a better job question for
judge lemire and i apologize i did not
sort of take a survey ahead of time on
what what circumstances they may be
considering a waiver of a rule usually
it's a timing issue
but
it's probably a better question i
apologize i just didn't come up with
examples before today okay thanks i
apologize i'd like to declare that
representative wrong is a co-sponsor on
the bill
i should not have called on i'm sorry i
apologize for that but thank you for
answering the question anyway mr head
but we do have one more question from
representative wazir
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question this question is more
of a broader that i have been hearing
all these bills
so far so the question is i have been
hearing um thousands of bills or
thousands of cases are being filed each
year and there are backlogs um in the
court system how are they prioritizing
those cases is there do they go by the
dates that has been filed or
based on the case scenario i'm just
trying to wrap my head around this
so
it it's a fair question so the you know
as i said
circuit court has roughly 125 000 cases
in that involves probate division
district division family division
probate division is sort of set aside
because those are largely now being
handled
in in concord at the administrative
office of courts where they don't need
to have trials so that's sort of a
separate issue so i'm going to set that
aside district division and family
division those cases are prioritized in
a number of ways and i won't get them
all
but uh so for example criminal cases may
have uh if there if there's a potential
for
a jail term
those have constitutional priorities
there are some statutes in which the
legislature has provided priorities
within the statutory language
it is a question also sometimes of how
long is the proceeding going to be is it
a
30 minute hearing is it a four day trial
so you know it depends on
what judges are available what are the
what other cases
have to be heard either through a
constitutional requirement or
through another statutory deadline so
for example during the course of a day
domestic violence petitions may be filed
you can have
a
termination of parental rights cases
that are pending you know various as i
said
family division is not just divorce
in their each one of those may have
their own internal required deadlines
and then you have those that have no
specific deadline
within
family division
they roughly are able to
get to a final decision in roughly 75
percent of the cases within a year
and then beyond that
you know some of them do take multiple
years
some cases are
heavily litigated
and have just boxes and boxes of
pleadings
um
and and those
tend to just take longer
and they're just highly contested
obviously the goal is
we have we have sort of internal goals
of trying to
um get a certain percentage out within
six months and within a year
but you know it's it's managing the
entire docket and that's done by staff
at each of the courts they know you know
they
basically you don't want aged cases to
be continued to to sit so you know it's
really a very complex
case management role that our clerks
handle and handle every day
within each of the courts
and and
it really become can be fairly
complicated
with regard to backlogs
there
clearly were some some
things that were slowed down during the
course of the pandemic
i think during oops let me give you
roughly in
in circuit court i'm not talking family
division but circuit court generally
they were holding even during through
the pandemic about 15 000 hearings a
month
and it's
it's a very
busy complex system that that gets set
up but
i can't give you you know any particular
cases going to be heard within a certain
period of time
it is it's the clerks working very hard
with the mix of cases that they have
before them and and what have fixed
statutory deadlines what have
constitutional deadlines what don't
what's the length of the proceeding what
are the unique circumstances an
interpreter needed
you know a whole host of
things go into into scheduling
um long winded answer i apologize but
there's no easy sort of
shortcut to sort of how these things get
scheduled
uh thank you miss had any further
questions
see you none thank you mr head thank you
i'll call uh katrina heinrich
thank you i am katrina heinrich
just listening to to our judicial
representative
uh i i wonder a question popped into my
mind he talks about the complexity
of the cases
does the system itself
is it such a complex system that our
judges actually use and waive the rules
in expediency and haste
it's just a question
i'm going to quote from goldstein well
known for his research on this topic
he stated that professionals who looked
at these cases found a pattern of
mistakes and dangerous outcomes
court professionals reacted defensively
to any research questioning of their
practices
the assumption continued that when the
decision was made it was right
our friend from the judicial also talked
about
reasons being given
and
at no time in my case have i been given
any reasons for the waving of
rules or rights or any
anything else one of the biggest
examples i have on that
leads to question if the family court
judges have evolved to rely on the
ability to just dismiss and apply
specific rules that they choose
1.2 and 2.2 which i spoke of earlier
waves the right to due process you
cannot submit evidence you cannot have
witnesses
all the cases we're talking about have
that similarity
in my specific case
i have an issue for the fact that
envelopes are being passed in court with
we don't know what in it we don't know
if it's evidence we don't know if it's
money we we have no idea what's in these
envelopes
and they were being passed
from the guardian at latime to the judge
the judge was accepting him the judge
would peek in them
and we never knew regardless of our
question the right to see it
so
with that said in my case the new
hampshire rules that were consistently
abused
and dismissed was
rule 1.2 and 2.2
specifically for me
it was evidence you cannot get evidence
in
one of the other issues that is really
huge in all of these cases and i'm sure
if they all take the time the requisite
time and think about it
is that by eliminating the right to
submit all of this
the courts are also extending that
by eliminating your right to bring in
family history my case didn't exist i
had a divorce
everything was set
but the moment the papers were signed i
was back in court for no reasons
i was told specifically by judge cross
that
there would be no family history there
would be no official documents school
records medical records we started from
zero
that's literally eliminating our family
life in every aspect
post divorce
so i question
the ability of the court to exercise
judgment
over post-divorce issues that are truly
issues
in my case ex partes were just filed
randomly even by the guardian at
lightham that is not his mandate
the ex partes were frivolous there was
no evidence for the expertise but yet
they were granted this extended our case
out to where we are now well over a
decade
guardian at light and made a lot of
money off of it
these ex partes
without evidence
did nothing
but emulate imminent harm
and that is due to waving of the rules
of due process
thank you
thank you very much any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
we'll call alicia roshu
thank you thank you
my name is alicia brochu once again i am
in support of this bill
um
the reason why i support this bill is
very simple judges have and they do set
aside the court rules and when they do
so they're not looking out for the best
interest of the children because that is
foremost what these family court judges
are supposed to do is look out for the
best interest of these children when it
comes to parenting cases
um
the rules themselves provide a framework
for how these matters are pleaded and
the procedures that are supposed to be
adhered to so when the judge sets aside
the court rules uh it sends a message
that in the family court forget what you
think you know about law
and the legal system it is the wild west
of
the court uh when i was taking my legal
classes i had to take a quite a few
family law classes and my family law
professor actually sat there and told us
don't get into family law
take it because if you do take
everything you think you know and throw
it out the window
uh
when was
my husband's rights to two of his
children were terminated and the
lifelong contact order was placed that i
referenced earlier it wasn't because
there was a finding of abuse neglect or
abandonment it was because he failed to
appear at a hearing
the mother reopened the case
and she did not serve him
and there was no proof of surface filed
with the court
the judge decided to set aside the court
rules regarding service and proof of
service and stripped the children of
their loving father
and that isn't even the worst tragedy
the worst tragedy of that came lasting a
year later when the exeter police
department knocked on our door at two
o'clock in the
morning asking if he could take physical
possession of the children
the mother was found several blocks away
from the home
high on drugs in a tree
the children were left home alone they
were three and six at the time
i will never forget the look of anguish
on his face when he had to tell the
officer that he could not help his
children
because there was a no contact order in
place prohibiting him from doing so
all because the judge set aside court
rules
and it's not just the judges that we
hear in the news that do this that order
was signed by judge foley
who is retired now and he's actually um
very highly regarded in the judicial
system
um
in other cases of his because my husband
has multiple children
i've seen the judges set aside court
rules regarding deadlines for answering
pleadings
um and the time that they have to
actually issue orders all the to the
detriment of the children
in the case riaz now has primary
residential responsibility for his
daughters the judge waited on average 10
days beyond the deadline for the
republican respondent's attorney to file
an answer to his motions for contempt
for violation of the parenting plan
there were 23 of them
filed by the time the case was settled
they never saw a hearing
and orders were never issued
the same case and a different judge
there was an ex parte motion that was
filed by the mother conveniently right
before he was supposed to start his
overnight stating claiming that he
kicked his two-year-old across the room
the initial orders were granted a
hearing was set they had the hearing the
judge waited four months
to reverse the ex parte orders
saying that those allegations were
unfounded so his child lost four months
of parental contact for nothing because
the judge set aside court rules
so in the meantime these children have
to deal with the emotional distress of
having their father ripped out of their
life again and again
all because the judge used their
discretion to set aside court rules
i'm sorry but as the gentleman and the
smashing thai stated earlier it's for
expediency
but these judges are not there to be
expedient they are there to protect
children
they are there to issue orders in the
best interest of children and the way
that it is now
they're putting their convenience
and
above what they're supposed to be doing
and that is looking out for the best
interest of the children thank you
thank you do we have any questions
thank you very much
next i'll call on vivian girard
you've asked for one minute
i don't even need that much
madam chairwoman and members of the
committee thank you again for having me
up here um my name again is vivian
gerard um and in my case julie and
dicasso constantly
allowed my ex to file items so late
that it was very biased against me
not allowing my lawyer enough time to
prepare for hearings
my attorney said these multiple late
filings have blindsided me judge julian
dicasso also allowed my ex to submit
evidence after the fact but not me
those were multiple serious violations
of the family division rules that really
hurt me in my case
and
this book that i have here i did not
make everybody copies but if you would
like it i can get it to you but this is
what happens
when the judge has too much discretion
i had to go to the supreme court
and
fight just what's in here because of her
discretions
and that's pretty much all i have but i
do have one comment
to richard head obviously there's
problems with the rules
i don't understand how this is fair that
i have to go through this for one
hearing to have those rules fixed
through the supreme court
for one case
and she did not tell me why she did not
follow the rule but this is my last
hearing
to get those discretions fixed
so if you have any questions i'll be
happy to answer them thank you any
questions
seeing none thank you very much
next i'll call on dan albert
you've asked for two minutes
thank you madam chairman chairwoman
excuse me again for the record my day
name is dana albrecht you've heard me
testify previously
first i'd just like to remark if you've
got a bill with great intent but maybe
there are some issues in the specific
language a pro proposed let's address
that with amendments
to that end i actually just emailed the
committee
some proposed language changes to this
bill that i think would address
a lot of mr head's concerns
respectfully i asked you look at that
offline
um
back to what i had prepared i just want
to say if we had this law
perhaps has amended amended that maybe i
wouldn't have needed to go up to the new
hampshire supreme court on my last
appeal at all and spend a year getting a
vacate and remand when instead the
family division judge could have just
followed the rules
um speaking to a specific rule
family division rule 126 e
it requires that motions that are not
ascended to will be held from 10 for 10
days from the filing date of the motion
to allow other parties time to respond
unless justice requires an earlier court
ruling
so this is the opposite problem of
vivian
they're not given me
the time the rule allows and they're
given the other party in her case far
more time
than the rule allows
and so i just like to echo what alicia
broshu i forgive i mispronounced that
said earlier
where you've got aggrieved parties that
feel they have false accusations against
them
that would be me
i've done nothing to deserve
a domestic violence restraining order
against me i got one anyway i appealed
it to the new hampshire supreme court
they gave me a vacate and remand
um if you want any further details under
the underlying circumstances let's save
it for questions because we should focus
on the bill we're discussing
um just suffice it to say i'm a peaceful
person never committed a violent act
back to the rule
um
unless there's an ex parte or emergency
situation
the court is supposed to hear from both
parties
before it decides what to do about
something
but in my tv case that the supreme court
just remanded
the judge
ruled judge curran ruled ex part a on
the other party's motion when there was
no
reason he couldn't waited ten days to
allow me to present my side of the story
and file an objection it wouldn't have
been prejudicial in any way we were just
talking about changing something
you know that's what you should have
done
and then figured it out after hearing
both sides of the story
and i think this is a widespread problem
that goes a lot
goes across a lot of different
underlying types of cases
you heard earlier from laura montgomery
about getting
kathleen sternenberg appointed by an
ex-part email with only 27 minutes to
object what do you do
enter kids taken away by
that in an ex part a proceeding
and another one where kids were taking
away in a 20-minute review hearing so
we're not
following the rules
that allow a party
who's had serious
accusations leveled against them
to actually be able to respond to those
and approach
appropriately have at least an
opportunity to rebut them so the judge
hears both sides and we can figure it
out
um
and i consider that the real problem
uh what we're really looking for is just
to get the right decisions
out of court cases as much as we can
so i would just suggest that we
adopt this or maybe some amended version
of this
or just do something
so we can address this issue
let's fix it and i'll take any questions
thank you any questions
representative long thank you madam
chair uh mr albright were you
represented by an attorney through all
this
i was previously represented by an
attorney but at some point you kind of
run out of funds on that so i'm
presently pro se okay thank you
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
considering that there's only five
minutes left
before 12 30.
i'm going to ask the indulgence of those
who are left to testify
that we can recess this hearing until
one o'clock
at that time we will resume
uh testimony
is the committee okay with that
okay then we will recess this hearing at
12 25 and come back at one o'clock
thank you
sponsors
don't worry about it
where do we go
um
[Music]
okay
is
thank you
oh
okay
[Music]
not yet
you know a little bit we'll want to hear
what
you have to offer
so we're resuming 12.65
it is now
and we'll call on
representative dan it's a
you're up
kiddo
and you've asked for
less than five minutes thank you
um
representative long um
made the uh raise the idea that
in session or
you change house rules regularly
but i want you to imagine
the equivalent of what happens to the
litigants and family court
you go into session
and normally you have an order of
precedence on the bills as to which
motions
supersede other motions
but what if on any particular bill
the
speaker might change the order of
precedence based upon whom the
representative was making the motion and
how much experience he thought they had
and that's the kind of situation you
have in family court
i understand
uh mr head's concern and some of the
concerns of the committee regarding
unintended consequences
number was the over 200 family court
rules
and this says that none of them can be
waived
and there will be unintended
consequences
i would suggest
that if the committee wanted was not
inclined to adopt the proposal before
them
that they might take a different measure
which is to require the judge
when he wants to waive a rule to cite
the rule that he's waving
make the justification for it
which makes it actionable on uh in
further hearings it can be objected to
um
it would it could then also be put into
a court or into a database
that would cite
the the judge
the case
the court rule the justification
and which party in the case
the what the rule was waived for
and that would give the judiciary and
the uh legislature
the power to see patterns
and if there is a pattern are there one
or two judges that are
principally involved in waiving the
rules
three or four limited number
when it when a judge is predisposed to
waive rules or disposed away rules is it
happening in favor of one party or the
other
those are very salient points as to know
and is there a particular rule that's
getting consistently waived
because
it's not written well or it's a bad rule
those are all parcels of information
that need to be brought out
if if
there were
a particular judge waiving rules
consistently
then
the legislature would be disposed to
removing that judge by impeachment
but you can't know what you you can't
act on what you don't know
i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you any questions
seeing nana i appreciate your time
next i'll call on is it gail
i can't
gail
does she choose not to come up
while she's getting her things together
i just want to let you know that we have
been receiving your emails
and i i just want you to know that this
during this these hearings this is not
the time for rebuttal
um so
your emails will be taken into
consideration they will not fall onto on
closed eyes
but there will be no rebuttal process
everybody's information is important to
us and
we're the ones that get to ask the
questions not the general audience
so we appreciate your emails but if you
don't get a response quickly that's why
gail you did not write in um a time
so i'll give you two minutes okay okay
thank you i'd like to give other
background but i'm going to submit it to
you so that that's no big deal but thank
you i am in support of this bill um i
think too many rules are being
overlooked
such as
opposing councils are
getting into private bank accounts
without properly
without even
letting the other party know
and the judges are not doing anything
about that so
i think that's a civil rights violation
and i
really think the judge should have
addressed that in the hearing
and not let that go so
i think it's very important that rules
should not be set aside for
for their peers
um so
any questions thank you any questions
seeing none
thank you for your time
next we have miss aaron justina
and you've asked for two minutes
and yes
good afternoon madam chair and members
of the committee my name is aaron
justina and i direct the domestic
violence advocacy project at new
hampshire legal assistance
i had not planned on testifying today i
did sign in opposed but
a quick review of the family court rules
i just wanted to point out a few things
that there are situations where it may
be beneficial and even safer for
litigants to have some discretion
in waiving some of these court rules and
i'll just give you a few examples if
that would be helpful thank you
rule 1.25 addresses discovery deadlines
it allows for
a response to interrogatories and
interrogatories
are those questions
that one side can ask to the other side
and there's a 30-day response
deadline to those interrogatories
so if someone had access to information
and it was beyond the 30 days
it may be helpful to the person's case
to have that information submitted um
and so it would be necessary if that
information wasn't available until after
the 30 days for a judge to say all right
upon request i've looked at that and
you know this is information that would
be helpful in this case so i'm going to
extend that deadline so that would be
helpful in that situation for that
rule to be waived
another one is rule 2.11 which
deals with first appearance
for those of you who don't know first
appearance is
required for all parties
either in a divorce or parenting case
involving minor children you have to
attend first appearance
and it gives you really
an idea of what the family court process
will look like and it's also the time
when your first
court deadlock court hearing or
mediation will be scheduled
that role 2.11 b requires attendance by
both parents
and both parents are expected to attend
the same first appearance
so if there's a domestic violence
situation where
it wouldn't be safe for the parties to
attend first appearance together you
would want to waive that court rule or
you would want to make a request that
that rule be waived
rule 2.10 involves the child impact
seminar
that rule states that any action
involving married or unmarried parents
of minor children the party shall attend
the child impact seminar um somebody may
make a request that this rule be waived
so for example if you didn't want to
have to let's say you attended a child
impact seminar two years ago and now
you're involved in a new family court
case where it's required that you attend
the child impact seminar again
you wouldn't want to necessarily since
probably not a whole lot of new material
in one or two years you may not want to
attend that child impact seminar again
it's time away from work time away from
your kids more money that's a very
lengthy seminar i think it's four hours
so you might want the judge to waive
that role so you don't have to attend
the child impact seminar again and you
can just show your certificate
rule 2.8 is in regards to children
testifying and that rule states a child
shall not be brought to court as a
witness
and i will just point out that
representative gay is a sponsor of a
bill this afternoon hb 1550 which seeks
to waive that very rule
so i did just want to point that out and
i appreciate your time in allowing me to
testify and to i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you for your time any questions
seeing none thank you
the final person to testify would be
representative cody belander
you've asked for three minutes
thank you madam chair and fellow members
of the committee i wasn't going to
testify today but
this bill is very important to me
i have testified before this committee
and has spoken to many of you
individually about my history with the
family court
most recently
referee foley
from the rochester district court dover
district court excuse me
um
told me in a court hearing that his
court his rules
he has an issue with pro se litigants
i am a pro se litigant because i
understand the law i may not have went
to school for it but it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure it out
interestingly enough after that hearing
i'd googled
referee foley
and he had and there is a yelp review
for the rochester district court
and specifically names referee foley
we have an issue
in our state and i've been saying this
for years prior to becoming a
representative and i'm saying it now
and i'll continue saying it until these
issues are fixed
judicial discretion is a problem within
our family court system
it needs to end
and i support the bill as written
and i'd be happy to take any questions
any questions
representative long
thank you madam chair
uh now the last speaker did you hear her
justification of waivers in
would you be opposed
to those waivers also
so i would
thank you for the question so i would be
opposed to any waiver that allows for
any form of judicial discretion
that allows for a judge to overrule any
judicial discretion that he sees or she
sees fit because
unfortunately
we see a lot of the times myself in the
two hearings with the two different
judges that i've had
in the
other
cases that i'm aware of families just in
my district alone
who are having these issues that there
are unintended biases towards families
and it's a problem
great thanks thank you
thank you
seeing no other questions and seeing no
other pink cards
i will close the hearing on
1265.
we're going to now re open the hearing
on house bill 1142
i believe the
prime sponsor would like to speak
and i'll need a pink card
turn on your microphone dear
thank you
relative to the right to submit evidence
and testimony family court proceedings
as we have just been discussing
right now
some of the rules are make give
tremendous discretion and this rule is
written in
that
on test
issue of testimony
and
evidence you cannot present it
in your case unless the judge
gives you permission
so it's not a right
and then we learn that if you appeal
your case as currently you would appeal
to the supreme court
you can't bring it up then
so um
that's why it's very simple we just want
to get rid of that rule and so that
people have the right to present
uh evidence
and testimony
so if you have any questions
thank you any questions
seeing none i appreciate your time thank
you next i'd like to call uh
richard head
uh you're asking for five minutes
probably won't either thank you kindly
thank you
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
this bill would
put in the in the
give the capacity to any party to
provide any testimony or any evidence
whatsoever so for example let's take
this hearing that we're here for today
it's not that unlike a court proceeding
you have a lot of people you have a lot
of bills you have a lot of people that
want to come testify
and you have a limited amount of time so
you are limiting the amount of time that
i have to speak
appropriately so because everyone's
testimony is important all the issues
are important and what you're asking is
that we come and present testimony that
is relevant to the bill that's before
you and we've heard that today too
and that's what a judge is doing when
they're in a proceeding and they're
asking
for the for the
parties to
present evidence that is relevant to the
case the way this bill reads is
the parties in any proceeding have the
right to present evidence and testimony
as written it is unlimited
they can come and provide testimony on
anything they can come and provide
evidence on anything and it's unlimited
in terms of time and scope so what the
significant concern about this bill at
least as written is that
every case can get out of hand almost
immediately you have a judge who is who
has a number of cases that have to be
heard that day all of them are
incredibly important
all of the information is important and
what the judges need is testimony that
relates to the issue that is before the
judge and evidence that is related to
that issue and once you start going
outside of that you start to lose the
ability to to hear all of the cases that
day to have all of the parties present
information and testimony and as written
this would essentially provide
unfettered
discretion on the parties as to what
they present how long they're presenting
and
uh the nature of that of that
information and evidence and quickly all
hearings will get out of control and
that's the reason why the judge needs to
be able to control what is the evidence
and what is the testimony if the intent
to this bill is to say
every case you're entitled to have
evidence and testimony okay again these
are family court proceedings which again
we don't family court family division
these are not
all marital cases
every party does have a right to an
evidentiary hearing in a in a marital
case
unless waived
that said not every issue is entitled to
a trial you get ultimately on the on the
case itself an evidentiary hearing
unless it is waived
but
what is really very unclear about this
bill is
what what types of of cases what types
of i'm sorry what type yeah what types
of cases are we talking about
um
because not every case needs to have a
hearing so there are large number of
probate cases that get resolved without
a hearing it just happens but that is
the
and and so in in family division there
are also other types of cases that do
not need a hearing to be resolved
this this bill just as written is so
broad that it it will it will
prevent the courts from doing anything
and being able to do their their jobs
and be able to get to the issues and to
be able to resolve those issues
unless you want to add
a significantly larger court system
and i don't think that's ultimately your
goal
it just is not manageable as written so
we would oppose this bill as written
thank you i'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you do i see any questions
representative long thank you madam
chair so in your opinion the parties
shall have the right to present evidence
and testimony
is that just the parties presented
evidence and testimony or do you read
this as
the testimony can be from
anybody
the the bills about the parties um okay
so but it doesn't say at what stage so
is it the initial
the initial conference um to the final
trial
but it but at least that's written it's
the parties okay thank you
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
next i'll call on katrina henrik
you've asked for three minutes
and again i'll
remind you that if you have written
testimony please submit it for the
record
again i'm katrina heinrich
i am here for this bill because i do
believe it is an important bill
any party should have the right to
evidence in my case
the court denied my right to due process
as guaranteed by the 5th and 14th
amendments of the bill of rights the
excuse i understand
is rule 1.2 and 2.2.
but there's no explanation as to why
that is
the family division is
a piece of our court system
that should afford litigants to have the
right to evidence
and testimony just like a civil and
criminal case
i understand that we want to make it
family friendly
but that's not what is occurring in
twenty percent of these cases if not a
larger number
in my case orders are then written
without due process but carry the burden
of legally binding decisions
with consequences and no options for
recourse
and we've already heard testimony about
how recourse is
very unapproachable
as previously testified and i do hate to
repeat this but it is about this bill
no evidence or witness testimony was
permitted
in post-divorce proceedings again this
is a post-divorce proceeding that should
have never happened
all life history
was eliminated
you can't bring in any facts you get
nothing you get zero
without the ability to submit evidence
or history and orders victims
to be legally bound to their abusers
without due process and in my case there
was abuse it is well documented there is
criminal records
furthermore this failure of due process
opens the door for coercion slander
allegations gaslighting corruption
moreover
and more
i feel like you could almost call it
court facilitated abuse
but the question is why
why is that allowed that's why we're
here today is to look at the laws look
at the facts look at what is not as
working there is a pattern it is not
just in the state of new hampshire
this is across the united states of
america there is about three states that
do not have this problem
all other states do
henceforth
i have already commended the governor
for signing
the proclamation for the family court
awareness month which again has embedded
in it
supporting facts and evidence that this
is real
i think i'll end on that because i know
that there's other testimony
thank you very much
any any questions
seeing none thank you
next i'll call on uh alicia broshu
you've asked for two three minutes
that's correct yes
i'm sorry what said that's correct yes
and thank you for hearing me again
um
i am testifying in support of this bill
um the purpose of the judiciary is to
look at the facts
and apply those facts to the law then
issue orders and concurrence with the
law how is the judiciary supposed to
ethically do so if the parties do not
have the right to submit evidence to
support their claims
if a judge is permitted to look at one
of the parting parties and say no i'm
not accepting your evidence it creates a
bias to the entire proceedings
i've witnessed the judicial referee
tell my husband that she would not
accept evidence that he had that his
oldest child graduated high school that
evidence was public
when they post the graduates
in the public in the newspaper instead
she took the mother's word that even
though he was almost 19
he was still enrolled
this led to my husband paid child
support for a year longer than the
statutory requirements because i think
it was like
uh a month into the hearings when he
first filed that the child actually
turned at 19.
i witnessed the judge refused my husband
evidence that the mother forged a
paternity test to make it look like he
was not the father of his youngest he
has with her that evidence was from in
the form of a police report where she
confessed to the officer that she forged
the test to alienate him from his
daughter
i've witnessed the judge refused my
husband's evidence that the mother of
his daughters lied to a mental health
provider by claiming that there was a
restraining order in place for the
purpose of preventing him from taking
part in the children's therapy that
evidence was in the form of the
children's mental health records
i've witnessed the judge refused my
husband evidence that she lied to the
court the mother and a financial
affidavit and did not disclose that she
was receiving tanf benefits for the
children
that evidence was in the form of a
letter directly from the department of
health and human services that confirmed
that the children were receiving the
benefit and as well as the date that
they started receiving the benefit
i've witnessed the judge refused my
husband's evidence that the children's
maternal grandfather threatened to pack
up his daughter and her children and
leave the states so he would never see
them again and there would be nothing he
could do about it that evidence was in
the form of a recording of the voicemail
he left a threat on my husband was
trying to obtain an ex parte order to
prevent the threatened kidnapping
in one of my husband's older case files
where the judge refused his evidence
that the dcyf worker caseworker never
attempted to contact him before she
initiated court proceedings she
testified that she tried to contact him
by phone his evidence was his certified
phone records
proving that she lied
he said i wasn't going to take it and he
had to deal with over a year of jumping
through dcyf hoops to get access to his
children back
when a judge refuses to accept evidence
then on the record all they have to base
the decision on is one party's word
against the other that allows them to
claim that one party was more credible
than the other and pick and choose how
they will issue orders based on their
own personal personal biases because
according to and the family courts don't
have evidentiary rules but the superior
court does and in superior court
evidentiary rules physical evidence has
a higher weight that they have to look
at than just testimony so when you
eliminate physical evidence now you just
have the testimony and they can say well
you know i kind of like the way that
that person looks better i think that
they look like they wouldn't lie to me
um
so it enforces their personal biases and
it oftentimes leads to orders that are
not in the best interest of the children
thank you
thank you any questions
representative alterla
thank you madam chair
is this working yes yeah okay thank you
um thank you so much for your testimony
today and um and all of the testimony
you've presented throughout the day um
just so
i can wrap my head around the
mechanics of how this is playing out um
it sounds like
i'll ask just about your case
specifically are there ones that you
have first-hand knowledge of
what does it look like
and what is the occasion
that a judge that there's
evidence to be presented
and
the judge refuses
is it during the course of
a
case review or it's during the course
so basically what happens is you will
file a motion
um
you are not you don't file exhibits with
the motion
you submit exhibits when you go into
hearing
so when you go into hearing
um
you know a professional currency you
give the other party you know your
evidence beforehand but you don't have
to do that with family court um you
could just show up with whatever so what
it looks like is you go
um
my claims are supported in paragraph
one two and three of my motion um by
these exhibits and the judge looks at
the bailiff and he says bailiff um can
you take this and he does one of these
that's exactly what it looks like and
then there's no reference to them in any
orders and they are not even in the case
file when you go to take the case file
thank you for
for demonstrating how that how that what
that experience is like and um yeah it's
very disheartening um especially when
you're submitting evidence
that
like i said family courts don't have
rule of evidence but the superior court
does
um so
in my husband's cases he made sure that
everything would at least be
submittable
by because you have to make sure you're
submitting credible evidence um so when
a judge is looking at a police report
proving that the mother is actively
alienating the child to the point where
she forged a medical document
and she admitted that to police
and the judge is
doesn't even want to hear it when
the action in front of the judge is to
restrict her decision-making because
she's not able to make good decisions
for the children you know it's very very
disheartening
thank you
any further questions representative
belanger
thank you madam chair thank you man for
being here today with your testimony and
i appreciate it and i'm sorry you've had
to go through this
so again i'm going to preface and i'll
get to my point
so
in my hearings
i present
if i haven't provided the evidence
beforehand
i asked the judge if he will accept it
and he or she technically but in my case
i've had both male judges
um
he will say it is up to the other party
if they have to if they will accept it
or not they have to review it and then
go through it and then i can give it to
the bailiff who will then give it to the
judge is that not happening
um
the
uh the hearing the child support hearing
um that was in front of referee culligan
um and was issued by judge foley that
did not happen she just absolutely
refused it
um the other cases uh was judge burns
and judge paulie hall
um judge burns was better about it he
did give the other party you know the
ability to say you know here did you
look at it is that okay with you know do
you accept it or or did you want to
rebut it um but paulie hall was the one
that liked to just take things and just
kind of throw them in the trash
so it really depends on the judge
follow up
and by paulie hall you mean thank you
madam chair and thank you for answering
my question by paulie hall you're
referring to judge hall correct judge
yes i'm sorry judge paulie hall thank
you yeah the one that recently made the
papers thank you
no further question
man questions from anyone else
thank you very much
thank you
next we'll call on uh
the former representative dan itza
you've asked for five minutes can we
thank you not a problem
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
i am still dan itza and i still reside
in manchester
um
the
making sure that both parties have equal
opportunity to present evidence to the
court in these decisions
is critical to receiving
to the parties receiving justice
[Music]
in past years i have submitted submitted
legislation that would require
uh that the evidence be submitted five
days before the hearing so that each
party has the opportunity for discovery
and the capacity to rebut
evidence that's spurious or or
false
i don't know that this is the best
presentation but the issue is clear and
present
you have to make sure that the parties
have the opportunity to present relevant
evidence
to the court
and that both parties have the
opportunity to to examine that evidence
before they get in the courtroom
i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you any questions
or seeing none thank you very much
next we have angela lozia
you've asked for five minutes
can we
thank you madam chairwoman and committee
again my name is angela luja for the
record
i'm resident here of concord new
hampshire
um i'm just going to kind of give some
examples because again like you guys
have heard i'm fresh out of court so
i'm going to give more examples more
than
kind of other things so in my case there
was a reference of collateral resources
that the gal catherine schoenenberg and
opposing council mentioned
one is my daughter's school teacher and
the other is my daughter's therapist
a parent teacher night the fifth grade
teacher spoke to my ex and i followed up
with an email to the teacher
then the fifth grade teacher changed his
story what happened in my case is
everyone involved had a different story
about the fifth grade teacher kathleen
sternberg wrote one thing in her cal
report
i got a different story
and my ex said another thing
so nobody agreed with what the fifth
grade teacher
was saying he didn't come to court to
testify that would have been nice
excuse me regarding my daughter's
therapist kim thurlow there there is no
email communication that i could find in
kim thurlow's record
stated anything regarding my parenting
or her concerns or her recommendation
on that bill summary it reflected phone
calls primarily
this is
conflicting hearsay evidence and i'm
just hoping that we can fix that with
this bill
any collateral resources that are
referenced in a gal recommendation
weren't subpoenaed for the final hearing
nor was i given a fair opportunity to
rebuke
some of those concerning allegations to
support the gal's recommendation
on november 30th 2020
there was a
a status hearing to review kathleen's
report kathleen recommended that my
daughter go live with her father
kathleen stated in court that my
daughter would be harmed if the current
parenting plan was not changed which was
an exhibit
which we
which is an exhibit in support of
hb 1346 and establishing a commission to
study new hampshire family court systems
early today that i testified at
kathleen had not completed her
investigation she had owned she hadn't
not finished speaking with parties on my
end before filing her report with the
court
a pre
premature recommendation without
completing her investigation
another collateral
resource that kathleen failed to reach
out to was my therapist of many years
that i signed a release for catherine
and for my therapist
speaking with
my therapist would have been beneficial
when making assumptions as kathleen had
about me
kathleen sternburn only reached out to
my therapist
after the status hearing in her
recommendation to remove my child
there were allegations made to dcyf in
march of 2020
that were unfounded kathleen sternenberg
never pulled the final report from dcuf
to review it was alleged i was doing
drugs in her report i voluntarily took a
hair follicles
test which was negative to refute
the allegations of drug use in
kathleen's report there was no evidence
submitted in the form of police reports
or other information in support of any
danger to my daughter that would justify
kathleen sterling bird's recommendation
in all my years i have never been
convicted
of any crime
or had any calls made on me to dcyf
meanwhile my ex had three duis that
wasn't a concern to her the court took
kathleen's recommendation
on a 20-minute status hearing through
webex prior to our final hearing which
was scheduled for january 28 2021
so they completely ignored the evidence
i submitted to rebut false allegations
of drug use but took kathleen starring
sterling birds made up claims instead
after the temporary hearing was granted
from the status hearing in november 2020
i submitted a couple videos to kathleen
that my daughter sent me dated one was 6
1 2009 stating help me
this was four months prior to my ex
motioning the court for custody
this video is alarming along with other
recordings of my daughter talking
about her stepmother hitting her and
other alarming information that would
hopefully make kathleen look at things a
little bit closer
this didn't change her recommendation at
the final hearing it was discredited and
never did she ever mention it in her
final report even though i addressed
these concerns on my first interview
and in my questionnaire
and didn't think i would have to send i
didn't think i would have to send the
videos however she did bill for the time
to review them
um again more evidence that was simply
disregarded i also provided multiple
text messages between my daughter and
myself prior to court to demonstrate the
relationship we had
texas between my daughter's therapist
and myself about the video helped me
mentioned above text message documenting
my daughter was not happy with her
father and stepmom and clearly
wasn't mature to have a say in this
final decision
but
all that was just ignored so i just
so i support bill
hb1142 because the court didn't look at
the evidence i gave them and just took
kathleen sternberg's word on everything
thank you any any questions
cnn thank you man thank you
oh i'm sorry representative
blander
thank you mr truman and thank you for
being here today and providing another
heartbreaking testimony thanks um
in relevance to this and your guardian
at lydem do you have the same judge
that had a conflict of interest
no i have i what i have heard today is
the last marital master um thomas cooper
thank you
call erica brent
thank you mr chair committee members
uh for the record eric brand
i'm from nashua
um
i am here in support of hb 1142
is a perfect example of why previous
bill number 1265 is so important because
these judges tend to
take uh and make their own rules so this
is just another great example of this
i'm gonna give you a story which i
haven't been able to share yet with this
committee and other testimonies
five minutes prior to my temporary
hearing
the opposing attorney brought in
a motion to the judge asking that i
basically wipe out my entire life
savings from my
deferred tax account and pay it to the
other opposing party
there was no hearing no evidence
provided at that particular time
there was an order that was given with
the rest of the
um temporary orders
to pay the pay
the opposing party the balance of the
tax offer to count all penalties and tax
liabilities within five days
meanwhile we never had a chance to
provide evidence
or to show anything during that
temporary hearing let alone having that
motion given to us prior to the hearing
with enough time to prepare for it
so once we receive the order we'd filed
a motion to reconsider
my attorney used many laws that were
backing up our claim
that motion to reconsider was denied and
there was threaten of incarceration to
myself
we then filed a motion to stay on the
payment requested a hearing
eventually five months later we had this
hearing
we provided evidence
in over 500 checks
in account statements to show
where prior funds had been used
these the evidence that we provided was
uncontested at the time by the opposing
party or the judge
and that was all based on money that was
spent
before the actual divorce proceedings
started and but prior to the anti
hypothetication order was even issued
after the hearing
we finally received the orders the
orders continued to say
pay the balance of the funds the fines
the taxes and now attorney fees
and additional fines
and then there was continued threats of
incarceration if we didn't pay it
the judge's answer this was former judge
intracaso as to why i had to pay it
had nothing to do with the evidence that
was provided
she said
you're paying it because i ordered you
two
this bill demands the court to listen to
both parties and make rulings that are
affecting their lives
without this bill
and hb 1265 we're leaving all this
discretion up to the judges
that could have a biased opinion against
somebody
and it's just leaving way too much in
the hands of somebody else to make
decisions and taking away from our civil
rights
both
we we heard earlier today and i'll quote
the judges rely on evidence provided
i wasn't allowed evidence to be provided
and ruled upon within my case
it was completely ignored
both bill 1265 and
1142 are being proposed to stop this
bias judgment ensure all parties are
getting a fair hearing
and to ensure ensure their civil rights
are left intact
we're talking about people's lives here
in the lives of their children and how
they're being affected
thank you
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you thank you
next i'd like to call uh dina albrecht
i got your name right this time
thank you i just want to say i support
the intent of this bill but i fully
respect mr head's concerns just want to
say that almost all police reports
entered into evidence in my case were
completely ignored in so far as
substantial testimony about them was
never mentioned in any narrative order
so i just ask how we can
maybe craft something via amendment that
addresses both the concerns
of
all of the aggrieved parties here in
family court
uh as well as the concerns of the
judicial branch
i mean i don't think we want to get rid
of like legitimate motions in lemonade
or something like that so i'd really
like to see something that addresses the
issue and maybe we just fix the language
thank you
thank you any questions
thank you very much thank you
next we have vivian gerard
you've asked for one minute
i might actually only need like 30
seconds
um
madame chairwoman and members of the
children
and family law committee
in my case judge and dicasso refused to
allow me to submit evidence in the
hearing
and didn't admit
it on record at all i want to be clear
that she did not even tell me why
it's not like my ex's attorney even
asked judge intercasso to exclude it by
filing a motion
my entire divorce
would have ended up completely different
if the judge just took in my evidence
thank you
any questions
thank you any questions
representative alterla
thank you madam chair thank you very
much for taking my question um at the
time i'm going to ask you a question
that i asked a previous witness
what did that look like at the time you
showed up in the room you had paper
how did you
like how did it play out that's what i
want to yep i want to see it if you
don't mind yup thank you so at the time
that i was in court my ex's attorney
gave in their package and they started
um
going through my employment
and she asked if if i had seeked any
employment
and my attorney turned around and said
i don't have it in my hand but i can get
it to you she says nope
and
not only did she
not look at that
that actually was the whole reason why
she took child support away from me
um i had a work log i also own a bed and
breakfast she told me that my
hobby
needed to be shut down within six months
and and said i'm glad you're trying to
live the all-american dream but go out
and get a real job but what she also
didn't look at which i tried to submit
was the fact that my income dropped
more than half
because my ex at the time
took my facebook my instagram my booking
engine my website shut everything down
because he was the one that started to
get it
going he was the technical guru
he set up the websites and all these
accounts he had all the passwords he had
tucked his email behind so when i tried
to go in and re-change the password
it went back to him as a
hey your password was changed
i didn't know anything about the
technical parts of this because that was
his specialty
i had an email from
um one of the um
the accounts that i was trying to get
reestablished
and they acknowledged that it was shut
down by mr silva
and that alone
would have showed the judge
that
my income was affected which made it
look like a hobby because
he tampered with my
accounts
until this day if you look at how much
money i make
it's probably
triple of what it was back at the very
beginning of the divorce so as soon as i
re-established those accounts but it
took me a year i had to have court
documents to say that i was awarded the
business i had to show all my um
my my passports i had to show my my um
operation operating plan i had to sh i
had to prove to them that this business
was only established by me
we bought the property together but the
business was 100 mine he had no
involvement whatsoever so by not proven
to the court
these things that has happened
affected my child support tremendously
and as i said i've been doing this for
seven years
and
it he shouldn't have been tampering with
those documents
is that enough okay
any other questions
any further questions
thank you very much
um and we have one more person to
testify and that's gail
i'm sorry i can't dribble it
you did not
specify how much time you need so i'll
give you two minutes it'll just be very
very brief
um
thank you again for allowing me to
testify before you my name is gail
drobat for the record and i am in
support of house bill 1142 i feel it's
imperative that all litigants be allowed
to submit evidence
as this is not happening the judges are
picking and choosing who submits
evidence what can be submitted to the
extent when a litigant files
a motion to add evidence it's denied and
then opposing counsel will submit
evidence
second day of trial can you speak into
the
microphone please thank you
do you need me to start over
no um
the judge's um opposing counsel submits
evidence that is not ascended to second
day of a final trial and leaves out a
portion of the exhibit
the attorney makes material
misrepresentations to the court
interfering with the judicial process
for the judge to make a non-biased
decision on her material
misrepresentations
again the judges are defying their
judicial canons by not treating each
litigant with respect when not being
represented by a member of the new
hampshire bar
thank you
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much and with
that i will close the hearing on house
bill 1142
i'll now open the hearing on house bill
1551.
representative gay
thank you madam chair
um
i did pass out earlier
well i hope i did
uh a pink sheet
did everybody get that
uh that's testimony from the person
whose
parents
entire contents of their house were
being delivered to her house today at 11
or all days
she points out
she points out the whole point of my
bill
which is
to give justice to people who are not
rich
it's
extremely expensive to have transcripts
made the the recordings of hearings are
25 to 35 dollars so that's doable
but if you get a transcript which is
what you need to pursue a case
it's
fifteen hundred dollars is is a drop in
the bucket
uh she says in her testimony that she
has spent twenty five thousand dollars
just on
transcripts
um
and
i'm sorry i'm not focusing because i'm
thinking of so many issues that affect
every single one of the bills uh one is
that these court proceedings go on and
on and on and it's part of harassment
because if you have enough money and
you're mad you can just keep going back
to court and it causes the person that
you're filing against to have to spend
money and take time away from work
and uh answer you so it's gets extremely
expensive it is a method of of torture
um so this bill simply says
that the written transcripts
each party
under the jurisdiction of this chapter
shall have the right to create their own
written transcripts of the court
proceedings
and we can certainly
some of the other bills that we've
talked we will be talking about about
submitting them in appeals you know we
can put controls in so that they have to
um
they have to
designate what time a certain thing
a certain
whatever's important they have to say
at what
time and you know in the minutes what is
the right word to say the chronological
order of your transcript has to match
the the official tape or
in the case of some other bills that
take that the recording you made
to be compared to the official when
they're different
so uh it's just a matter of money
because it excludes the rules that they
are that you must buy the transcripts
from this one company
in arizona which i understand is
considered modest by uh new hampshire
standards
you still have no other option
and if you can't come up the transcript
your appeal
i've seen it
denied
and the weird thing is if you're a
criminal
and you don't have money you are given a
let's see not prosecutor what you're
given an attorney
but lord help you if you're just a poor
person who's been hounded in family
court
so
thank you
any questions from representative gay
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative k for bringing um this
forward
i guess
my take is while i understand that
um
the the cost is is high perhaps maybe
looking at it
and figuring out a way to make it more
affordable but
i i just
do you not see this as an issue that
anybody can can transcribe an
interpretation
an interpretation
of
the recording
do you need to clarify well i would
think that uh the the opposing person
whoever's on the other side of this
hearing
would be very happy to listen to the
recording and to point out any
discrepancies
so i really think that you're always
going to have somebody checking
on your work and now that we have
software that converts spoken word to
written word
it's be a lot more uh
you know you'd have to
once you had that you'd go back and edit
it to make sure you had paragraphs and
everything but i would think that the
opposing
party would be happy to say you didn't
do this right here's here's my
transcript
follow up
so then it becomes
thank you madam chair and thank you for
answering the question so then again to
further that issue then it becomes a he
said she said situation and then it just
kind of
bounces off i think there's a i guess do
you not see that as a problem because i
i would rather see something along the
lines of finding it more affordable to
get transcripts are you proposing an
amendment representative no i'm trying
to ask her if she would
if she doesn't see that as a problem and
maybe
she could come back with an amendment
thank you that's where i'm going with
that
well you're welcome to write an
amendment too
i certainly appreciate help
one of the real serious issues
is that multiple people have told me
that when they get
recordings
the recordings aren't even right
so we're talking about because they were
edited as they were made
that we talked about this last week so
i'm sorry that i'm revisiting it but
it's the three issues are tied together
making a recording
making a transcription
submitting it with i have three separate
bills so they can be all argued on their
own behalf
if you're what currently
you are stuck with the recording
and it could be edited and we have many
people who can testify that the
recording
omits some really questionable things
that the judge or court personnel said
so if you get the recording
and yours is different
we're not proposing that anybody
file an appeal and just use their own
they would have to submit the official
recording and the official transcript
but then here's my recording and here's
my transcript it's one of those real
serious things that we have no proof of
right now until you can submit your own
and make your own
and uh it's so important that i think
if we do it finally
uh people who are
misbehaving that's the nicest word i can
think of will know they're going to get
caught and there ought to be teeth in it
too you know you you're going to be
reviewed if you do things like this and
and you get caught so no i didn't think
it was simple i don't think it's easy
but i think it's real important to
address that problem
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
next i'll call on
richard head
you've asked for five minutes and we'll
try to squeeze it down a little bit
please
i will thank you thank you um thank you
madam chair members of the committee my
name is richard head i'm the government
affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch
we're obviously very sensitive to the
issue of cost
it does cost money litigation costs
money transcripts are expensive and i
don't disagree with that i've certainly
represented enough clients who
raised concerns about the price of
transcripts on appeal the transcripts
sorry
the transcripts are a necessary element
of the appeal
and
the court relies upon it and not just
those parts that are identified in
briefs but the whole record uh as it's
been submitted to the court
this this bill as as written has no
it actually i'm sorry i did take a look
at the cost of transcripts in the other
new england states
and the cost of transcripts that new
hampshire charges is
almost in almost all cases lower than
our other new england states or the same
so we're not charging sort of an
outrageous amount as compared to the
other states but it is it does cost
money and i'm sensitive to that
the
issue though is is really the
reliability of that transcript because
that transcript does become the record
and it does become what the judges at
the supreme court are ultimately looking
at and ruling upon
and
the current requirement does have a
certified transcriber or a certified
record from a transcriber
that is filed with the court that is
sort of
an incredibly important part of of
ensuring that the the supreme court
record is accurate
that said mistakes do happen and if
those are raised
with the court they can be addressed at
some level
but as written this
has no standards for what that
transcript would look like it could for
example as written this bill would allow
for a handwritten transcript of somebody
who is taking notes in the back of the
room i'm not saying that's the intent of
of the of the sponsor
what i'm saying though is as written
this bill has absolutely no criteria or
standards for what it is that would be
submitted as a transcript um so we have
significant concerns about about the
writ the bill is written
i'd be happy to answer any questions
however thank you any questions
i i should also point out there is a
provision in the supreme court rules
that allows for the parties if they can
agree understanding these are highly
contentious
cases if they can agree and file a
stipulation of the facts you don't need
to submit a transcript you don't need to
submit those records and essentially
that's a no-cost alternative i recognize
the the limitations of that but i just
want to point it out thank you
representative belandra
thank you madam chair
uh i did and uh thank you mr head for
your question uh for answering this
question i did think of one actually
before you take off do you know what the
cost is
per transcript
so it there's a it depends uh part of my
answer it depends on the
turnaround time
so a 45 day turnaround it's
2.75 cents a page in in new hampshire
massachusetts it's three dollars
connecticut three dollars and rhode
island it's three to five dollars
but new hampshire is 2.75 cents a page
for a 45-day turnaround
thank you
any further questions
thank you again thank you
next i'll call on representative kurt
welper
representative you've asked for one
minute
uh thank you madam chair yes for the
record my name is representative kurt
welper i represent stratfor district
three
and i just wanted to clarify something
that i heard representative gay say and
maybe just give you just a tiny bit of
what why
she's got a bill in judiciary as well
that deals with this type of thing i'm
supportive of this bill
because it allows
the individuals to make their own
transcripts
for which they have to have their own
recordings and part of the problem
with what goes on in family court is
that the judge
controls the recording so if the judge
doesn't want to have some stuff recorded
the judge just presses a button
and recording stops
if
the participants were able to make their
own recordings and make their own
transcripts from their recordings then
there would be
a fuller record than what is often
contained in the official transcript
so
i think this is a
needed check at this time
the testimony we heard was that well if
you wanted to put
a court stenographer in the family court
that would solve that problem and it
likely would but it would also cost a
bundle
so this is a way of uh handling the
situation to provide full evidence
for the participants and for the courts
in later hearings
and with that
i'm done
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much next
i'll call katrina henrik
and you've asked for three minutes
and hopefully we can squish that down
okay so i do have a just an example a
visual example this is actually a cd
recording
of the last hearing that i had
this was unobtainable for me
to get written it was going to cost me a
thousand dollars for a one-day trial
there's no way
while getting this it still needs to be
translated in some form of print
in order to be accepted for any court
proceedings
this is important to me because on this
day
the guardian at latem specifically
talked about how he was going to pass
this envelope that i had no right to the
contents to
and
that he was a gal that represented more
men than women
not children he represented
over 50 percent
men
but he called it about equal
that's critical evidence
with that said
this was a significant issue in my case
there is inherent denial of access due
to the extremism of the cost burden
to the access of written or audio
content
of record of the court proceedings
transcription fees are technology
technology
excuse me technologically
unnecessary
with modern technology and software
to that point the current way the court
uses the technology to record hearings
shows mistrust
as evidenced by discrepancies and family
court records
the importance of transcripts is
critical specifically when there is
conflicting data
a case i intended for another family
court litigant specifically has missing
testimony that i witnessed by judge
foley
who also
was stopping and starting with clicks
and feet devices he was in full view
this happened to be a time in the case
where he berated
one of the litigants
it brings into question how the court
software is controlled
reviewed
and if it's true to what actually
occurred in the courtroom
so a solution to me
because we do have technology we do have
software
is something as simple as a travel drive
is very inexpensive
each litigate can have it
the court has a copy of its own records
there has got to be a workable solution
for this
access
to records needs to be obtainable to all
parties so that
personal transcribing software even
manual
could work but i would disagree with
that and go more with
a travel drive that that is that is
verbally what occurred in the courtroom
discrepancy is more than just a
financial issue for someone like me
that's trying to obtain the actual
records that occurred
but but it's also an issue of
discrepancy of what actually occurred in
the courtroom
which more often than not has showed
missing data on transcripts we've we've
obtained
i think this could be at least the start
if there if there is possibly an
amendment
to solutions that could start restoring
the integrity of the family court with a
new form of checks and balances
and on this topic
i thank you
thank you any questions
representative long
i'm not sure if you will know this or
not but
i could you just transcribe the
portion that you wanted
or do you have to transcribe the whole
day the whole
hearing in in that particular case on
this one that i spoke of
we were not sure
what time of day it occurred so we had
to have the entire day we had no time
stamp to know otherwise
okay
thank you
and our final person is dana albrecht
you've asked for 30 seconds
based on prior testimony we might want
to bump that up to one minute and i'll
still keep it short again still dana
albrecht just like to say in my recent
supreme court appeal
the official transcript from e-scribers
left out key portions of the audio
causing the new hampshire supreme court
to order an amended transcript
the stuff they left out was key to the
court's order to vacate and remand
so i believe that's one problem
that a lot of people here are trying to
fix and i certainly support
fixing that
i think another problem people here
trying to fix is cost and i point out
that a company like speech pad widely
used in the entertainment industry
is much cheaper than a company like
escribers
widely used in the judicial system
um
i don't want to take that too far but i
just like to echo
uh mr head's point
that if the parties
in a case
uh can reach some sort of stipulation
that a transcript a far lesser cost
that perhaps they prepared themselves
from their own recording
is sufficient to decide the records on
appeal and they agree to that
i don't see why the court shouldn't take
that just as a starting point to address
some of these issues thank you happy to
take questions thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
time thank you madam chair
and with that we will close
um
house bill 1551.
we will now open house bill 1550
and
did you amendment and it takes words out
so it doesn't make it longer
representative gay did you pass in a
pink card
thank you
thank you madam chair
this is very very simple we just took
out a couple of words
twice
right now children do not have a right
no matter how old they are they do not
have a right to testify
and some children
some children are not it's not
appropriate for them to
testify
but i've certainly met teenagers who are
frustrated out of their mind that they
cannot speak
uh
they cannot speak
on their
you know all these decisions that weigh
excess heavily on them
so
that's why this one uh well
i'm so sorry that i'm such a poor
speaker so
thank you for being patient
uh house bill 1550
says the court shall permit a child 12
years of age or older to testify orally
at any proceeding proceeding determining
parental rights and responsibilities
and the court may permit a child
under 12 years at the discretion of the
judge
and we
how we change this is he used to say the
child could testify
orally
or and um
the official terminology for
a signed statement that's witnessed
i can't remember adjectives but it means
it's officially legal somebody's
observed it it's not just a child write
something and hands it in
but after discussing this with several
people
uh
court
court experienced people said
we'd never accept a child's submission
of something written
as testimony because you can't
cross-examine them
and we don't define
how the judge would take the testimony
because we figure that's the discretion
of the judge
how to do it
so that's the entire
point of this
and there is a
i
hope i've passed out
a pink sheet on this
if i'm not i've got to go find them
but it's testimony from
the mother who's
can't show up today because of all days
but
she her children were desperate to be
heard
and they would write letters to the uh
to the judges
but of course the letters didn't go
anywhere
so
i'm thinking of all the kids who really
really want to be heard
to give them that opportunity if they're
12 or older
and then if they're
under 12 for the judge to decide whether
that's appropriate
thank you any questions
yes
um
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my my question how was the age of
12 determined
out of thin air
okay in the past in the past i've heard
in the in the past kids could
and have input and that may have been 12
that may have been 14. so i just took
the the younger of the two
thank you thank you
any further questions
thank you representative
next i'll call
richard head
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch the we do have
significant concerns about this bill as
written the the uh
the risk of manipulation of a 12 year
old is immense
and the
requirement without any discretion on
the part of
of the court to
allow a 12 year old or older to testify
creates
significant
risk to that to that minor
in terms of manipulation by by apparent
um threats that that child if you don't
testify a certain way
you know the consequences will be x uh
to pit a 12 year old against two parents
to have a 12 year old cross-examined on
the stand
um i mean it's it's hard enough for an
adult
but to have 12 13 14 15 year olds
required
without any discretion of the court
would
be potentially significantly detrimental
be happy to answer any questions but as
written we would oppose it
thank you
any questions
representative long
thank you madam chair um
does the judge have the discretion now
to
speak to the child in his uh
what what typically happens is there
would be a motion by a party to to allow
that and then then the judge would uh
talk to the child in chambers
so it would be a motion
if i may thank you so it would be
one of the parties would be requesting
it correct
okay thank you
any further questions
thank you very much thank you
next i'll call upon aaron justina
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee um i did rece
send a written testimony last evening by
email
i have extra copies if anyone needs it
again my name is aaron justina and i
direct the domestic violence advocacy
project at new hampshire legal
assistance
new hampshire legal assistance is in
opposition of house bill 15
fn
nhla is a statewide nonprofit law firm
our attorneys and paralegals
represent low-income and aging clients
in civil cases
involving urgent basic needs including
safety from domestic violence and
stalking
nhla's domestic violence advocacy
project provides free legal advice and
representation to low-income victims and
survivors of domestic violence sexual
assault and stalking in high lethality
protective order cases and divorce and
parenting cases and when i say high
lethality cases i'm referring to cases
where there is a significant risk
that the victim will be killed or
seriously injured by their abuser
in 2021 nhla represented 207 victims and
survivors and spent over 9 500 hours
representing victims and survivors in
new hampshire courts statewide
house bill 1550 fn requires the court to
permit any child 12 years of age or
older to testify orally or in writing at
any proceeding to determine parental
rights and responsibilities and as we
just heard regarding the amendment gives
discretion to a judge to allow a child
under the age of 12 to testify
while i'm sure this bill is well
intended this bill is problematic for
the following reasons
one this bill is not in the best
interest of children
someone testified earlier today that
children don't deserve to be put in the
middle but if called to testify children
may perceive their participation as
forcing them to choose between their
parents which is a harmful proposition
in the best of circumstances
but consider an abuser skilled in the
art of coercive control and manipulation
grooming their 12 year old child to
testify against the other parent at a
final parenting hearing what is to stop
that parent from making threats for
example to kill the child's beloved
family pet to harm or kill the child
or to harm or kill the child's sibling
if they don't testify exactly how they
want them to
the answer is nothing will stop them
what then happens to that child if the
court does not rule in favor of the
abusive parent
that child may be susceptible to further
abuse if their testimony just isn't
right in the eye of the abuser
this bill doesn't shield the child from
cross-examination
that means that each parent will have
the right to question their own child on
the stand under oath either themselves
directly or through their attorney
this bill doesn't make the courtroom
confidential unlike child abuse and
neglect cases
that child will be forced to testify in
public about their home life their
relationship with each of their parents
what they have witnessed and where they
prefer to live and with whom
two this bill contradicts state policy
section six page five of the parenting
plan states each parent shall promote a
healthy beneficial relationship between
the children and the other parent and
shall not demean or speak out negatively
in any manner that would damage the
relationship between either parent and
the children
forcing or encouraging your child to
testify against one of their parents in
no way promotes a healthy or beneficial
relationship between the child and their
other parent
ironically it also puts a condition on a
minor child to speak out negatively
about one parent while
simultaneously advising parents the
adults against doing that very thing
in fact if passed this bill would be in
direct contrast to the state's policy
under rsa 461 a2 which is that children
do best when both parents have a stable
and meaningful involvement in their
lives
allowing for children to testify against
their parents in a family court
proceeding has significant potential to
irreparably harm the parent-child
relationship and is likely to lead to
instability and further tension and
conflict within the family unit
this bill does not account for existing
court practices rule point two point
family division rule two point eight
um allows uh states that a child should
not be brought to court as a witness or
to attend a hearing
unless there is prior written order from
a court allowing that child's
participation
so the court does recognize that there
are some circumstances where child
testimony may be warranted but certainly
that is the exception not the rule this
is intentionally done to protect
children from the process which is
likely to be adversarial
traditionally it was the gal who would
interview the child and report back to
the court about the child's demeanor
concerns and preferences
this process while at times is not
perfect and may even be problematic was
an opportunity for children's voices to
be heard while being spared from being
placed squarely in the middle of a
contested court battle
with the elimination of the gal fund in
families who are unable to pay for a gal
no longer have a jail appointed to their
case
as a result some judges have been more
inclined to interview children in
chambers in the process that you just
heard from mr head
and this is done in an effort to
increase access to justice in those
cases involving low-income litigants
another person testified earlier today
that children don't deserve to be with
the best parent but both but that is
exactly what this bill does it forces
the child to choose the best parent
for these reasons nhla asked this
committee to vote inexpedient to
legislate house bill 1550 fn
thank you for your time and i will take
any questions
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you so much
next we have anna goulet zimmerman
you've requested two minutes
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is anna goulet
zimmerman i am an attorney i practice in
manchester
and i am also a member of the new
hampshire association for justice
um
i used to do a lot of family law i now
do
as little as possible um
but i do still i do still do it and one
of my big philosophies was always always
always what's the best thing for the
children here
and i turned down cases when i thought
the people who were coming to me were
being unreasonable in their expectations
and what they wanted and if i had ever
had a parent walk into my office and say
my 12 year old is going to testify
that is definitely a case i would not
have taken because i would not want to
have been part of harming a child in
that way
children should not be in court picking
a parent against the other parent and
then being cross-examined by the other
parent
it's almost like the tale of solomon
right the parent who puts that child on
the stand
is harming their child
there are ways to get that evidence as
you've heard their guardian ad litems
it honestly it concerns me when i hear
people say things like children are
writing these letters that they can't
give the judge they're writing down all
the time what they think should happen
because children shouldn't even be
involved in this process
now that there are exceptions i guess i
shouldn't say that too strongly but
there are some exceptions but for the
most part this should be parents saying
we're working this out mom and dad are
trying to work this out no we've got
some disagreements but this is not what
you need to worry about parents should
be in pr you know promoting healthy
relationships for both parents with
their children and having those children
get involved take a stand against one
child go one parent
write letters against one parent go to
court and testify against one parent is
not that we have a standard now which
once someone's a mature minor
and it's not automatically 12 it's not
automatically 14 the the
views of that child can be taken into
consideration and that's done as you've
heard through either guardian ad litem
or the judge privately in chambers
talking to that child about what's going
on what are the concerns why are they
making that
and then the last thing i'd add is that
it's not just i'm talking about 12 and
14 year olds i would say this applies
all the way up no child should there
should never be an automatic we're going
to put the child on the stand if there's
an extraordinary circumstance and the
judge thinks it's appropriate in my
experience the judges are very concerned
about trying to do what's right for the
children trying to weigh all the
evidence in family court which is a very
difficult place to be often
the large number of pro se litigants
makes that even more difficult
um
but it's it's
it's just not appropriate i mean i look
at my own life my daughter who's now 20
when she was 16 and 17 she hated me
um
you know and if you've got little kids
anyone you know it's common
she's a great kid she loves me now but
would we still have that relationship if
that had been she's going to be in court
telling everyone how much she hates me
and how horrible her life is with her
mother and
and all that instead of us working it
out and doing doing the things that we
did so i would i would ask you please uh
vote in expedient to legislate this bill
and i'm happy to take questions
any questions
representative long
thank you madam chair and thank you for
your testimony the um
have you
had um
cases where the child went in the
chambers and spoke with the judge yes
can i follow up if i may on that
certainly follow and what was the
disposition of those generally
so generally the the judge would say
something along the lines of
i've spoken with the ch the child
um
their their wishes because it was
usually like what would the schedule be
are consistent with what was what is
presented in this order
and and then they'd issue the order
without getting into a lot of details
any details about why or what they said
against one parent or the other parent
or anything like that okay thank you
you're welcome
thank you any further questions
thank you very much for your testimony
next i'll call uh represent
representative belanger
you've asked for less than five minutes
so i said give or take five minutes you
said like somewhere in between there i'm
not sure but i'll make it brief thank
you
so for the record my name is
representative cody belanger and i
represent the center of the universe for
those who don't know that's epping
thank you
when i was 12
i was removed from my mother's care from
the state of vermont
i'm very open and honest about my
stories i have nothing to hide
and
my father was there
and my mother came to me crying
and said
your dad's trying to take you from me
i was about 11 to 12 years old at that
time
now
despite now as a grown-up i probably
would have been better off with my
father because my mother was an abusive
person and now i realize that
i was about 12 years old when
this happened so if this bill was to
pass
and i stood up
in the court hearing at my foster
hearing
and told the judge i want nothing to do
with my father
that's what we're talking about now i i
do oppose this bill for
personal reasons and other reasons
there's a better way that we can go
about doing this
in my adult years
i was a parent educator for a company
in new hampshire that services dcyf
and i saw
firsthand
a family
persuade
their 12-year-old daughter
to tell the judge
that they belong with mom and dad
and these are stories these are issues
that are happening
so for those reasons granted mine was
from vermont but we eventually moved
here about 12 years a few years after
that happened
for those reasons i ask that we oppose
an itl this bill thank you
take any questions
any questions for the representative
seeing none thank you
i don't have any more pink cards so i
will now close the hearing on house bill
1550.
and we will now
um
we will now open the hearing on house
bill 1511
with the sponsor
representative gay
has everybody gotten their copy of the
amendment and the pink
testimony
can you pass a couple back this way
yeah
thank you
i'll keep one of those
there you go
this is the conclusion of the two other
bills about making your own recordings
and making your own transcripts
this is really why
why the effort was made to make it uh
legal for people to make their own
recordings and transcripts and this in
no way undoes the current press current
method of filing an appeal to a higher
court because the appeals currently mean
that you have to submit
your official
transcript with
and maybe the official uh
recording
i'm not sure if you have to do the
recording but in this case it would mean
that to file an appeal
where the recording was wrong omitted
important information
you would up submit both you would
submit your own recording and transcript
and
the official recording and transcript
and you would have to
uh you would have to notate where they
differed so that the court personnel
would not have to waste a lot of time
trying to find it
and this is a very serious issue
as you've heard
some people say and there are plenty of
people who've told us who are not
testifying today that their official
recording and transcripts were different
omitted really important information
so
if you have any questions i'll be
glad to see if there's any more to
clarify
any questions for the representative
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
next i'll call mr richard head
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
there's
there's actually a series of bills one
of one which is in judiciary
house bill 1592 that would allow parties
to make their own recordings
and then we have the other one which
would allow the parties to
submit their own transcripts and then
this one which is to submit any
recording or transcript of any relevant
hearing
to the appellate court so
i lose track a little bit of some of the
bills in terms of what their intent was
one of the problems with allowing and
again we're talking because we don't
family court anymore family division
and family division does a wide range of
cases and this would appear to allow any
party to record any proceeding and
family division whether they be
confidential whether they
you know without regard to the subject
matter domestic violence proceedings um
just a wide range of types of cases some
are extremely confident or private some
are extreme or confidential
in in and without any
sort of
role of of the court and again
i understand that some have concerns
about court discretion but court
discretion is important because one of
the aspects is
what is the subject matter being
discussed here what is the what would
this recording be recording and what
would it be capturing
the other problem
the other issue with
in concern with
individuals recording hearings is what
is being captured are we capturing
conversations that are happening in the
galley behind
by people who don't realize they're
being recorded because the the
microphone maybe of the telephone which
may be
not up front but maybe in the back
is it capturing information that people
don't realize is being captured
is it
what's the nature of the proceeding
because the court does not have control
over that recording is that something
that would be posted on on a website or
on the internet social media
would it be modified in some way so that
it would appear in some social media
setting to be testimony along with
different lines and what actually
happened
i'm also very sensitive to testimony
that has occurred where the court's
recording is not complete and accurate
and
some of that has occurred and as you've
heard some testimony that
in
in circuit court
the judges are record are
responsible for controlling the
recording we used to have what are
called court monitors before that we had
core stenographers so the stenographers
were actually doing all the the
stenographic and you would order the
transcript from the court stenographer
then we had monitors and the monitors
were responsible for the recording
equipment
and then through more budget cuts we've
the judges are doing it now if we
brought it back to monitors you wouldn't
have sort of that concern that exists
that we've heard in testimony here about
the judges controlling
the recording
but we don't have that currently so i
get and i'm sensitive to the concern
that people have raised about
having something that would ensure that
the recording the official recording is
is accurate this bill however doesn't
quite do that and i'm not quite sure
what this bill would do because
it would allow apparently the parties to
submit any recording to the supreme
court
somebody else may submit another
recording to the supreme court some of
these hearings are multiple days you
know so we have multiple days of
recordings that are being given to the
supreme court supreme court doesn't just
focus on
a particular line or a particular
sentence in a in a
in a transcript
it's looking at the record so now we
have multiple days of recordings that
the justices have to be listening to
to sort of discern what is what is the
record
it's really not the way
an appellate record is created
where you have competing recordings
competing
whatever it may be it's it's really a
role
maybe there's a better way of doing it
i'm not i'm not i'm not insensitive to
that
but as this bill is written and again
i'm talking about the bills that are
being presented and i haven't seen an
amendment if there is one
that this would just allow the parties
to submit any recording or any
transcript again no standards no quality
control
no
sort of unclear as to what that means
to the appellate court and then the
appellate court decides which may be
used as the basis for the appeal and
it's really the burden of the parties to
present to the court what the record is
and if under this scenario it's really
your the parties are leaving it to the
court to determine what the record is
when they're not the appealing party the
court has to be the unbiased supreme
court's the unbiased receiver of what
the record is it has to be
sort of as accurate as it can be
so
whether there's an amendment that gets
to a particular issue i don't know but
this would just have
without any ability of of a trial judge
to decide given the context of the
hearing whatever a right to record in
that recording of whatever equality is
now the potentially the record that's
going to the supreme court it just have
significant grave concerns and again as
i testified earlier there is at least a
court rule that would allow
parties to stipulate as to what the
record is
again i get and i understand that these
can be incredibly contentious
cases but
but there is at least another avenue for
for presenting the record
if there are other ideas and solutions
as i said before what we're talking
about here are the rules of the
appellate court and there is a rules
advisory committee there's a rules
making process if people have
suggestions on rules about what is the
record
it's really not it's a judicial function
as to
what is the official record that goes to
the supreme court
and with that i'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you thank you
any questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
next i'll call katrina heinrich
you asked for three minutes we'll give
you two
yes
i do right here
hi i'm katrina heinrich again
i agree
that the intent of this bill
has some merit
but it does need some amendments as to
what those amendments are that that
needs to be determined
but one of the things that has popped up
in testimony
was the fact that
judges that are supposed to remain
altered and neutral
can control the record
i believe a bill like this needs to add
some kind
of element
that holds them accountable
so official court recordings
that bear missing time and discrepancies
shall be deemed suspicious and possibly
altered and subject to penalties under
new hampshire rsa 64.7
i think something like that is is
critical when we're talking about
well no we're not going to give you a
right to actually have a recording that
might prove
you were telling the truth and somebody
else altered it
these are these are issues we certainly
need to look at
as i've already stated in my case the
discrepancies and missing time segments
is an issue
i observed both ethical and procedural
misconduct by the officiant toward one
party in a case which i've already
testified to
i think it bears maybe a little more
scrutiny but i don't believe it should
just be tabled
thanks
thank you
any questions
seeing none
i'll call on the final uh speaker
[Music]
dana albrecht
you asked for 30 seconds again thank you
maybe back up to 45 because
uh so this echoes the issues on hb 1551.
you already heard my testimony uh on
that so i won't repeat it
uh for this i just like to point out
that currently the record is governed by
supreme court rule 59
and when because of the issues in my
case i asked the trial court clerk to
provide me with a
certified cd of audio
by that i had in mind she'd sign it some
kind of seal the same way you do with
paper copies
uh just indicating that the clerk was
representing that this was true and
accurate
audio
um
and apparently that's prohibited under
supreme court rule 59
so there's no way we can ask the court
right now
for
official audio you know
there is no such thing as official audio
and i just think it would be valuable
for us to at least be able to do that
um
that concludes my comments
thank you
any questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you madam chairman and that concludes
the hearings on house bill 1511 fn i
will close that hearing
we can now open the hearing with a pink
card from representative gay
okay
however you choose
representative
i know huh
okay
we're going to open the hearing on
house bill 1458 fn
whoops
supposedly there's already a rule
that judges can rule that
motions are excessive
but apparently it happens so frequently
that that's why i've submitted this bill
they are
people are being harassed by it is a
favorite way
to harass
the person that you aren't happy with
so um even though
even though you're like for
instance for child support
there's really a rule that you can only
address it
every three years
and yet you're going to hear from people
who have emotion filed against them
every two months
and so uh
that's why this that's the real basis
for this rule uh for this bill
uh to stop these frivolous excessive
harassing
um
filings
that uh a judge should be able to tell
is is unfounded
um
the testimony uh sheet from again
that mother of two daughters
um
she says my case spanned many years with
countless filings
her parents she told me her parents
paid for her legal fees
apparently her ex had a lot more money
than she did
and he ran up because she would have to
answer his filings and she was afraid to
go pro se her parents paid 500 000
dollars
to respond to his constant harassing
emotions she said i was eventually let
go from my job due to the days off i
required to attend court hearings and
court ordered appointments
she was also ordered to go to years
of
therapy
to determine whether she was a stable
person
and
so that got that was expensive and that
took a lot of time
so she says overall the solution would
be to limit the
the length child custody cases remain
open
especially where there's substantial
evidence for one parent to have custody
um
you know that's
the dad the dad was a drug addict and
had other things that made the kids not
want to be with him so anyway i to me
it's it's a very simple
it's a very simple request
that the judge uses their their legal
power to deny
motions that are repetitive excessive
and harassing
thank you
good morning mr chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch we don't have a
position on this bill but
some
um information there is a rule as as you
heard that would allow parties to if
there are sort of harassing pleadings
that are being filed for the parties to
essentially not have to respond
that does get used
and it has been used
one thing that a in in in so i
practice litigation for a better part of
30 years
one thing i know about rules is rules
beget more litigation so once you create
a rule which which would itself impose
costs and penalties
you're going to see motions asking for
those to be imposed and you're going to
see more litigation over
whether or not something is harassing
it it's just an inevitable part of
putting together a rule like this you're
going to see more litigation perhaps
more harassing litigation over over
something like this
in in the context of
divorce and family division
as as you've also heard there are a
significant number of pro se parties who
are not represented with an attorney
and
it is true that judges do give
some
leniency not leniency is the wrong word
but some
leeway um for for unrepresented parties
who may not be familiar with the system
um in the nature of their filings it
does not mean that they're allowed to be
harassing it does not mean that they're
allowed to be intimidating
but a judge does take into account the
sophistication of the party and whether
or not they're an attorney if there is
an attorney that is filing it and the
judge believes that the those are
being filed improperly
that judge can direct that attorney to
to stop filing them and can impose
sanctions in terms of a referral
uh to the professional conduct committee
if that's appropriate
but what
the bill sort of as written simply says
that if the judge finds that there's
excessive or harassing legal uh filings
that they can incur that they can impose
these penalties
i'm not sure that's going to change the
number of of these of those cases that
are found to be
intimidating harassing but it will
itself create some more litigation over
that over that subject matter
the bill is also and i think there was
an amendment which i've not seen but it
also says that it shall report such
conduct to the supreme court committee
on professional conduct
which is which is appropriate but only
if the party doing it is is an attorney
so and as i said the vast vast majority
of these cases are pro se so there is no
attorney um so there would be no
referral and
and so i'm not sure what that line was
intended to to um
to to do
since most of these are not going to be
caused by an attorney
but i'd be happy to answer any questions
if there are any again we don't have a
particular position on the bill but just
add some information
thank you any questions
thank you very much thank you
um
next we have
katrina heinrich
you've asked for three minutes if we can
squish it to two
um
this is um i'm katrina heinrich
again sorry about that but
this case
is my case
this is over 30 pages long and this is
the case summary
all it is is it says how many hearings
and stuff there's been
within the first year post-divorce
there was numerous exportes all
frivolous
nothing
there was nothing
and yet the judges gave merit to them
this is part of a process
it has been well documented again
in the proclamation that the
governor signed
the studies support exactly what we're
saying again it's across the united
states not just new hampshire
there's a process a methodology to
finding the cases that they're going to
elongate
my cases happen be one of them
but it has to have
several pieces to it
the studies choose to use words like it
has to be post-divorce
they say
well the court already during the
divorce already has all your financials
they know where your assets are
there has to be an unhealthy parent
there has to be a healthy parent
the discovery documents are critical and
then of course the gal outsider
information
these pieces are necessary for any of
these cases that i've been talking about
like mine to proceed
with the inherent over
filings
it affects jobs it affects
visitation no matter who has the child
it just is a constant reminder in my
case
every friday that there was visitation
there was something filed that would
inherently ruin that visitation
the judge would not be able to hear it
so you lost another one this was a way
to slowly take away visitation
so in my case experience the other party
was permitted to file meritless exportes
frivolous emotional slander and
allegations the filings were not only
entertained but the entertaining of them
always finding in the favor of the filer
the court encouraged his behavior he was
very
very outspoken and arrogant about it he
could file as much as he wanted
with the lack of due process the court
did not require any evidence of
allegations
instead permitted the frivolous motions
to be used to prevent established
visitations to control my movement
through society that included access to
children's events activities access to
records and more
and remember
at the end of the divorce i was the
primary parent because i was always the
primary parent
but that switched in these ex partes for
no valid reasons
my children were healthy
clean
and well educated they were very out
well spoken and considered above average
yet the court refused to listen to those
facts
in entertaining these baseless filings
the court undermines the public trust
and the integrity of the institution
the court has the ability to protect
crisis and post divorce on facts from
the discovery process
once established the gal reengages and
frivolous filings begin and final
divorce is turned upside down
the damage goes beyond financial and
time ramifications
in the end they are artificially
manufacturing a brand new reality this
brings me back to the testimony i gave
you earlier in the day where once you
are out of divorce court they start at
zero and they create an artificial
reality and these cases get prolonged
again mine is over a decade old
and that's
that's all i have to say about it thank
you
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
i'll next call on anna goulet zimmerman
you've asked for two minutes
again my name is anna goulet zimmerman i
practice law in manchester and i am a
member of the new hampshire association
for justice
i would point out that with regard to
attorneys under our rules of ethics
professional conduct 3.1 already
prohibits attorneys from frivolous
filings
and there is actually an rsa rsa 507 15
which applies generally to all courts
and covers this exact same language
so i would start by saying i don't see
why there's any need to
add this separately into two separate
provisions of the family law statutes
where it already exists
i would also add that the courts do have
the ability to limit the frivolous
filings you have to ask for it
i was trying to remember if it's once or
twice i think i've asked for it twice
and i might have gotten it twice but i
know there's at least one case where i
just filed a motion saying
please tell me i can stop answering
these things it's it's taking too much
time and it's going to cost my clients
money and this is this is just harassing
as a pro say on the other side and i
said and i propose that if there was a
motion that the court thought might be
require a response they would notify me
and my 10 days to file my objection
would happen at that time and it worked
great i just stopped responding to
anything for about a year and a half and
then there was one that came up and we
we had to answer it so there are
remedies already in place um
and this is just unnecessary thank
you thank you any questions
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
for being here today and providing that
testimony quick question so
you mentioned you're an attorney correct
yes okay follow-up to that technically
certainly was just clarifying so um
if if you as an attorney
were filing repeatedly over and over and
over and over again do you think the
judge would catch on and go
you know
what's going on absolutely
oh what
i'm sorry will you certainly follow up
okay and then
second to that don't you have a ethical
obligation to to not do that yes yep
that's the rule 3.1 i have an ethical
obligation not to
um the court can report me
um
if there's an opposing a counsel
opposing counsel could afford you know
it could could do that
most often or again we're talking about
about pro ses and then of course the
other problem is as an attorney
um
we only have half the story when we hear
the story right so we get lots of we get
lots of calls that sound like oh my gosh
this horrible thing has happened
and
i always would start those by calling
the other the opposing counsel and say
help me understand do you know what's
going on
um
but sometimes you can't reach someone
sometimes it is something that requires
immediate action and you take it based
on you know good faith and
what you believe is the right thing at
that time and then sometimes it you know
you find out there's more to the story
as there often is but but we're all
we're all kind of going into the system
usually at least the legal the attorneys
on it trying to do the right thing
understanding what the right thing is
and i think the courts are in the same
situation if they get a pleading that
looks like it's an emergency someone's
filed an emergency
you know they can't take the risk of
just saying okay never mind just go go
back with that other parent they have to
have a hearing on it and look at it and
figure out what happened
and it's it's unfortunate in some cases
but we've all seen the really really
tragic cases
that have gone wrong
and you know that's that's what the
courts are always trying to to weigh i
would imagine and that's a heavy burden
any further questions thank you very
much for your testimony thank you
next i'll call on vivian gerard
you've asked for two minutes
is she here
well we'll put her behind you
mr albrecht and if she's back
we'll call on her
uh thank you madam chairwoman again dana
albrecht national new hampshire
um
i'd just like to point out to the
committee first of all
that just because something
might have
hurt me in my case
doesn't mean it's bad legislation
and
briefly echoing back to
my morning testimony on appeals
uh in that exhibit
uh was a finding by master dalpra
that my attempt to correct his
bad order
was harassing so he could have hurt me
for that
but that's i think
an issue of judges and not legislation
so again just because it would have hurt
me doesn't mean it's bad legislation i
think it's good legislation
um
i like it
i don't think it goes far enough
uh i just want to bring up one other
problem i had
where there was a witness in my case who
felt
very intimidated because he was facing
false criminal charges i was
also
given false criminal charges
and he was hoping to make it here today
to testify
so i don't actually want to speak too
much to that i just wanted to provide
his police report for you while i'm here
because i already made copies
and i'm sure he can follow up with
any written testimony later
so that's all i have on this if there's
any questions
thank you
i see none thank you very much
so although ms gerard is not back um
there is testimony being
passed around
um she i did speak with her and let her
know that i would put it at the end
and um so but we are gonna have her the
benefit of her testimony
you can make a note that she's not here
but we submitted yeah
and with that
um i will be closing
house bill 1458 fn
yes
and we're going to give
two minutes break
you take your time
thank you
so
foreign
crazy
thank you
um
yes
wow
ols
oh you
may have fallen out
i did but it must have fallen out i'll
make another one
yes
uh
okay
thank you madam chair
um
we are
i'm sorry
uh bill 1458
nope that's not it no
it's still
12 53
i'm sorry
that's okay i just got
lost if uh
just had it
if somebody just gives me there is
nothing to add there's nothing to pass
out if somebody just hands me a copy of
1458 i can do it
no 12 53 12 53
thank you ma'am thank you
okay
this bill would allow parents to choose
the counselors
because
kids are assigned by judges counseling
many on many occasions
and
the parents don't have any choice in who
this counselor is
and we really think that
if you can get the parents if the
parents agree
they can suggest counselors of their own
choice
and of course if they're going to
not agree then after a certain amount of
time the the judge would
regain that uh prerogative to make the
choice of counselor
what changes in the bill
is that
number one that the parents get to write
get the right to choose
and
this is an old change that's
that should have been written years ago
because they tried in previous laws
travis previous rsas
to direct
payment
in selecting a counselor they would
accept the old
terminology was accept direct payment
from the
provider
uh because that was the best wording
they could come up with so that they
would be
honoring the parents
insurance so that they would not be
paying out of pocket
um
but they're actually the most current
terminology one of our representatives
as a
retired md and so he said it should be
instead of accepts direct payment from
they are a participating provider
in the party's health insurance
this is already in
in rsa that you're supposed to try to
accommodate
families medical insurance
but right now
from all the cases that i have heard
uh parents
get told who they're going to take their
child to
and they don't have any choice in who
this person is
and lots of times it's out of pocket
and that goes for the parents as well as
the children so it's one more
debilitating financial burden of being
in the family court
that's it
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
i appreciate your time
you've had quite the day
and it hasn't come to an end yet
so next i'll call katrina heinrich
you've asked for three minutes
we're asking that you squish it a little
and i appreciate it
you've done a great job
okay
i try to eliminate if you've already
heard it what's the point
um
so on this bill
you know we know counseling has numerous
issues
some of the biggest ones is that
children that are already in counseling
maybe you have a proactive parent
they're getting pulled from those
counselors in that relationship
and as representative gay said billing
is an issue
frequently going to therapists who don't
necessarily have a license they're
getting
billing codes that don't exist so they
can't really bill for it so they're
having to pay cash out of pocket
i think this is a familiar talk topic
that we talked about in 2020
with that said
i think there are some things that could
be relevant if we added to the bill
i think we should add something to the
extent of
any existing patient provider
relationship shall remain intact
any existing provider evaluation and or
diagnosis within one year time frame
shall be accepted as current information
and the court shall accept the
professional conclusion as fact
if a child has been in therapy for more
than a year or consistently receiving
treatment from a specific provider
that provider and diagnosis shall be
considered current
such a relationship shall continue as
long as considered necessary by the
provider
selection of a provider shall not be
contingent upon the sole discretion of
the policy holding parent by default
both parties must be in agreement with
provider and insurance
the court shall not order counseling and
therapy services unless medically
indicated and not as a mechanism to
advance one party's cause over another
the court shall also not make medically
unnecessary inquiries or interventions
um i refer back which what what happened
to my middle child um all the children
had already been evaluated they were all
considered to be
excellent students well-respected
students
uh and above level
however
once the case started being flipped um
the first thing they did was they tried
checking the middle child into a psych
ward with no reason i got calls from the
police coming to pick up the child this
happened two days in a row
the child then gets pulled by a
self-inserted guardian light and who has
not been reappointed to the case
and he comes to me and tells me
that if i ever want to see my children
again because he is going to take them
that i have to comply with who he has
chosen he has an existing relationship
with this provider he used them for his
case and they are known to do specific
therapies that are not in the best
interest of the child
the billing on that there was some that
was cash there was some that was not at
the time i was not wise enough to really
be paying attention to the billing codes
that is a huge issue
so i think when we're looking at
something like this i thinking the
additives to it is probably
a way to make the bill
better not necessarily to make it more
complicated but i'm looking to find a
way to make it
perhaps a little
better so it actually has
a very thorough purpose
and that there is account ability which
is what is lacking throughout the family
court
and with that i'm not going to give you
any more examples
you definitely
understand this case the only thing i
will add is my daughter that
as i mentioned this morning due to
severe ptsd could not be here
as much as she wanted to
she did want me to convey the simple
fact that had she not been moved she
wouldn't have this ptsd she wouldn't be
in the situation she is in
the state of new hampshire's court
failed all three children specifically
her she wound up with
medical incapabilities that were
physical that could have been prevented
and then she wound up with mental
all preventable and all with the only
parent advocating for the child
so thank you
thank you any questions
representative petrina
hello
i just want thank you so much for taking
my question i just wanted to know if you
submitted your uh recommendations for
amendments to representative gay because
you presented a lot of um i did submit
them to her i don't think she has them
on her but i did submit them to her via
email so she does have them um i will
also put it in my
my things to you guys thank you very
much okay thank you
anything else
any other questions
thank you all next i'll call gail
bat
thank you you've asked for three minutes
yes
thank you madam chair can we squish
thank you
thank you members of the committee for
the opportunity to testify before you
today each of you as our elected policy
makers have the greatest ability to
reform outdated laws to better protect
children and families of new hampshire
my name is gail drobat although my
own family is intact i advocate for
other parents
that have been abused by the new
hampshire family court system
i come before you in support of hb 1253
i believe this is imperative a counselor
ordered by the court of their choosing
in my opinion allows the court
affiliated therapists to be biased from
the onset of therapy
it is also imperative that each
therapist in court involved proceedings
at minimum are credentialed in family
systems therapy a therapy that can
assess diagnose and treat the symptoms
that recognizes the breakdown in the
family otherwise these therapists are
getting it wrong a lot of the times
inside with one parent
again one of the fathers previously
mentioned was forced to sign on with the
mug a therapist of the mother's choosing
believed to be recommended by the
guardian ad litem that therapist allied
with the mother
did not include dad in the process made
unfavored assessments that was dictated
by the mother this information is in
email correspondence this therapist
again was court ordered to provide
billing and insurance records to the
parties
in a september 2020 court order
to date the counselor is in contempt of
that court order and the court defies
making her
present those documents
she states she doesn't have them
although her ethical codes dictate that
she is to maintain those
for seven years after the age of
majority so
there should be no reason that she
doesn't have those documents and
the court now is making the father pay
attorney fees to opposing counsel
because she's defied that court order
and he wants the records
so
it's imperative that
i believe
therapists need to be chosen by parents
and not
court officials
because i feel they're choosing their
peers
that aren't qualified
in the breakdown of the family
so thank you so much
any questions
seeing none thank you so much for your
time
and with that that's our whoops wait a
minute
oops
we have dan itza
thank you
for the record i'm dan itza and i regard
reside in the
city of manchester
um
first a technical correction to the bill
uh roman numeral three line four
the first word parents
that should be parties
the way this is written the parent the
parties would have the
power to choose their counselor the
counselor for their children but not
their own counselor
and very often the parents are included
in the counseling requirements so that
there's just that word change to
make the law correct
beyond that i want to advocate for the
power of the parties to choose the
counselor
our counselors
um
very often in the instances that i have
observed where the cases have gone
sideways where they become complex cases
there is a pattern where you have a
judge
a gal
and a counselor and you see that
triumvirate repeated
on multiple occasions in multiple cases
and it appears to be at least in my
opinion a cottage industry
the fact that these counselors are
making life decisions for families
the families need to be
in control of whom their counselors are
um
i think it's vitally necessary i'd be
happy to take any questions
any questions
i see none thank you very much for your
time
and with that i will close the hearing
on house bill 1253
and
representative gay do you have a pink
card ready
okay
you will hand them to my able assistant
that would be great
and with that we'll open the hearing on
house bill 1199
and it's 3 38.
thank you madam chair and thank you for
all your patience in dealing with so
many
so many issues
house bill 1199 deals with such an
important issue
that we have a judge who has come to
plead her case
i'm here because as a person who got
involved in family court through victims
of domestic abuse
i am particularly concerned about the
effects on children
as you all are
and the testimony this pink testimony is
not from the mother this is from the 15
year old daughter
who had to endure
five years of
reunification therapy
i'm not sending you or giving you all
the many many articles
um on
reunification therapy but one of the
real strong points is
you can't you can
unify you can reunify people who were
unified before
but to call it reunification if those
people had no relationship or had a very
hostile relationship that was totally
different
the
i thought it was so important
that this girl decided that she really
wanted to tell you what it was like
because it's nowhere it's not anything
like counseling that you've ever heard
of and that's why most professional
counselors have never heard of
reunification therapy because it has no
training
it has no certification
it has no coverage by insurance so when
people are ordered to go through it
they get to pay out of their pocket the
150 to 350 dollars per hour for it so it
also impoverishes people besides in the
case of domestic abuse
it forces children our spouses to sit
there in the same room
with their abuser
and it takes
in by law it's very difficult to prove
abuse
so even though it happens and we have
we have
centers around the state to help victims
deal with it
it happens a lot
and i have learned
yesterday last week i heard back
from doc uh attorney barry gold's
gold i'm saying his name are gold
it's not goldsmith oh
you can see why i'm really an unusual
unusual uh politician since i can't
remember words and names but um
is it goldstein
yes it's goldstein and he's written
several books and uh i actually
did print
uh
i'll have to
have to find it because somehow it
didn't make it into my
my bag i guess i'll just send it to you
because in his web page
uh he's
in his webpage he lists 12 things that
in the 1970s people just assumed were
facts
and
since then we've had a lot of research
to refute those and explain better how
you identify domestic abuse
you know how it started out as just
bruises but then we realize it's much
more extensive than that
but i will send that to you because it
was extremely extremely educational
but he's written
at least three books
so i'll i will send that to you but
meanwhile the pink page is the
um
is the testimony from a 15 year old who
says in here she's actually written to
courts before and of course nothing
happened as a result of that but it made
her feel better that she was
trying to give herself a voice
so please read that
and the
the change this this law we had lots of
people
offer what they thought was a best way
to state this
i'm personally not against family
counseling at all
i think that's a really useful tool and
when children have been
swayed by one parent or the other
are bribed we all know we don't like
that we really want somebody who's
impartial but caring
to try to do an analysis
of the children's situation of the
parent situation and work as a family
system to bring the best result that
they can
however what's happening right now with
reunification therapy is they're pretty
much following that's creator
opinion richard gardner
who liked to be called a doctor but he
didn't have patience
and uh he had some really strange
opinions like
sexual abuse of children really wasn't
sexual abuse and reporting it was more
damaging to the child than the actual
acts
that was
um
he has a very strong following because
rich abusers loved him
and unfortunately that has taken over
as a credible
credible argument in american courts in
british courts
in australian courts
meanwhile councillors real genuine trade
trained certified counselors say this is
not true
this is
uh
they don't say hogwash they use other
words just meaning it is not legitimate
and is extremely damaging to children
who have been abused to be put in front
of a counselor who's going to tell them
that they it's they need to make a
peace with this parent who has abused
them
so the wording here doesn't say anything
negative about
unifying in a family
what it says is they are
the court shall go give due
consideration to selecting a counselor
who is a participating provider in the
party's health insurance
the money does count you know people do
need to be protected that way
any therapy to unify a family with
counseling
shall be provided by a mental health
therapist
certified or licensed by the state of
new hampshire and trained in family
systems
who will first evaluate the family
members to determine if such therapy is
appropriate
whether or not the children are covered
by health insurance that's a legalese
thing dealing with previous laws
so this says to unify a family
you need to have a trained counselor and
right now people who have a shingle out
that says i'm a reunification therapist
do not have to be they don't have to
have any training in family counseling
they may be a counselor maybe in weight
control or something but if you read
i hope i've already sent it to you if i
haven't i'll resend it testimony from
five different people who have
experienced
devastating effects of being
pushed into reunification therapy
with a person who's
who doesn't doesn't care what has
happened and if you're uh been abused
that's tough you need to make peace with
this parent and the children are told
if you don't
we're going to give custody of you to
that person
so that you can imagine what fear these
children live in
once they've been talked and she's very
good about talking what it was like
and she had to go through it five years
and the amazing thing was
she and her sister finally at the end of
five years
they told the council they went in there
and they said
we're not coming anymore
so she was horrified and she said they
said they had to stay so they stayed the
whole hour looking at the floor which i
thought was amazing gumption
for kids who had gone through this for
five years
so that's my story
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
next i'll call on katrina henrich
again i'm katrina heinrich
on this particular one
and betty did an excellent job of
conveying
so many of the stories some that i've
participated in
uh
this particular bill
is critical to
kind of some of the pieces
that the honorable itza spoke to for the
trifecta
tactic that's being used
in particular
again in courts across the nation not
just new hampshire
the gals are specifically
working way outside of their context
they shouldn't have the ability to go
beyond the scope of their jobs or in
function
to move the case from one direction to
another post-divorce
that can be occurred by all these
different avenues that they stack up one
being
this reunification therapy experiment
and that's the only word i have for it
it's an experiment because all i have
heard
is the kids that have been in it and the
kids that my daughter has met with
is they become very confused they don't
know how to function anymore
the only thing i can really summarize my
feeling on this is
that in my experience the title
or whatever you call the action
for a type of certified
therapy
is only relevant when it is a proper
billable diagnosis
that it is provided by a neutral
certified practitioner
who can
justify their findings that it is
medically necessary that there is a
reason component for it there must be
something that brings us back into the
courtroom
where judges are allowing even ordering
it and practicing in the trifecta
if it isn't necessary why are we doing
it are we trying to force relationships
it's just a very valid question that i
think needs to be explored
and that is all i have on that
thank you any questions
seeing none next we'll call anna goulet
zimmerman
you're asking for two minutes
madam chair members of the committee i'm
not sure if i should keep introducing
myself but i will in case the record's
uh split up i am announcing for the
record i am anna goulet zimmerman i
practice law at the law office of
manning and zimmerman in manchester new
hampshire and i am also a member of the
new hampshire association for justice
um
i think if i'm understanding the
modifications or the amendment that was
proposed as it was read in by the
sponsor
i am less concerned but i also don't
know i just don't understand why this is
necessary i mean one if there's no
training or certification or anything
like that specific to reunification
therapy
how do we prohibit it um
but this also this notion of what is
medically necessary i can think of a ton
of situations and i'll give you a couple
of quick examples where it is definitely
without a doubt in the best
interest of the child to try to have a
positive relationship with both parents
and i don't know if we call it
reunification therapy i'm going to put
that in air quotes um or if we call it
how do we improve the relationship
between the children and the parents
therapy but it amounts to the same thing
i represented a young young father once
who had a little kid who he didn't even
know had been was his child
um when when dcyf came in took the child
from mom they started being questions
about well who where's whose dad where's
dad
and that was when he found out that he
might have a child
and he was great he came back he went to
counseling he learned about kids and
there was a process
because he had no you know we weren't
going to just take this child who was a
couple years old at the time and
overnight move her in with a family with
someone she didn't know
but there was a process to forge that
relationship and it ended up being a
great relationship and last i knew he
was a great dad
um you see this through dcyf where
you've got parents that have drug or
alcohol problems they have an
opportunity to get clean and be
reunified with their children
and are we saying we're not gonna do
that in family court if someone actually
had a problem
and they have fixed that problem we're
just going to say never mind your
children don't want to see you we're not
even going to try to make sure you can
have a positive relationship with them
i know there's questions on alienation
does it happen does it not happen why
does it happen but there's a variety of
situations where throughout the divorce
to process the children are
upset
reluctant to spend time with another
parent there's some issue going on and
certainly and i didn't catch all of the
amendment but i would urge you to
certainly not pass anything that
prohibits the courts from encouraging
the children to go through counseling
that would allow them to have a positive
relationship with both their parents
thank you thank you for your time any
questions
seeing none thank you very much next
i'll call dana albrecht
again just for the record dana albrecht
nashua new hampshire
echoing what was just said i know this
has been through a couple different revs
um i would urge you to pass something
uh similar to the latest
uh requiring
that a family systems therapist
uh support a positive
and healthy relationship with both
parents
absent
uh clear and convincing evidence in a
court order that that's not in the
child's best interest
because i think that's what we're really
looking here
is
a good positive relationship with both
parents
unless we've got a good re really good
reason
why we shouldn't have that
um
so i'm a little less hung up on wording
as some of the other folks but i think
we should focus on what it is we want
rather than what it is we
are maybe trying to avoid
um this one is particularly near and
dear to my heart
uh up until april
uh i was actually probably the primary
parent in my household
just to remind the committee from my
testimony on shared parenting i'm the
father of four children
to
older boys to younger girls
the older kids kind of is
so they're in much better shape
uh but i do have a poor relationship
with my daughters
and
i don't need some crazy
unlicensed unrecognized
person or therapy to fix that
i need
a really solid
licensed marriage
family child family systems therapist
who is willing to work with both parents
to help our kids
put this back together again
and there's been some real challenges
there
uh
since
the
um
hearing where master del pra
basically said who the f cares
about my testimony
and that my kids were morons
um
actually the resulting order from that
hearing is still in effect right now
we filed a motion to vacate but the
court hasn't heard it
and it gave mom sole decision making
authority to suck the counselor which
probably speaks to the last bill as well
and i've actually had serious issues
with that person
i'm not going to blame them too much i
think they're young and inexperienced
but i've heard multiple conflicting
stories from her
why she will only communicate with mom
or only communicate with mom's counsel
and
not me
and even a story from her that there's a
court order preventing her from
communicating
with me
so i think if we can just kind of really
clean this up as to what's allowed and
what's not
kind of echoing
almost the theme of the day on
discretion
that would be a good thing
uh
i would further add this has been
exacerbated
since
you know kathleen sternenberg sent the
kids to california they've moved a lot
so they've been from hollis new
hampshire to
sierra to pasadena california to sierra
madre california
currently to east china
michigan
and so when you put the whole
multi-state thing
into the mix it can get even more
confusing
um
to that end i would just have one
concern about the languages written
where it says new hampshire
um maybe take this offline i just want
to make sure that we're not causing
jurisdiction problems
if kids are in
another state and
i'm sure it's an easy fix if that would
be an issue
um i think that's it uh if there's any
questions
any questions
i see none thank you thank you
next we're going to call dale dubock
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee
again i support this bill there is no
evidence-based practice for
reunification therapy
again i believe at minimal it should be
family systems therapy where they
recognize the breakdown in the family
dynamics and maybe can rebuild that
also if there's allegations of abuse or
neglect in my opinion there would need
to be a certified therapist well-versed
in childhood trauma attachment
pathologies stuff like that
and figure out why one child is allied
with another
parent and
figure out where that's coming from okay
that's my and i actually have some
information to give you guys to read on
great that
please submit it
thank you very much any questions
seeing none
thank you we'll
call on our last speaker on this bill
parana judge jennifer lemire
thank you for taking time out of your
busy schedule thank you very much madam
chairwoman and members of the committee
i was here
last monday but i i don't know um i
think that some of you were here
but in case you do not know me i just
very quickly wanted to give you a little
bit of background
i am jennifer lemire i'm a circuit court
judge here in new hampshire
i'm born and raised in new hampshire i
live in stratham
and
i have
well i practiced law in new hampshire as
well as maine in massachusetts but
primarily new hampshire for 14 years
before i went onto the bench in 2010.
i did general civil litigation but
a focus in family law as well
representing parents
and parties that were going through
difficult family law matters
i've been on the bench now for 12 years
here in new hampshire and full-time
and
i sit as every or almost every circuit
court judge does
in the three different divisions of the
new hampshire circuit court we have the
family division the district division
and the probate division
almost all of the circuit court judges
sit at least in two of those divisions
at any given time usually family and
district
probate divisions don't appear in every
courthouse in the state there are fewer
of them but i actually sit in a
courthouse that does have a probate
division so from time to time i'm also
called upon to preside over those
matters
but in the family division we hear
of course divorce and parenting cases
but also a number of other types of
cases on a daily basis and those include
child support domestic violence
child abuse and neglect cases
termination of parental rights cases
adoptions
and
guardianship of minors
and then at the same time we're hearing
cases in the district division of our
courthouses
for criminal arraignments please bail
hearings trials civil litigation
including small claims hearings landlord
and tenant disputes stalking petitions
so in a given day
any of us might have a mixed docket we
talked about that a little bit last week
what that means the docket is just the
hearings that we have on every day from
8 to 12 and then from one to four
usually there are
six to eight hearings in the morning 30
minutes each no time in between
maybe six in the afternoon if they're
longer hearings there are fewer of them
of course
but we're very busy in the circuit court
new hampshire
have been for quite some time and we try
to hear as many cases as we can
because we are so busy
also at any time throughout the day we
have walk-ins with domestic violence
petitions stalking petitions emergency
landlord and tenant petitions
and
at night we take calls 24 7 and on
weekends 365 days a year
from local police departments looking
for emergency restraining orders search
warrants
dcyf may have an emergency request to
remove a child
or the police may have a juvenile that
they wish to
seek to detain or have in custody and
need us to help them determine where
where that child should go if a parent
isn't available for instance
um
so
that's what we do in the circuit court
on a day-to-day basis
um
and we do the best we can because we're
statutorily authorized of course to
apply the law to the facts that are
presented to us
and in the parenting and divorce realm
of course that's rsa 461 a that's our
parental rights and responsibilities
statute
in the very beginning of that statute it
sets out the policy of the state of new
hampshire and it is to
support the frequent continuing contact
of a child with each parent unless it is
detrimental to the child to do so
and it sets out that we have to take
into consideration safety issues that
may be present for the child or a parent
and
we have to obviously always be guided by
what's in the best interest of the child
when we're faced with a parenting case
or a divorce case that has a parenting
component
we have to help parties develop a
parenting plan
that's within the statute and it is in
fact an eight-page document uh that is a
roadmap for uh parents going forward how
they're going to share and at you know
their parental rights and
responsibilities with one another
because of course
at the outset every parent has the same
rights as the other parent
under the new hampshire constitution
and we have to determine what happens if
they cannot agree
on how they're going to share those
rights going forward they have a
conflict with one another the parents do
or a parent and a guardian if that's the
case or what you may have in your
particular case
um so
we encourage in the first instance and
it's part of the new hampshire state
policy to do so that the parents can
enter into a parenting plan together
that they agree upon together
we help them to do that if they can't do
it on their own with mediators that we
provide with case managers who work in
the family division who help them
prepare the forms they're not attorneys
or
mediators but they can assist people who
aren't represented by counsel to do you
know some very difficult work that needs
to be done because we request a lot of
forms
and we also have along the way um
something called neutral case evaluation
which is free to the parties and we have
a judge or a retired judge sit with the
parties and act somewhat like a mediator
but spend a few hours with them hear
what their issues are in their case and
help
by telling them what they as a judge if
they were the judge on the case might
order sometimes that helps parties to
settle the case themselves
and that's all a voluntary process
the parties have to agree to participate
in that it's quite it's been quite
successful
i currently sit
on the complex
docket for region c of the of the state
of new hampshire we have four regions
regency is rockingham and stratfor
counties and two years ago
when judge foley
stepped back from being the presiding
judge of the complex family division
docket
we split the case in the state rather
into four regions and i became the
presiding judge of the complex case
docket for the family divisions of
rockingham and stratfor counties all
that means
is that the judges who have these busy
regular dockets in those counties if
they're faced with a case that's
particularly complex can request that it
be transferred reassigned to my docket
because i have
more time and resources available i have
a dedicated case manager
i have a complex list of adr alternate
dispute resolution mediators who have
been
vetted and interviewed by the adr office
at the administration administrative
office of the courts
to deal with complex issues
and that's at no cost to the parties who
are on my docket
and um the complex cases generally fall
into one of two categories the majority
of them that i have presently
are legally complex or they have large
financial interests and complex
interests of that nature they may be
they may involve
assets
such as real estate in other countries
in other jurisdictions
conflict of laws issues across states
closely held businesses that need to be
allocated during in a divorce which can
be quite complex tax issues
real estate valuation issues
requiring long trials i have mostly long
trials on my docket and i have the time
set aside to do that the regular dockets
can't handle perhaps in the next
year or so a five day a six day a 10 day
trial but i can do that on my docket for
those legally complex matters and the
other complex type of case that i do see
occasionally on my docket are those that
have very high conflict difficult
parenting issues such as those i'm sure
you've been hearing about today they're
very difficult cases of course there's a
lot of emotion in in many aspects of
what we do in the circuit court but
certainly in these cases and i
understand it having presided over
many many of them over the last 12 years
i sat in manchester portsmouth
dover rochester and now brentwood for
the last two years
and
we do as i said what we can to apply the
law and the policy of the state of new
hampshire to the facts before us
one of the things that we do have to do
shifting now to to this house bill 1199
is in some cases and i i just want to
again i can only speak about my
experience
but
it's it's rare
first of all that i would order
something that i
would understand to be reunification
counseling as you're hearing about it
today
certainly we see many cases with
counseling being ordered
and it may be actually in many cases the
parties or the children are already in
counseling before they even appear
before me in my courtroom
and that's because the parents have have
put them there they might have done that
by agreement they might not have but
that may already be in place
if there is a particular issue in a case
that makes it difficult for me to
determine what is truly in this child's
best interests because maybe there's a
substance abuse issue in the case maybe
mental health issues
maybe the child is resisting or refusing
to go with a parent and and we don't
know what the cause of that is
i'm not a child psychologist i don't
have those
those qualifications
i may have two parents in front of me
one that is absolutely adamant
that um he or she is doing everything to
encourage that child to go and the other
parent saying no you're not you're
you're withholding the child uh you're
in contempt
you're not you're not doing what you
need to do to comply with this order
they may not have any evidence to show
me
that can help me decide what is actually
going on here
but that child may need to have a place
to go and a counselor to talk to to talk
those things through
if i order counseling in a case
i always first promote the parties to
agree to who that counselor is going to
be sometimes they have absolutely no
idea and they need someone to help give
them a suggestion sometimes well first i
and again that the part of this that
that talks about insurance
i don't have an issue with because
there's already written into the law the
fact that we have to give to due
consideration to the presence of
insurance and whether or not a counselor
is on someone's insurance we consider
cost or at least i consider cost and i
and my colleagues as well
to the parties in many areas in these
cases not just counseling but also if
we're going to appoint a guardian ad
litem we can no longer appoint a
guardian ad litem in a case in new
hampshire if the parties cannot
demonstrate and we get their financial
affidavits and we get whatever evidence
they give us tax returns pay stubs what
have you of their income if they can't
demonstrate an ability to privately pay
for a guardian we can't appoint one we
used to have a fund in new hampshire a
gal fund
that's no longer there and it was it was
fantastic to have something to assist
parties who needed that because in some
cases a gal would be tremendously
helpful a good qualified gal would be
very helpful in a particular case
but we can't appoint them now even in
cases that need them and sometimes
parties are are asking for them and if
they can't afford it
there's no there's no
no resource there for us any longer but
we consider cost and certainly when
appointing a counselor ordering a
counselor i should say
what i do if they don't agree i ask who
has the insurance if they have insurance
if they do they may not know who's
covered under their insurance i'll ask
them to have a printout made of
whoever's available under their
insurance policy and share it with the
other party they might both have
insurance they can exchange them
if they still can't after they do their
own research on who they'd like can't
agree
i might propose that they seek the
recommendations of their pediatrician
show those lists to your child's
pediatrician and see if the pediatrician
can point you in a certain direction
that he or she would recommend
and choose that way
if there can be no agreement and the
child
has a need for counseling and i feel
it's in the best interest of the child
to be in counseling
then i ask each parent to propose a
counselor and tell me why that counselor
is the person he or she proposes and
submit that we'll have a hearing i'll
hear their respective positions and
ultimately i need to decide
but i do assure you that in my
experience that any counselors that
have
been i and again
i'm not usually selecting a counselor
certainly if a party needs to be in
counseling that party should pick his or
her own counselor it's a very personal
process
um and i i don't know that i've ever
ordered a party to to go to a particular
counselor
if
a child needs a counselor again we
promote agreement if there can't be
agreement look to the pediatrician
usually that's where they find the
recommendation
but
in a very extreme circumstance and again
i've only had a handful of these over
the years even on my my current complex
docket
where there is a reunification protocol
in place what that
involves in my experience is each parent
is in counseling and the child has a
counselor
and then there's a master family
therapist
who is
someone who has a master's if not a
doctorate
in child clinical development
or child clinical psychology
and
counseling psychology
i heard
new hampshire certified and licensed
mental health counselors
that is something i see quite often in
these cases
i know of no one myself
that
is involved in any of these cases that
doesn't have those type of
qualifications
but again it's a very rare circumstance
because a child is refusing to go with a
parent it may be that
and i heard
mention of a case where perhaps a child
may have been traumatized by the parent
that they're refusing or resisting from
i need to know that as the judge on the
case if that's the reason that a child
is truly resisting or refusing contact
i am not going to order there to be
contact with that parent because i have
to take into consideration what's safe
and and certainly what's in the child's
best interests but sometimes we don't
know that until the child's been
evaluated
courts need all the resources available
to us to help us with these very
difficult cases
we are
truly concerned about what is in the
best interest of these children and
these families that come before us
and i i agree
with
the attorney that spoke earlier
that
we want to help foster healthy strong
relationships within families certainly
when it's appropriate and in the child's
best interest to do so again we take in
whatever evidence we have available to
us and
if we don't know the root of the issue
it could be a child's age the child
could have separation anxiety could have
developmental issues could have
uh his or her own mental uh health
issues that are causing this issue you
know resisting or refusing the other
parent if that child isn't being
evaluated and treated for that
um
then reunifying that child with the
other parent isn't even going to be an
option
and the cases that i have currently on
my docket
and i only have two or three
two that actually have a reunification
protocol in place
they were agreed upon and proposed by
the parents
they wanted they bought into this
process
one of the cases you know i can't speak
to the facts of a pending case
but i'll just tell you that in one such
case um
a father hasn't hasn't had contact with
seeing his child in many years
and
there
there are issues that the parents that
cause the parents to not be able to
agree upon anything
and that's understandable that happens
quite frequently in our cases before us
but what they did agree to was that they
would prefer to be in a therapeutic
process that might have a long-term
sustainable effect for this child
than to be constantly in the courts and
coming back to relitigate year after
year until this child turns 18
and unfortunately that's what keeps the
a lot of these cases in our court system
a long time unfortunately the fact that
that there hasn't been a sustainable
solution to whatever the issue is that
is causing this family to be hurting so
and causing this child to not have a
healthy relationship with both parents
so a colleague of mine when i spoke with
him about this
bill said
why would anyone want to take one of the
very few arrows we have left in our
quiver in terms of the few resources we
have as circuit court judges to try and
help children and help families in these
very very difficult cases
i have no agenda i have no
desire to cause anyone to pay for
something they can't afford or to be in
a process that they don't believe in
and so i attempt to
have everyone agree at the outset
in my cases if that can't happen again
we have to come back to well what's in
the child's best interest
and one thing that we can't do
because there is is case law the miller
and todd case tells us what we can't do
is if there's a case where it has been
found that a parent is
alienating a child against the other
parent
and such that the child no longer wishes
to have contact with another parent we
can't just pick that child up and put
that child with the other parent
particularly if there are any
allegations of abuse certainly
particularly even if there aren't
there's no evidence of any abuse but
there are allegations and the child is
resisting and refusing
and it may be a belief that one child
one parent's alienating the child from
the other parent
we can't do harm to the child we can't
force the child we can't
cause trauma to that child that may
already have experienced trauma that's
what we're trying to avoid doing we're
trying to also
promote frequent and continuing contact
between a child and both parents because
that's what the state of new hampshire
tells us that we need to do when it's
appropriate and in the child's best
interest i know i
i circled around there a little bit i
touched on a bunch of things i know
you've been at this it's been a long day
for you all um i'm happy to answer any
questions if you have any questions um
but i just wanted to touch on a few of
those things from where from where i sit
and how i see it thank you your honor
that was very informative
um i see representative belanger has a
question
thank you your honor for being here
thank you madam chair for allowing me to
ask the question so
what you're saying
is this
what we're hearing
is this i understand
how do we do this
all i can tell you and i mean absolutely
no disrespect to anyone here in the
courtroom and i i don't don't know their
individual cases um and and
all i can tell you is from my own
experience and and
uh we have
we have tens of thousands of these cases
new coming in new every year i think you
heard um administrative judge king talk
about that or if you were here a week
ago monday he spoke to the numbers and
the cases that have been brought forward
um are almost equal to that
and and we have i think now 39 judges
handling those thousands of cases
and
these are difficult cases there is a lot
of emotion
and there are often people who
have concerns about the process who've
had a very difficult experience with the
process i understand that i've seen that
but
we need a way to
make orders
that
are going to promote
the children's best interests and we can
only do what we can with the tools that
we have and the evidence that's been
presented to us and apply the law to it
i mean that's the thing we have to apply
all of the factors under 461 a6 which
include evidence of of abuse and that
would be abuse of apparent abuse of a
child under the the child protection act
or domestic violence statute
um
i understand they're you're hearing very
very different stories all i can tell
you is is how we approach it from the
bench
i
truly believe it's not the vast majority
of the cases that we hear
but
i don't know how else to explain it to
you there are people who absolutely have
had a very difficult time with their own
case and their case is important
everyone's case is important every child
is important every parent going through
this process
if it were an ideal world we'd have more
judges we'd have more staff we'd have
more time to spend on each case
some cases that have been in existence
for a long time
and and maybe some of these folks here
have cases like this they have
pleadings and pleadings over years and
they've been involved in the court
system for a long time and and it's just
it's horrible
if we could all spend as much time as
i'm fortunate to be able to do on this
particular docket at this time
across the state
maybe we could help these parties more
help these children more but we do what
we can with the resources that we have
and i i've also had success stories i
have had great success stories with
children who may have
had for whatever reason
a strained relationship with a parent
then go on to have a very strong
relationship you heard earlier
talk of what happens in child abuse
neglect cases and for four years sitting
full time in dover that was almost my
entire caseload was child abuse and
neglect and termination of parental
rights cases and they were so difficult
but
we always always always worked towards
reunifying the child or children with
the parent or parents
and that by law is what we have to do
that's that's the original plan starting
out and whatever the issue was that
brought the
the parties before us whatever the
conditions were that led to a finding of
abuse or neglect they have 12 months to
correct those conditions whether it's if
it's substance abuse
they get into a recovery program they
have services that are provided and we
encourage them we meet with them on a
periodic basis and
and
often counseling is involved as you can
imagine in that process and has to be
with a child that may have been
subjected to
some very serious trying things
if if we were straight out flat out
precluded from ordering counseling or or
what is being called reunification
counseling here
what would we do in cases like that
in those cases once they close they go
into
the regular parenting or divorce
docket because they need to have a
parenting plan then if if the child is
reunified and if they don't have orders
presently in effect and they're in
separate households they need court
orders to help them going forward
and we
likely are going to have counseling
continue in those cases if we can and
the parents are probably going to want
it the children are going to need it and
and we can't be precluded from ordering
it if it's truly appropriate and in the
child's best interests
um again
these
the reunification protocol i spoke about
is expensive it is i understand that
and so we do
consider what parents are able to afford
if they can't afford it it's not going
to work if they if they don't agree to
it at the outset it's not going to work
i saw something about um
not wanting
one parent to choose a counselor perhaps
for a child or what do you do if the
parties
have joint decision-making
responsibility meaning they're supposed
to speak to each other and reach an
agreement before they make major
decisions like putting a child in
counseling what does one parent do if
they really want their child in
counseling and the other parent just
won't agree won't respond even
make a court order
disregards the court order what do you
do
in that case that parent brings that to
the court's attention and we might make
an order that allows that parent the the
ability to
provide a counselor for that child
every case is very fact driven
and we just have to pay particular
attention to the facts in that case and
what the child in that case needs
and what the parents are able
to do
not only financially but otherwise are
they able to communicate are they able
to agree if not how do we do that
i i'm not going to just pick a counselor
for a party or a child
i'm i'm going to get them to refer to
other professionals who might know that
child pediatrician is a great one
that's someone that should be able to
make that referral
um
i i can't
i can't say what every judge has done
um but i can tell you that that i and
and
and my colleagues that i know i've been
on the bench for a long time with
working in these cases caring about
these cases about the parties that
appear before us and the children
we're just striving to do what's in the
child's best interest
and i fear i've been talking too long
and i don't want to i don't want to keep
you longer than that i'm welcome thank
you
we don't take questions from the
audience
thank you
there'll be no interaction please
but thank you thank you so much any
further questions from the committee
uh we really appreciate your time you've
given us
a a plethora of knowledge uh we we
appreciate that
uh and thank you for taking the time out
of your day to to come here you've had a
very long day too well thank you thank
you for your thank you committee it's
very important thank you
and uh that was supposed to be our final
speaker however i do have one more pink
card vivian
um
girard 30 seconds and i will hold you to
the 30 seconds that's quite all right i
just wanted to say thank you you you
sound like a very good judge um i wasn't
going to discuss this bill but at this
point
just to give you a quick little heads up
here on based on my case which you've
all heard my case all day long today
being the silva v silva
my
income has been compromised through
child support as you all know
so right now our lifestyles are not
equal and by a parent
who keeps spending more money on the
children and buying them the things that
they want
is very damaging on a relationship like
mine with my daughter
my children right now my relationship
has been so damaged that i don't think
i'll ever be the same so i think by
this bill
i obviously think that some of it has to
be modified to a certain degree to make
sure that it is covered by insurance but
for what has happened in my life and
trying to alienate me from my children
it is not that in the best interest of
my children
and this actually has abused not only
the system through harassment of all of
these years the seven years that i've
been in the system but it's also mental
abuse on my children so at this point in
into your um to your point exactly is
now i have to go back through um the
court to ask for therapy
for my children so now i'm in the same
situation as you guys are here right now
thank you any questions you're very
welcome any questions
seeing none thank you and thank you for
speeding it up i appreciate it i know
it's important
no what you have to say is important and
we want to hear it
and
with that i have no more pink cards
um
on 11.99 i will close the hearing on
11.99
do you need a few minutes
okay
i will
open the hearing um
on house bill 1515
and i'm sure that representative gay is
going to send a pink card up
with some testimony
any more pink cards final call
thank you representative gay
uh the amendment is short and the actual
even though the uh bill looks long it
only has
three things in it they just put the
entire build entire rsa there or several
and then so there's just uh
let's see there's four little things
here
so if you want to look at your bill
go to page two
this is about
uh if you're
well there are multiple multiple things
about dealing with your gal
so number one one some of the issues
that i've been told about by people who
are very unhappy were that
they had the gal who wasn't treating
both parents equally and their real
concern is supposed to be the children
so they shouldn't be
favoring a parent over the other parent
they should be gathering in
information about alls
another problem with guardian ad litems
right now is that they can bill
without
specifying what they're billing for or
how many hours it was or
uh when you just
all of a sudden you get a bill and
you've got to pay it or else you're
going to be
in trouble
uh and then it also as this bill also
addresses the issue that when you have a
gl that you think is doing things that
are underhanded you really don't have
anybody but the gal board to report them
to and statistically
their response is really
about
zero so on page two
uh line thirteen
the guardian at lightham in the course
of their appointment shall offer to meet
with both parties
simultaneously with each party
separately or any combination of those
options for equal amounts of time
so they're not spending
you know
seventy percent of their time with one
and thirty with the other or worse
then on line uh nineteen
when appointing a guardian at lighting
to be paid from a state fund the court
shall establish an hourly rate in
writing and a maximum fee see that's
paid from a state fund you're not going
to be a state fund
which shall not exceed the hourly rate
maximum established by court rule for
abuse and neglect cases you may not be
in an abuse in a net neglect place so we
need to protect
everybody
so they don't get surprise billing
then
line 23 when appointing guardian let him
to be paid directly by the parties the
hourly rate
this is the ad
in writing
so if you're going to pay a guardian
item you need to be notified in writing
what rate you're going to be paid
being paid and the maximum fee for the
appointment
and then it has some restrictions on how
much it is however
the judge can change this rate they can
increase it so you're not it's not
fixed uh fixed by state law
let's see the fees for services of the
guardian item and others utilized by the
guardian and
and others used utilized by the guardian
and approved by court shall be a charge
against the parties
this is the ad
in an itemized bill which may be
requested by any party at any time you
might want to ask before it's over what
they're charging
so during you can ask at any time during
the garden atlanta's appointment and
which shall be paid upon the conclusion
the guardian ad litem services
then the amendment is to page
three
the line that we're
amending is
lie on six
as it reads originally the party shall
have the right to approve refuse or
report to the appropriate licensing
board the illegal behavior of an
appointed guardian at lotum or other
appointed counselor at any time
the amendment says
since so many people have said when they
did appeal to the guardian at lightham
uh
the
the board the i'm sorry i'm not saying
the right name i can't remember what
it's called but they're part of
licensing they have a subset of the
licensing of of our state
they've said they are not getting any
kind of response so
my amendment to the amendment says the
party shall have the right to approve
refuse or report to the appropriate
licensing board the illegal behavior of
an appointed guardian at leidem or other
appointed counselor at any time
if there is no satisfactory response
within 28 business days the parties may
refile their complaint to a higher
appellate or reviewing licensing board
or court
that's it
thank you
any questions
representative blanchard
thank you madam chair thank you
representative gabe for being here today
again on our last bill today
um
are you aware of
house bill 1520
uh is that your bill it is
follow up
so specifically i'm very keen on clean
bills that are very cut and dry and to
the point
so
15 20
seeks to and i quote which has not been
heard in this committee the guardian of
items shall provide an itemized bill to
the paying party
and all parties representative
we're discussing 15 15 we're not
discussing any other bill i'm getting to
my point thank you representative
you you and representative rice do that
to me all the time well sir you have to
stay on the subject at hand
and all parties shall have the right to
request the itemized bill for review
cut and drying to the point
would you be would you
cutting and drying to the point be
willing to come forward to this
committee with amendment that focused on
the non-billing requirements so that
that may be brought up in a different
hearing
yes i i would
really like our bills to be merged so we
cover all the points with one bill
instead of multiples
no further question
follow-up
okay no further question
representative altschiller thank you
thank you representative gate i just
don't have the amendment did that go
around
it has
there are copies all right thank you
somewhere here
any further questions for representative
gay
thank you very much representative and i
appreciate the fact that you have extra
amendments for us
the next person i'll call is angela
lozier
ms lozier you've asked for 20 minutes
yes
no you asked for 20 minutes
god bless you but you're gonna get two
as are we
but we'll work together to get this done
yes much appreciated thank you um
um again my name is angela lozier for
the record
you have heard several testimonies for
me today one on tuesday
the 11th on shared parenting
a few things about my gal
one was the billing and how she spent
[Music]
more time with one house than the other
i received one of her bills during the
court proceeding and the other one
was until
excuse me
six months after the final hearing
at this time i discovered she had spent
you know significant more time speaking
with stella via zoom
um when my daughter was with her father
kathleen also spoke again about my to my
ex and his wife that i was unaware of
not only did she ask for weekly updates
from him after the the status hearing
and removing her from my custody
um
let's see i'm trying to glimpse it over
for you
[Music]
i don't need to go over that
after the status hearing um kathleen
asked for weekly updates with my ex
which consisted of more construed
allegations about me and my scheduled
time with our daughter and no point
during those weekly updates to kathleen
ever follow up with me regarding these
allegations
i was asked for an update on january
13th
before our final hearing
i stated my concerns and
answered kathleen's questions kathleen
immediately emailed my ex to ask him to
explain
the concerns i had but she had not
done the same for me
i wasn't given the same opportunity
this bill is concerning um the
procedures for guardians that light him
in the family corporate seatings
could specifically the billing
okay can we stay with that please sure
you have one more minute okay
um
i guess i wish i would have been aware
of um
on the bill you get an itemized yeah not
only how much is she charging but how
she's
spending her time
you don't discover these things until
maybe 24 hours before court i got her
file
um but like i said her final bill i
didn't get until six six months after my
final hearing which if i wanted to
um
proceed forth i don't know whatever way
i would have wanted to i i feel like
it's been so much time why reopen it
um so i guess
billing is definitely important to know
and keep maybe an updated um
on both parents not keeping it from the
other
so thank you no thank you
any questions
seeing none
thank you for your time next i'll call
on uh dan it'sa
honorable
dan you're asking for five minutes in
the interest of time can we squish it to
maybe two and a half i'll do my absolute
best thank you uh
for the record i'm dan it's i still
reside in manchester uh 12 years ago i
was vice chair of the committee to
review the gal audit
and the legislation that you see here
was one of the products of that in
2013-14 i forget particularly
um
one thing that i would add to
the legend to the law as it stands now
page one line twenty three
the guardian item has to report their uh
investigation
at at the pre-trial hearing i think it
would be beneficial to the parties if
there were some additional period like
five days before
the pre the pre-trial hearing so they
know what they're expecting
um
as to uh billing the
the
rate is essentially set by the state
because it's all keyed to the rate set
for abuse in the neglect cases so that's
the benchmark
and then for those privately paying
there are no state payees right now uh
because there's no fund for private
payees the rate can be no more than
twice that
and it can't exceed more than 23 hours
unless they agree i think it would be
very beneficial to insert after they
agree that the gal or the parties or the
court has to say 23 hours plus 20 hours
plus 40 hours so that everybody knows
what they're getting into no blank
checks
that's a real problem
um
i would go on
under uh now it is it was the intent of
the committee
that once the gal's contract appointment
expired there was no more work done
there was no more billing that was all
the parents were obligated to
and that is from what i hear not the
case
that the that the guardian items
activities continue after the
appointment in some cases
and uh be and
that some judges require those
additional fees to be paid
i think you should strengthen section
five roman numeral five
and make it clear that the parties are
not responsible once the appointment
expires
if the gao wants to work then it's on
them it's donated work
um
and
that's it i'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you
any questions
thank you so much for your time i
appreciate you
squishing it down
the next person will be
dana albrecht
thank you madam chair again for the
record dana albrecht national hampshire
and thank you for helping to move this
along
is a very brief preliminary matter i
just want to make sure that the copy of
this page 2
lines 13 to 15
speaking
to
uh
equal amounts of time
that something
like that is still in whatever
or similar to it whatever version we're
discussing now because i don't have the
most recent
uh and also the same for billing down in
28 30 so i do speak to the bill
uh just as a one more very brief
preliminary matter i just want to echo
uh rep belanger's comment about
he's hearing
this
from
the judge all wonderful things and this
from the parties and how do we get from
here
to here
so you might get just a couple sentences
that mixed in to address these two
portions of the bill
so i'm just gonna
um kathleen sternenberg
in my case
uh
i'm one of the nine
uh essentially heavy heavily favored uh
my ex in terms of how much time she sent
i would go so far as to say she acted
almost as her second counsel
and i believe the written transcript of
her testimony uh the gal testimony uh
presented last tuesday to this committee
would support that so again i think
that's speaking to equal amounts of time
and
non-bias
um
in terms of billing
she charged over ten thousand dollars in
fees for her investigation
uh
to relocation to california
when the maximum written fee cap i ever
got was four thousand dollars
um at the time
i
didn't know any better but i think the
you know billing in here is speaking to
that
um in terms of equal
amounts of time i just might suggest to
say something about references as well
because i found that she
spent a whole lot more time speaking to
mom's references than mine
um
and
just to kind of wrap this all up and
close in terms of what happened here
with meeting the time
in the billing if
by law we're supposed to promote a
healthy relationship with both parents
i would just have to ask
in my case
how a gal
moving the kids all around the country
does that in charging
ten thousand dollars for it
you know what's going on here and that's
just to kind of close with the gulf once
again between
rep belanger
and
her honor how do we get from here to
here
and happy to take any questions
thank you
any questions
seeing none thank you very much
next we have eric brand
you're asking for five minutes can we
squish it down to two and a half please
yes thank you
thank you madam chair and committee
members
um you've heard many bills between today
and last week as well
um
i
i'm in support of 1515 and possibly
representative belanger's bill as well
but with a modification that i didn't
see in either one of these though i
haven't read your complete bill yet
we all know from some of the happenings
in the nashua court system
that there can be a conflict of interest
that can arise
i believe
like to believe all judges in the
systems are very good judges
but we've seen that there are some that
are not
if we were to add in
a lottery system
into the appointments of guardian items
this may help many families feel
comfortable and not feel that somebody's
just hiring a friend such as what's
happened in nashua now what i mean by a
lottery system if we all think back to
when we had the housing
uh real estate crash back in 0.708
there were a lot of appraisals that were
going on it was a lot of
bankers loan officers that were leaning
over to their friends and saying hey i
need an appraisal that's going to match
what this house is selling for can you
get it for me and if that friend
wouldn't do it they'd go to another one
so then the states moved into this
lottery system where the appraisals were
then appointed
and that took away
that whole flaw within that system
if we were to add in something within
these bills or maybe there's an
additional bill that's added in
that could hopefully change this and
regain some confidence from some
families that don't have confidence with
how the guardian middle items are
appointed
this all ties back into what we spoke
about last week with the 50 50 shared
parenting
if we start with the 50 50 shared
parenting there's going to be a lot less
guardian items that are going to be
needed and appointed
because as i've testified once before
and this is one sentence here that i
still believe that each parent
brings to each child being raised a
substantial amount of
characteristics and helps form that
child and when you take one parent away
and make them in every other weekend
parent it doesn't make that child whole
thank you
thank you very much any questions
thank you thank you
next i have gail
drew boot
i'm so sorry
drawbat it looks like a u
when you write it it looks like a you
that's why
gail drobat
so can i speak to the um
last part the party she'll have the
right to approve refuse a report to the
appropriate licensing board the illegal
behaviors
[Music]
of an appointed guardian ad litem
again i'm not personally in the court
system i have spoken to many parents
over the years so i advocate for them
but this one particular case
kathleen sternberg allied with the mom
dad has not seen the child in four years
the egregious behaviors of kathleen
sternenberg
in many many cases
are affecting children in this state
here's his complaint to the guardian ad
litem board
i just received on december 27th
they there was no finding
of um
violations on her they said under 50302
they found no
violations under 50302c
says she is to
follow her order on appointment
from the court she did not do that she
did not go to dad's house
she did not meet with dad and the child
how is it possible they have found no
wrong doing
and where do you go from here
like
there's got to be
somewhere for these parents to go
it's been to the jcc it's been to the
attorney discipline office
this child is in
turmoil he's got 125 behavioral
referrals
the courts will not address his mental
emotional state
and
kathleen failed this child
she concealed important information she
concealed 87 behavioral referrals in
fourth grade alone
from the court she concealed
inappropriate behaviors in the mother's
care from the court
there's no
where for these parents to go to protect
their children
so i just this is important that
there's another board where you can go
to
to report these people
to protect children in this state and
we've all seen
the news where national news now for
abusing children this is going to stop
these children need to be protected in
this state
um
thank you i mean that's
that's going to be important to all of
us and
where we are failing our children
any questions
no questions seeing none thank you for
your testimony
next i have anna goulet zimmerman
madam chair members of the committee i
am still anna goulet zimmerman i
practice law in manchester new hampshire
and i am a member of the new hampshire
association for justice
i signed in a pose but that may be the
wrong word i more just have just several
concerns about the wording on this and i
wasn't even planning on testifying about
this one but since i've been here all
afternoon i figured i'd stay for it
um
first part is this additional
requirement of equal amounts of time i
understand the sentiment where that's
coming behind
but there are lots of reasons why time
might not be equal
that is not necessarily because
someone's biased
i'm going to give you an example of me
and my husband who are fortunately not
before guardian ad litem and not getting
divorced but if you ask either of us to
tell a story it takes me about five
times as long as it takes him i say he's
missing a lot of context he thinks i'm
adding a lot of stuff that really
doesn't matter but that's just how
people are so some people are going to
have the exact same they're going to
have a harder time formulating their
thoughts maybe they're rambling more
maybe they're a little less organized
where someone else is like here it is
it doesn't mean there's there's bias you
can of course on cross-examination if
you think these issues have come up you
can say well look you went to this house
you spent this much time with the kids
there how come you didn't come to this
house so there is a way to address those
issues um
as far as evidence the guardian i mean
it feels a little like today we're we're
more talking about is there a problem
with a guardian ad litem which of course
is not what this statute and the leg you
know is is to address
i have no issue with itemized bills i
think that's fine um
which shall be paid upon the conclusion
of the guardian ad litem services i do
have an issue with never been a guardian
ad litem but you've heard today people
talk to you about cases that are going
on for seven years and if guardians
aren't going to be paid until the very
end of their cases it's hard enough to
get guardian ad litems they ought to be
paid as they're going along for the work
they're doing
there is under section five already a
provision for the maximum fee and you
have to go to the court they have to ask
for additional sufficient say they need
the additional fees
and and have that approved so i'm just
i'm confused as to why
there needs to be kind of duplication of
that or why that's an ongoing issue
um the last thing is the section seven
there's already a right to report
illegal behavior i i don't know what
we're trying to add here except maybe
get even more complaints against
guardian adult items i also don't
understand the language you know if i
take out the some of the words the right
to approve to the appropriate licensing
board the right to refuse to the
appropriate licensing board i don't even
know what that means
i mean i get the the right to approve
report to but i don't know why we have
approve and refuse in there
and
this notion this additional thing of if
there's no satisfactory response i'm
sure this has already come to
everybody's on this committee's thought
but obviously there's going to need to
be a fiscal note because you're talking
about creating an entire new division i
would suggest uh with great deference to
the parties that are here today i
understand that family law can be a very
very difficult process to go through
um
but that if a complaint has been to the
guardian light on board and the
professional conduct committee and
reviewed by the court and everyone has
said there's nothing there maybe there
isn't a need for another board who will
also review those complaints so thank
you for your time thank you any
questions
seeing none
thank you very much for your time
next is katrina henrik
thank you all for your time
it's been a long day for everybody so i
just wanted to thank you
um i i left my glasses back there so
please bear with me for a moment
oh thanks thanks thanks i knew that was
gonna be the issue by the end of the day
okay
all right now that we've had comic
relief
um
so on this basically i'm just going to
cover a few quick points that's it
i don't think we need to
to extend too much on this one
i reiterate from my previous statements
not just this testimony but the
testimony of the past 12 years that i've
provided to the committees
the gao is a private citizen with
immunity
and he is for hire
in my case
the discovery process of the divorce
which ended his appointment
showed the wealth that was there to get
the gal spent a significant amount of
time post-divorce even possibly
pre-divorce
with the other party
the gal testified
toward the end of our 12 years
when my daughter was kidnapped out of
the state
he testified to the last three years of
her life when he had no contact with her
so the discrepancies in what's actually
happening
and what we know people can do
or should be doing
is quite great in about 20 of the cases
i lost one of my points i apologize
for me personally i got
no record despite repeated requests of
all the billing
i never got any billing records at all
from him
i never got any
records after repeated requests of his
file
it is my understanding we're allowed to
have that
i have yet to be provided for it
i don't know i cannot tell you what his
true total was that he accumulated in 12
years
including the two years that i
previously mentioned in my case summary
that he functioned post-divorce
immediately post-divorce was functioning
with the court and never reappointed
but the court allowed all of it
regardless
so there are discrepancies and i'd like
to believe that everybody is there for
the right purposes
but in my case
everything went completely sideways
when it comes to the guardian at
lightham
i think they're an evil necessity with a
double-edged sword
they are not a casa
guardian item
so i think the billing when you're
talking about a private contractor is
very very critical to be overseen
to avoid
undermining the court process and our
belief in the system
with that said i'm going to end today
and i
god you guys have a great night
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much
and our final although she
gave us two cards
you only get two minutes
and that would be vivian gerard
sorry it is a long day here
i appreciate you guys taking the time to
um meet with us
so in this particular bill i do support
it because i see the effects that it had
on me my friends and their children
during my divorce in 2014 the court
family court ordered a gal
my experience was concerning
as my gal tried to pull my children away
from me based on a false police report
divorce with or without children is
stressful a gal has many influences on
the future of your children and is
unnecessary in many
cases in my case
my gal was very biased
she did not have equal visits to both
homes
she did not look into the false police
report
she did not look into the false dcyf
reports
i was fortunate that i didn't have the
outcomes that could have very easily and
negatively impacted
my time with my daughters and the
decisions
i hope that i will never have to go
through a gal again
but based on the harassment that i've
i've experienced it scares me to death
because i probably will end up back in
court again
my friends behind me here today
you have heard their testimony it's very
concerning to say the least
they are just a few of what
few that have been traumatized but
a
gal my hope is that with all the
testimonies that all of us shared this
will make an impact on the family court
these laws will help our children lead a
better life
unfortunately you cannot
report on any of the gals
reports or concerns until your case is
closed by then it's too late
so please stop gals like kathleen
sternberg from making the children
victims by pulling
a parent
away from a child
that's all i have thank you
thank you any questions
i see no questions i i just want to take
a minute to thank everybody here
who has brought us some very valuable
information
we obviously have our work
in front of us
to um
try to implement what you've said to
make these laws better and i thank you
for
sticking it out for the day it's been a
very long day and we do appreciate it
thank you
and with that i will close the hearing
on house bill 1515
have a nice day people
holy moly